BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A STATEMENT ON PROVIDING
TESTIMONY AT THIS HEARING- WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO START THE
HEARING UNTIL WE HAVE SOME MORE
MEMBERS PRESENT BUT- I DO WANNA
MAKE SOME. SOME REMARKS SO- ANY
WITNESS WHO DID NOT MAKE THE
REQUEST IN ADVANCE AND ARE NOT
ON OUR WITNESS LIST WILL BE
LIMITED TO NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. AND NO
EXCEPTIONS WILL BE MADE.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AFTER THE
MAIN WITNESS TESTIMONIES GIVEN
WILL BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF
TWENTY MINUTES FOR EACH BILL.
NO SAY THAT AGAIN. ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AFTER THE MAIN
WITNESS TESTIMONIES GIVEN. WILL
BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF TWENTY
MINUTES FOR EACH BILL. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION WE
HOPE AUTHORS AND STAKEHOLDERS
ARE RESPECTFUL OF THIS PROCESS.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME WATER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH OR PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. ROSS
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN IN
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE. IN THE ROOM OR AT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE WE DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS HERE TODAY WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER. OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
THAT SIXTIES SPACING. THERE ARE
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN A
QUORUM IS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
OVER THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. I
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
HER ARE DONE TESTIFYING TO
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO WHAT. WELL ACTUALLY
COULD DO TWO AT A TIME NOW-
TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE TAKEN UP
IN THE ORDER LISTED ON THE
AGENDA AND THE DAILY FILE. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE MAY HAVE SOME
WITNESSES HUSING A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION HERE ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM.
AND ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IN THE DAILY
FILE AND ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO WELL BEFORE THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON
HIS BEGINNING THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED INTO THE QUEUE. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN ELIMINATED
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE WHICH
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM AND YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
YOUR WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL. YOUR MAIN ON THE LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED
UPON TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. CALLER
COMMITTEE AT THREE NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANNA NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORT POSITION
LETTER PORTAL WITH INSTRUCTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. ND
YOU CAN FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE
COMMITTEE THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILEALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE STILL
ALL FACE. IN FAIRNESS TO
EVERYONE WE WILL NEED TO BE
ESPECIALLY DISTRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS TODAY. WE WILL HEAR FROM
UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE
MINUTES EACH FOR EACH SIDE.
AFTER THE TWO MAIN WITNESSES
FOR EACH SIDE TESTAMENT TESTIFY
IF THERE ARE ANY. WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONES AND COMBINE THE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME.
ORGANIZATIONS THEY REPRESENT
ONE AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE WILL LIMIT ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON ANY BILL TO TWENTY
MINUTES- WE DO HAVE A SENATOR
SKINNER HAS ASKED THAT I AND I
HAVE AGREED TO ACCOMMODATE HER
BILLS OUT OF ORDER. WE WILL TRY
TO AND HEAR HER BILLS CLOSE TO
TWO FIFTEEN. AS CLOSE AS WE CAN
WE HAVE ONE BILL PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT TODAY. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB THREE SIXTEEN BY- SENATOR
EGGMAN. WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE
MEMBER TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA WILL BE
SUBSTITUTING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JOAQUIN ARAMBULA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY. SO WE
ARE. WAITING FOR REPUBLICAN
MEMBER- WHICH WE DON'T HAVE YET
SO UNTIL WE CAN WE CAN'T
CONVENE WE CAN'T START UNTIL WE
GET THERE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR PATIENCE SENATOR. YOU
DON'T COUNT ANYMORE SORRY. I
HAVE A QUESTION. HELLO YES I
WHAT I'M WEARING- ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS IT'S GONNA DO- WILL BE
TESTIFYING- SHE WE HAVE A
TRANSLATOR FOR HER AN
INTERPRETER I'M SORRY WOULD
THAT BE THREE MINUTES EACH OR
WHAT W. THREE MINUTES- TOTAL
INCLUDING THE INTERPRETATION.
ARE WE WILL EITHER SEE I CAN I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE
THERE WE'RE WE WILL DO OUR BEST
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
THERE'S A CHALLENGE ON THE
TESTIMONY AND WITH THE
TRANSLATOR AND DO OUR BEST TO
ACCOMMODATE I APPRECIATED. THE
QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. MAYBES IN THE LOUNGE THE
JUST GRABBED ONE ANYBODY. THE
PROVIDING. I THINK RESTATE IT
IF SOMEONE COULD IF SOMEONE
JUST COME IN AND JUST BE HERE
LONG ENOUGH TO SEE. WHAT WE
CAN'T START TO HAVE A
REPUBLICAN PRESS. IS THE LEAST
SHOWN UP SO. YEAH YEAH. HE'S
COME IN BUT HE WILL BE HERE
HE'S HE'S GONNA BE CITIES COULD
BE A LITTLE LATE ALSO. THE
THREE MEMBER. THREE PRIMARY.
FOR- THE HALL JUST. JUST JUST
WANT TO SPUR LIKE WALK IN JUST
YEAH. WAVE.
ASSEMBLY HELPED
MANY.
WE HAD ENOUGH. HEY WE CAN
NOW- GO AHEAD AND BEGIN OUR
HEALTH COMMITTEE HERE WE'RE
GONNA BE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO SENATOR BATES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YEAH BUT
THE- THANKS. THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN WOULD AND MEMBERS ARE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN IF A SIMPLE
BILL TO CONTINUE A SUCCESSFUL
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN. THAT
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
ALMOST A DECADE FOR THE STATE'S
BIOTECH INDUSTRY. SMALL BIOTECH
COMPANIES MUST COMPETE FOR
SCIENTISTS AMONG THE LARGE WELL
ESTABLISHED COMPANIES. SB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN WAS INTRODUCED TO
ENSURE THAT THE SMALL COMPANIES
CAN DO JUST THAT. INDEED ENABLE
FOR BIOTECH ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PAN TO CONTINUE. BIOTERROR AS
YOU KNOW IS UNIQUELY CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IT HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL TO OUR ABILITY TO
RECOVER FROM THE DEVASTATION OF
THE COVE A PANDEMIC. DUE TO ITS
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT AND THERAPY
RESEARCH THOSE SCIENTISTS AND
THEIR SUPPORT TEAMS WHO HAVE
BEEN LABORED TO BRING US. THESE
INNOVATIONS DESERVE THE BEST
HEALTH CARE OF THEMSELVES AND
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE JUST
THAT. I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO ADDISON
SAID IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. PLATINUM QUALITY
HEALTHCARE TO BUY TECH
EMPLOYEES AND BUILD A STRONGER
BIOTECH INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH VIACOM CALIFORNIA AND
THE LEGISLATURE. SO THIS HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE PROGRAM CAN
CONTINUE LONG INTO THE FUTURE.
WITH ME TODAY OR TOMORROW TOP
REPRESENTING VIACOM CALIFORNIA
AND TODD BENNETT WITH MARSH AND
MCLENNAN INSURANCE AGENCY THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE BIO
CONTRAST TO PRESENT THEIR
COMMENTS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO SENATOR BATES I
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY-
TO OUR MODERATOR. AFTERNOON OUR
DOCTOR WOULDN'T MEMBERS I AM
ONLY ROOFTOP HERE ON BEHALF OF
CAL FIRE CONTROL FORMULA THE
SPONSORS OF SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN.
WE ARE STATEWIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF LIFE SCIENCE
COMPANIES. THE LIFE SCIENCE
INDUSTRY IS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRUE HOME GROWN INDUSTRIES.
WHILE MANY THINK OF THE LARGE
WELL ESTABLISHED COMPANIES IN
THIS SPACE. IT IS THE SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED COMPANIES THAT
HELP DRIVE MEDICAL DISCOVERY.
SOMETHING WE HAVE ALL SEEN
FIRST HAND. WHAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CODED VACCINES
WHICH BEGAN EXPRESSING IDEAS
AND SMALLER BIOTECH COMPANIES.
HOWEVER THESE COMPANIES MUST
COMPETE WITH THE LARGER
COMPANIES FOR TALENT AT ALL
LEVELS. BECAUSE THEY OPERATE IN
A HIGHLY COMPETITIVE LABOR
MARKET THEY MUST OFFER HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO ATTRACT TOP QUALITY
TALENT. TO ADDRESS HIS NEED BY
A COMMA ESTABLISHED A HEALTH
CARE TRACK. SPECIFICALLY FOR
ITS SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED LIFE
SCIENCE COMPANIES. IT'S
BENEFITS ARE HIGH QUALITY AND
ARE AVAILABLE TO NOT JUST THE
MOST EXPERIENCED SCIENTISTS BUT
TO ALL THE EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
ENROLLED COMPANY INCLUDING
ENTRY LEVEL CLERKS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT. OUR
PLAN PREDATED THE FULL ROLLOUT
OF THE ACA. AND NEED HELP
PLANTS HAVE BEEN REGISTERED
WITH THE US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
AS FULLY COMPLIANT WITH THE
PLAN THIS ENTIRE TIME. WE
RECOGNIZED THE CONCERN ABOUT
CERTAIN ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT PROVIDE
SUBPAR INSURANCE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES OR ARE NOT FULLY
INSURED. WHICH IS WHY SB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN WHICH CRAFTED TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED. IT IS OFTEN NARROWLY
CRAFTED TO ENSURE THAT IT WOULD
NOT RESULT IN ANY FLIGHT FROM
THE SMALL EMPLOYER GROUP MARKET.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
IN MEDIUM SIZED COMPANIES
WITHIN THE BY A CONTRACT. WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONNECT ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR WOULD MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TODD BENNETT AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THE BEYOND BENEFITS
TRUST AND SHARE SOME IMPORTANT
MECHANICS OF THE PROGRAM. FIRST
MUCH LIKE SMALL BUSINESS HEALTH
INSURANCE IN CALIFORNIA. STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE BUILT
INTO THE STRUCTURE OF THE ON
BENEFITS. AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO OFFER A VERY STABLE PROGRAM%
TO LIVE. THE LIFE SCIENCES AND
BIOTECH PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS.
THIS INDUSTRY DEMANDS THE MOST
TALENTED MINDS AND THEREFORE
EMPLOYERS DESIRE TO OFFER RICH
BENEFITS. THAT MEET AND EXCEED
COVERAGE FOR BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AN ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFIT. WHICH ARE INCLUDED IN
ALL THE PLANS OFFERED THROUGH
THE PROGRAM. BECAUSE CLAIMS
DATA IS PROVIDED IN THE DE
IDENTIFIED AGGREGATE FORMAT
IT'S NOT MADE AVAILABLE FOR
EACH SEPARATE EMPLOYER OR
INDIVIDUAL AND BEYOND BENEFITS.
THEREFORE WE CAN'T CHERRY PICK
WHICH EMPLOYERS JOINT BEYOND
THAT. WE ALSO CAN'T REQUIRE
THEM TO LEAVE THE PROGRAM BASED
ON HEALTH STATUS. ON ADULT
STATUS OF THEIR EMPLOYEE
POPULATION. AND ONE UNIFORMITY
WILL IS PROVIDED TO ALL
EMPLOYERS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
COMPANIES HEALTH STATUS. EVEN
AS A FULLY INSURED PROGRAM
WHERE THE CARRIER HOLDS ALL THE
RICH BEYOND BENEFITS HAS BEEN
SAVVY ENOUGH TO BUILD A
RESERVE. WHICH WE CAN USE TO
HELP OFFSET FUTURE ANNUAL
INCREASES FOR THE PROGRAM AS A
WHOLE. TO FURTHER BENEFIT
PARTICIPANTS THE BEYOND
BENEFITS TRUST HAS SUCCESSFULLY
NEGOTIATED STREAMLINED
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN
COMPARISON. TO THE TRADITIONAL
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE. AND
CONSISTENTLY LOWER THAN TRAINED
RENEWALS. IN ROMAN FROM SMALL
GROUP EMPLOYERS AND BEYOND
BENEFITS REPRESENTS JUST ONE
HALF OF A PERCENT OF THE TWO
POINT THREE MILLION INDIVIDUALS
AND CALIFORNIA SMALL GROUP
INSURANCE MARKETS. ALLOWING THE
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE WILL ALLOW
YOU IT WILL ALLOW US ALL TO
HELP SOLVE THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THIS INDUSTRY. OFFERING THIS
PROGRAM STATISTICALLY AND
ACTUARIALLY DOES NOT
DESTABILIZE THE EXISTING
INSURANCE MARKET NOR DOES THE
DEBATE THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT TO US ALL.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SINCE OUR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY REGISTERED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT WILL JUST BE ASKING FOR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL A SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY WISHES TO. TESTIFY
IN THIS BILL. SEE NO ONE WILL
NOT GO BACK TO YOU MADAM MADAM
OPERATOR AND PLEASE. HAVE A
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON SB. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. THE WOMAN FEATURE WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE KEEP PEOPLE
QUEUING UP AT THE MOMENT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN MAYBE
YOU'RE ON MUTE. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER OR ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
SEVEN ZERO. BY ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS EILEEN
PRIDE AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE CELL I'M FROM
KERN COUNTY AND OWN PROPERTY IN
PREGNANT COUNTY AS WELL. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THE
TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. CNN WE
CAN'T MOVE THE BILL AT THIS
POINT WE'RE STILL WAITING TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. I WILL THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME OF A- TO PRESENT THE
BILL. CERTAINLY I IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ARE EXPERT WITNESSES
ARE AVAILABLE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK IN APPRECIATE AN AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU DO HAVE QUORUM.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND WE
HAVE QUORUM WILL BRING IT UP
FOR A VOTE SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR SENATOR
BRADFORD NEXT THE- NEXT STEP
HERE. YOU HAVE SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY ONE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SIR. DO NOT TOUCH
MICROPHONE I WON'T. THANK YOU
MISSED YOUR I'M HERE TO
PRESENT- SB FOG TWO ONE. WHAT
IF WE SIMPLY ENSURES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS CLARITY AND THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE AND SIGN
MEDICARE AL DRUG REBATE
CONTRACTS FOR NEW TYPES OF-
CONTRACTS CALLED VALUE BASED
PURCHASING AGREEMENTS THESE
CONTRACTS CAN SPECIFY PAYMENTS
OVER TIME BASED ON AGREED UPON
OUTCOMES. SO ITS RESULTS
ORIENTED IN OTHER WORDS OF
TREATMENT IF IT DOESN'T WORK
THEN THAT MEANS THAT- MAC CAL
CAN BE. REIMBURSED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT A ONE TIME
TRANSFORM TO GENE THERAPIES AND
MANY OTHER INNOVATIVE
TREATMENTS ON THE HORIZON
MANUFACTURES AND- PAYERS ARE
LOOKING FOR NEW WAYS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT TO INCREASE
PATIENT SUCCESS ACCESS I SHOULD
SAY I MANAGED. A FINANCIAL
RISKS AND MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY THIS BILL
PREPARES CALIFORNIA MATAGAL
DRUG REBATE PROGRAM FOR PATIENT
ACCESS FOR. TO TREATMENT BEING
DEVELOPED THAT MAY ONE DAY BE
ABLE TO CURES. DISEASES SUCH AS
SICKLE CELL ANEMIA OTHER STATES
ARE ALREADY DOING THIS WATCH A
MASSACHUSETTS ARIZONA TEXAS
JUST TO NAME A FEW- WHO'VE
ALREADY PROVIDED AMENDMENT
PLANS THAT HAVE. PROVIDED VALUE
BASED PURCHASE AGREEMENTS FOR
THEIR MEDICAID PROGRAMS SB FIVE
TO ONE PUTS US ON TRACK TO
ENSURE PATIENTS AND OTHER
DOCTORS CAN ACCESS THESE LIFE
CHANGING TREATMENTS AS SOON AS.
THEY ARE- BECOME AVAILABLE-
HERE JUST TO IS JOHN VALENCIAN
BEHALF OF BLUEBIRD BIO. THANK
YOU BEFORE WE TAKE TESTIMONY WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SO I'M GOING
TO ASK OR SECRETARY TO PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE. WHERE HERE.
MAYES HERE ARE YOUR CURRENT.
GARCIA. BIGELOW BURKE. CAREER
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. WALDRON. WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM YEAH
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL GO AHEAD NOW- MISTER
BRADFORD MOVE ON PERCENT RECORD
KEEPING- TO YOUR WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN JOHN
VALENCIA HERE ON BEHALF OF
BLUEBIRD BIO. WE WANT TO THANK
A CENTER BRADFORD FOR ADVANCING
PUBLIC POLICY. THAT WILL IN THE
FUTURE THAI. DRUG OUTCOMES TO
REIMBURSEMENT AND STATUS ON THE
MEDICAL FORMULAR WE THINK THIS
IS A COMMONLY HELD GOLDEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE AMONG INDUSTRY.
IN THE FUTURE FOR EXAMPLE IF A
DRUG FAILS TO PRODUCE AN AGREED
UPON OUTCOME. A CLINICAL
OUTCOME VALUE BASED CONTRACT
COULD TRIGGER A REFUND OR OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE STATE. CENTER BRADFORD'S SB
FIVE TWENTY ONE UPDATES A
DECADES OLD LAW THAT WILL
PROVIDE AUTHORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TO FLEXIBLY NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS
WITH INDUSTRY TO THE BETTERMENT
OF PATIENTS AND MEDICAL WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE
A WITNESS ON THE TELEPHONE-
MARC TRICIA I AM FROM- CO BIO
CONSULTING. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HE'S NOT ON THE PHONE WE SHOWN
TO BE IN PERSON- WELL. I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T HAVE ON THE PHONE
OKAY WE DON'T HAVE THEM ON THE
PHONE WE DID HAVE SOMEBODY HERE
IN PERSON I DO KNOW WE DO HAVE
SOMEBODY FOR AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SO I GUESS
AT THIS POINT I WILL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND IF THE
OTHER WITNESS OF ARRIVES WILL
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
TESTIMONY SO- PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST NAME AND
POSITION. ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER. AND
THEN PLACE IT BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SICKLE CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I NUMBER TWO OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO ME FAN
ON BEHALF OF CRISPR
THERAPEUTICS IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BRIAN
WARREN WITH THE BIOTECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS HOLDING UP THE
LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
AMANDA WHITE HOUSE AND I'M AT
RIDGECREST PREGNANCY CARE
CENTER AND I'M IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY I'M NOT SURE THAT'S THE
RIGHT BILL BUT- YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CALL BACK LATER I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE BILL BUT-
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM- FOR
THIS BILL. I AM BALLOT MARKING
FROM TEN O'CLOCK AM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BERMAN IS THE CHAIR WE
HAVE SOMEONE OF QUEUING UP AT
THE MOMENT OKAY. MY NUMBER TWO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER TWO TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE AUTHOR. SEVEN WE HAVE A
MOTION WE HAD A MUCH BY MISTER
MASON SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY- NO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER BRADFORD
LIKE CLOSE CENTER BRADFORD OFF.
MISTER BRADFORD FIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MR CHEER- THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE AS WE
ALL DEAL WITH THE ESCALATING.
COST OF HEALTH CARE THIS IS A
WAY OF CURTAILING THAT. R. AS
IN LIFE WE KNOW WE'RE NOT PAID
ON EFFORT WERE PAID ON RESULTS
AND WE WANT TO APPLY THAT SAME
THEORY TO. OUR MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND R. COSTA
DOING MEDICINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. ASIAN WE HAVE A
MOTION PRIVATE STIR MAYES A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND A LAST
MINUTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES. MAYES I FIGURE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE GARCIA. GARCIA
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW I BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO I LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
STENNIS ZERO GIVE US TEN VOTES
IT'S OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR GINGRICH
JR MEMBERS- BUT I'D LIKE TO GO
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A
SECOND BY. MISTAKE YOUR CURRY-
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO A PROBES
PREPARATIONS- MEDITECH JERRY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOOD HI
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES AYE AYE
YOUR CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
GARCIA. GARCIA I BIGELOW. BY
THE NUMBER ONE SPY SENATOR
BATES. THAT'S OKAY. BIGELOW AYE
BURKE CARILLO. HI FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
MISSOURIAN I RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
SENATE ZERO TEN ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPENED THE BILLS OUT
LIBERAL OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON AND THEN FINALLY WOKEN UP
WILL GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB THREE
SIXTEEN. OKAY PROMOTION. THE
MOTION BY MISTER NAZARIAN A
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ MEADOW
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WHAT I
NUMBER FOUR I REMEMBER S. YES
HI. YEAH WHEN I MAYES. MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
GARCIA GARCIA I BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE BURKE REAL CARILLO AYE
FLORAL. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I NAZARIAN. HI NAZARIAN I
REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON. TEN ZERO TEN
ZERO WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON SO I CENTER
AND WHEN I SEE YOU HERE AND YOU
HAVE THREE BILLS WE HAVE AN
ARRANGEMENT WITH SENATOR
SKINNER. IF IT AB THAT TOOK YOU
AS CLOSE TO TWO FIFTEEN IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE. I THINK SB THREE
EIGHTIES GONNA TAKE LONGER THAN
FIVE MINUTES BUT IF YOU'VE GOT
A- ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE BILLS
THAT- MIGHT BE A LITTLE SHORTER
DURATION WE'RE HAPPY TO BUT YOU
GO AHEAD. CERTAINLY'S MISTER
CHAIR CAN YOU CAN USE SUGGEST
WHICH ONE MIGHT BE THE SHORTEST-
WELL I YOU KNOW I THINK SB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE IS A GREAT CANDIDATE
ALL RIGHT LET'S DO THAT THEN.
THINKPAD GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
NICE TO SEE EVERYBODY OVER
HERE- TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
FOUR SIXTY FIVE- WE CAME INTO
THIS YEAR WITH AN INTENTIONAL
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE MOST
PRESSING NEEDS AND OF COURSE
SOME OF THOSE BEING- MENTAL
HEALTH. AND HOW WE TREAT THAT
AND HOW WE ARE FUNDING ALL OF
THAT. A ONE OF THE WAYS WE DO
THAT IS THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND FOR
THOSE WHO ARE AT THE- AT THE
MOST HIGH LEVEL OF NEED WE HAVE
WHAT IS CALLED A FULL. FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP- SO AND
THAT IS WHAT KIND OF IT BUT
WHATEVER IT TAKES- METHODOLOGY.
TREATMENT MODEL TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH FOLKS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE START TO REALIZE
THOUGH IS THAT THAT MAYBE OUR
OUTCOMES ARE VERY GOOD WITH
THIS AND WE'RE NOT. KEEPING
VERY GOOD TRACK. OF THAT SO
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
THE COMMISSION THERE'S AN
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION. THAT
OVERSEES ALL OF THAT AND AS WE
KNOW THERE'S MULTIPLE SOURCES
OF FUNDING THAT COMES INTO OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IS VERY
HARD TO KEEP TRACK OF THEM TO
BE ABLE TO DECIDE. WHAT IS
ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE WHAT IS NOT-
WHERE IS A GOOD USE OF MONEY
WHERE IS PERHAPS NOT. AT SO
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
THE COMMISSION TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE HOW MANY OF THOSE.
SERVED BY THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS EXPERIENCE THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. WHY INDIVIDUAL
SEPARATE FROM THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS AND WHAT SERVICES
THEY RECEIVED. IT WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO REPORT TO INCLUDE THE
DEGREE TO WHICH- THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS ARE ACCESSING
THIS THE SERVICES AND WHAT
BARRIERS THE COMMISSION MIGHT
BE ABLE TO. IDENTIFY THAT TO BE
ABLE TO REMOVE WE THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO. REALLY
SET OUR COURSE FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS AND FOCUSING ON
WHAT ACTUALLY WORKS TO BE ABLE
TO USE OUR- OF PUBLIC. AND
PRIVATE MONEY THE MOST
EFFECTIVELY- THAT WE PASSED THE
SO THE SENATE WITH THE
UNANIMOUS AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- AND TO WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS RANDALL HAGAR
REPRESENTING THE PSYCHIATRIC.
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TOBY TOBY YOU
IN WHO IS BIG THAT DIRECTOR OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNT. COMMISSION
VERY MUCH VERY REV THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR- WOULD GO
AHEAD TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I WILL NOTE THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY REGISTERED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AND THE SECOND BY I
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL
HAGER REPRESENTING THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
A CALIFORNIA- I THINK- CINDER
EGGMAN GAVE THE CONCEPT VERY
WELL THIS ONE UNDER. COUPLE
POINTS- YOU KNOW THE SCHOOL
THAT. KIND OF A CORE PIECE OF
MANY COUNTY SERVICES ARE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS AND ARE
ACTUALLY BASED ON. THE
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
MODEL WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
STUDIED MODELS IN THE HISTORY
OF COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH.
IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
FIFTY YEARS. AND WITH MANY
POPULATIONS IN DIFFERENT
TREATMENT CONTACTS USING IT
WITH PEOPLE HE HAS ABUSED DRUGS
AS WELL AS THOSE REMAIN THE L.
YOU CAN GET VERY EXCELLENT.
OUTCOMES AND- PUTTING IT VERY
SIMPLY IS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO WORK THE MODEL TO GET
THE OUTCOMES. AND AS SENATOR
EGGMAN HAS HAS INDICATED WE'RE
NOT QUITE SURE IF THAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE. A SYSTEMATIC WAY OF
MEASURING- AND COLLECTING DATA
AND REPORTING THOSE OUT COMES
OUT. SO IF YOU CAN DO THAT AND
THEN YOU CAN ACHIEVE COULD
FIDELITY YOU'LL GET BETTER
RESULTS. AND SO WHILE IT MIGHT
BE GOOD TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
BY 50% WHAT ABOUT SIXTY SEVENTY
OR EVEN EIGHTY PERCENT. THAT'S
WHAT THE POWER IN THIS DATA-
THAT WERE ABOUT TO COLLECT WE
HOPE TO COLLECT. BOB CAN DO AND
SO WE RECOMMEND THIS MEASURE TO
YOU VERY HIGHLY FOR THAT REASON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS. MR YOU IN.
DEBT GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS TOBY DOING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. HI
TWO ONE AT WHEN I THINK CENTER
EGGMAN FOR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
S. B. FOUR SIX FIVE WOULD
REALLY STRENGTHEN ATTENTION ON
CALIFORNIA'S FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS- AS I
THINK AS YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. ALONG WITH THE
COMMISSION HAS AN OVERSIGHT
ROLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC FUNDS IT REFUSING TO
SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH. ARE
BEING USED EFFECTIVELY AT
ACHIEVING KIND ABOUT COMES THE
ROLE LOOKING. FOR- THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE US TO PAY
SOMETHING. IT TO FOR SERVER PAR
FULL PARTNERSHIP AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THESE PROGRAM
ARE SOMEWHAT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA. THEY PAIR SEVERAL
CORE VALUES VALUES OF RECOVERY.
RESPECT FOR THE PERSPECTIVE OF
CONSUMERS WHICH IS WHY THESE
PROGRAMS ARE CALLED
PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE THEY'RE A
PARTNERSHIP BUILT BETWEEN THE
SERVICE PROVIDER AN INDIVIDUAL
BEING SERVED. AND THEY REALLY
BRING THIS WHATEVER IT TAKES
APPROACH WHICH IS- WHICH
RESEARCHES DEMONSTRATED CAN
HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE A FORMER
COMMISSIONER RICHARD VAN HORN
WHO PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK HE
WAS INSTRUMENTAL. IN HELPING TO
BRING THIS MODEL. INTO FRUITION
IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE STAKES
ARE VERY HIGH WITH THESE
PROGRAMS. NOT ONLY ARE WE
SPENDING UPWARDS OF A BILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR ON THESE
PROGRAMS. THERE THEM THE MOST
CONCERTED INVESTMENT WE'RE
MAKING TO REDUCE JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT TO REDUCE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. AMONG THE MANY
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACING IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING REDUCING
PRESSURE ON OUR STATE HOSPITALS
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ON HOUSING AND REDUCING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS OFFER
THE POTENTIAL TO REALLY ADDRESS
THAT AND WE KNOW MANY OF THEM
ARE WORKING VERY WELL. THE BILL
WOULD HELP US UNDERSTAND BETTER
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AND
WHY SO THAT WE CAN BE MORE
FOCUSED IN AND IN SUPPORTING.
OUR COUNTY AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO ENSURE WE'RE
DELIVERING CARE TODAY'S MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS IN WAYS
THAT ARE BOTH EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY THE
COMMISSION VERY MUCH SUPPORTS
S. B. FOUR SIX FIVE AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES ARE SERVICE
ANYONE I'M SORRY THERE IS
SOMEONE HERE IN THE GALLERY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY JUST NAME
AND POSITION ON THE BILL
PLEASE. YES MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
ANYBODY ELSE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HANNAH BACK OFF HERE
REPRESENTING CAL VOICES. WE
ARMS STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST NAME.
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION IF
THE REPRESENT ONE. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR SIXTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE-YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION SB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. EIGHT LINE
NUMBER TWO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
HERE TO COMMENT ON A DIFFERENT
BILL. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TIRING THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE MANDATE ON AT THE FOUR
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER
TWO FORTY THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS PROPOSED
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT SB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
NAOMI ROMERO AS WITH A
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NUMBER TWO OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS EILEEN I AM I
RESIDENTS KERN COUNTY OWNED
PROPERTY IN FRESNO COUNTY THE
LOW BARRIER SHELTER IN KERN
COUNTY ARE ALWAYS EMPTY IN THE
STREETS ARE FULL OF THE
HOMELESS CLIENTS TRONG
OPPOSITION BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY
BEING PROVIDED AND ANYBODY THAT.
ALMOST WHY NOT. THANK YOU
CAROLINA ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY I JUST THOUGHT
I'M OPPOSE FORTY FIVE BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE A GOVERNMENT IN NEXT.
MY NUMBER ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE IS OPEN. AND MEDICARE AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF THE AUTHOR MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. YES SENATE I JUST
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEN
NONE- THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
THE SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
WHICH I CLOSE SENATOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION ONE ASPIRANT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN THE BILL
DOESN'T CHOI DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WILL HAVE ASKED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE GARCIA.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BURKE
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON. I HAVE EIGHT
ZERO THE BILL HS A BOTH WILL
LEAVE ITS OUT WELL THAT THE
ONLY DEVELOPER FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON AT THIS POINT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND I DON'T SEE SENATOR
SKINNER SO GOING TO ENABLE
SEVEN FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
THANK YOU THINKING ABOUT
SHOPPERS TO CARE TODAY I'M ALSO
PRESENTING SB FIVE OF SEVEN A
BILL THAT WILL MAKE SOME
REVISIONS TO LAURA'S LAW AT
THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE
HEALTH AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEES
WITHOUT AGAIN UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- IF THE
SPOKESMAN RECALL LAST YEAR THIS
HOUSE WAITED AT A LOWER IS LAW
BILL THAT WITH THAT SAID THEN
THAT. COUNTIES AND LAURA'S LOG
IN AS A YOUNG ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE UNABLE TO BE COMPLAIN
ON THEIR OWN AND THIS WILL DO A
MANDATED COURSE BASED UPON A
LOWER WILK WILCOX ANOTHER AND
YET ANOTHER YOUNG WOMAN WHO
WERE SHOT AND KILLED BY A
CLIENT WHO WAS NON COMPLIANT
WITH THEIR WITH THE TREATMENT
PLANT FLOORS LAW THAT SAYS IT
CAN BE INTENT OF ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT AGAIN KEEPING PEOPLE
IN THEIR HOME ENVIRONMENT BUT
AT THE SAME TIME AND NOT HAVING
TO HOSPITALIZE. BUT MAKING SURE
THEY GET THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. A PREVIOUS. PLACES HAD A
COUNTIES HAD TO UP IN LAST YEAR
WE SAID COUNTIES HAD TO OPT
OUT- AND INDEED WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SAY NOW OVER THIRTY
COUNTIES. HAVE IMPLEMENTED
LAURA'S LAW. TO THIS JUST DOES
A LITTLE BIT CLEAN UP. BECAUSE
CURRENTLY YOU HAVE TO BE IN A
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA TO BE
ABLE TO ADMITTED FORCING OF
PEOPLE ARE COMING OFF A
CONSERVATORSHIP OR LPS. THAT
AND THEY MEET OTHER CRITERIA
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO GO AND
WE DON'T WANT TO GO BACK ON THE
STREETS AND CONTINUE TO SPIRAL
DOWN- AND SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE. SUBSTANTIALLY
DETERIORATING DOES OF COURSE
HAVE JUST GOTTEN OUT OF A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE FOR THEM. TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE INTO A LOWER LEVEL OF
CARE- BUT WE'RE ALSO THEN GOING
TO TALK ABOUT- MEDS AT LEAST
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THERE'S
NO FORCE MEDS IN THIS BILL BUT
AT LEAST BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION- AND TO BE ABLE
TO. INCORPORATE CLARIFICATION-
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO AGAIN ARE ARE
ARE STABLE BUT- THAT MAY BE
HAVE DEMONSTRATE THE ABILITY TO
DO THINGS BEFORE- THE
MEDICATION- AND FINALLY THE
BILL ALLOWS APPEARANCES BEFORE
THE COURT FOR TESTIMONY. BY
VIDEO HAS WE'VE SEEN HAS BECOME
NECESSARY- IN IN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. SO THE BIG- UTILIZING
TECHNOLOGY MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXITING IN
PATIENT HAVE ACCESS. TO A DUTY
AND SOME MINOR. FOR THE CAR FOR
CATIONS. AND WITH ME AGAIN I
BELIEVE I HAVE. RENTAL HAGAR
WITH THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA. AND CAL
STANSFIELD THE DIRECTOR OF A.
O. T. SERVICES AT TURNING
POINT. COMMITTEE PROGRAMS IN
NEVADA COUNTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. WILL TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR OUR- OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES TESTIMONY PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL ACRE
AGAIN- REPRESENTING THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA- THE SENATE
COMMITTEE TREATMENT AS THE
MODEL HERE AND IT COMBINES THE
ASSERTING YOU KNOW. THAT THE
TEAM. APPROACH IN SERVICES WITH
THE COURT SUPERVISION AND THIS
IS WHAT MAKES THIS MODEL-
EFFECTIVE SO IT DOES PROVIDE
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE A HISTORY.
THAT DEMONSTRATES THEY HAD
DIFFICULTY COOPERATING- WITH
THEIR TREATMENT TEAMS ARE
MAKING APPOINTMENTS NOT TAKING
THEIR MEDICATIONS AND
PREDICTABLY BECAUSE OF THOSE
THINGS BECOME ARRESTED
HOSPITALIZED OR HOMELESS. AND
THESE ARE REPEATING PATTERNS OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE ORIGINAL
STATUTE ATTEMPTED TO- BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A BENEFIT FOR. AND
WE PROVIDED- A SMALL MENU OF
CHANGES THAT DOES AS CENTER A
COMMENDED INDICATE A PROVIDE
THESE KINDS OF BENEFITS FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE STABLE AT THE
MOMENT BUT THEY DO HAVE A
HISTORY. FIFTY ONE FIFTIES OR
OR WHAT HAVE YOU- GOING INTO
THE COMMUNITY AFTER CONSERVE
OUR SHIPS- CANDY COMPENSATING
AND RETURNING TO THOSE TYPES OF
MORE EXTREME INTERVENTION SO.
THIS IS AN EARLY INTERVENTION
TOOL IT DOES- PREVENT RELAPSE
AND DETERIORATION. IT'S
PARTICULARLY. GOOD WITH
INDIVIDUALS. WHO LACK THE
INSIGHT TO. X. THERE ARE
CAPACITY TO GET INFORMED
CONSENT WHICH IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE WANTED TO HAVE
MEDICATIONS FLAG SO THEY COULD
BE- MUCH MORE UP FRONT FORWARD
IN CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
TREATMENT TEAM AND THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE COURTS AND
THE INDIVIDUAL AND- AS SAYS
UNDER EGGMAN ALSO SAID WE'RE
HAVING A LITTLE
TELECONFERENCING- ASPECTS OF
THIS SO THAT BOTH THE SUBJECT
OF THE PETITION FOR THE
EXAMINEE FELL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL. WHO IS PETITIONS-
WHOSE AFFIDAVIT IS SUBMITTED
WITH THE PETITION TO THE COURT-
CAN ACTUALLY MAKE APPEARANCES
THAT WAY SO AGAIN WE HARDLY
RECOMMEND US TO YOUR SHOULD DO-%
VERY WELL IN EXPANDING THIS
PROGRAM TO A NEW GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT NOW GETTING
THE BENEFIT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH IN
OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
IT'S
OPEN A MEMORY WE DON'T HAVE OUR
SECOND WITNESS ON THE PHONE.
YES CAROLINA'S OFFENSE. YOU MAY
HAVE YOURSELF OUR MEAL. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES PLEASE
YEP WITH SORRY I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT I AM HERE- FANGIO DIRECTOR
OF ACTINIUM G. TREATMENT FOR
TURNING POINT COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
NEVADA COUNTY REFERRED AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR AOG SERVICES
WITH A LONG HISTORY OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS DUE TO GRAVE
DISABILITY. RESULTED IN SIX
CONSERVATORSHIP THIS INDIVIDUAL
BECAME THE FIRST PERSON
CALIFORNIA JURY CBOT SERVICES
WHICH PRESENT PREVENTED
ADDITIONAL EPISODES OF GREAT
DISABILITY AND STOP THE
REVOLVING DOOR OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE NEED
TO BE CONCERNED. TODAY WE
OBTAIN COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF
HOW E. R. T. IS BRIDGE THE GAP
IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE SAVING
LIVES AND REDUCING HUMAN
SUFFERING. THE LAW REMAINS THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE COMMUNITY
BASED OPTION BUT PROTECTION OF
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AT ALL STAGES
OF THE PROCEEDINGS. UNDER THE
PETITION. ACCEPTED OKAY
TREATMENT IS A BILL. ON YEARS
OF CAN TREATMENT MY- CAN TO
STRONG AFFECT AND PREVENTING.
FORTY TERRIER RATIONING WOULD
LIKELY RESULT IN GREAT
DISABILITY. YES HARM TO THAT
PERSON OR TO OTHERS. EIGHTIETH
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE TREATMENT
AND THE PROCESS WORK IT SAVES
LIVES REDUCES SUFFERING
PROMOTES HOPE AND RECOVERY AND
SHOWS PEOPLE CAN GET BETTER I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE OF
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE GREATEST
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
COMPASSIONATE INTERVENTION HI I
RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW GO TO OTHER
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TERRAIN MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HANNAH BACK
UP AGAIN HERE REPRESENTING HELD
WAY SAYS WE WOULD LIKE TO STATE
OUR STRONG OPPOSITION. TO SB
FIVE OH SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THREE ONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY. SEE NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES SO SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON SB FIVE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PERSONAL YOU DON'T FROM
THE HELP OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI RANDY WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR THAT THAT THE ASIAN
WITH THE READ AND AMENDMENTS
WERE REMOVING OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITE
OFFICE ARE CONCERNED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NAOMI RUNNERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB
MARTIN PASS UP HOW MAY I AM IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JURY MEMBERS CALLS
WORSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THIS IS
GOOD I DON'T CALIFORNIA CAN DO
ANYTHING BECAUSE YOU CAN EVEN
STATE JUST TELL PEOPLE TO
PROTECT THEM THANK YOU WHICH IS
WHY YOU SHOULDN'T GROW. JUST
YOUR NAME AND POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
ONE MORE LIGHTING HERE TO JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT.
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY SAID YOU
HAD ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE. I DO
I DON'T SEE WHY MOMENT FOR THAT
COMMENT OKAY. THANK YOU SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TO LIGHT HIM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. YOU KNOW
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. SEEING
NONE WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MR
MCCARTY THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASSED TO DO JUST TO JUDICIARY-
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER EGGMAN. JUST ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND CONTINUE
TO STRENGTHEN OUR CONTINUUM OF
CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD
AYE. MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BAKER CURRY II
GARCIA. BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
BURKE. CARRILLO AREA AYE FLORA
LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA. RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. NINE ZERO THE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES IT'S- IT'S OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS
THAT ON- AND SENATOR SKINNER IS
STILL- IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE. SO
WILL- WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD ON SB THREE EIGHTY
SENATOR EGGMAN OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CARE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OKAY THE FOR MY
THIRD AND FINAL BILL TODAY
MEMBERS ANOTHER BILL THAT YOU-
YOU'VE YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE ON
THIS FLOOR- WE PASSED- END OF
LIFE OPTION ACT. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND WENT INTO EFFECT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND SINCE THE
INITIAL BILL PASSED WE'VE HAD
I'VE HAD HILL TWO OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS IN THE ASSEMBLY SOME
OF YOU PARTICIPATING IN THAT-
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ACT THAT WAS WHEN THE
COMMITMENTS I MADE WHEN WE
PASSED THE BILL WAS TO SAY WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO HOLD HEARINGS
AND HEAR FROM PHYSICIANS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND- AND
EVERYBODY ABOUT HOW THE BILL
WAS ACTUALLY GING SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE. THAT NONE OF THE
FEARS THAT WERE EXPRESSED EARLY
ON- CAME TO FRUITION- THROUGH
THOSE THE MOST THING THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT IS NOT THE ANY ANY
KIND OF ABUSE THERE'S NOT BEEN
ANY REPORTED ABUSE OF THE ACT
AT ALL BUT BARRIERS TO THE ACT-
FOR PATIENT ACCESS. TO AFTER-
FIVE YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION
THE CURRENT PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFICULT SOMETIMES FOR PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
THE END STAGES OF LIFE AND
UNNECESSARILY CUMBERSOME AND
WITH MANY ROADBLOCKS STILL IN
THE PLACE TO BE ABLE TO USE IT
ONE STUDY FROM KAISER
PERMANENTE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SHOWS THAT ONE THIRD OF
TERMINALLY ILL ADULT TO REQUEST
AT THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT.
DIED BEFORE THE BE ABLE IN
COMPLETING THE TIME CONSUMING
PROCESS THAT IT TAKES TO BE
ABLE TO USE THE OPTION- JUST
YOU SO WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT WE ARE ASKING TO DO
IS TO REMOVE THE FIFTEEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD AS YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO ASK THEIR
PHYSICIAN THEIR ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN DO IT TO START IT AND
THEN DO THAT IN WRITING THREE
DAYS LATER AND THEN FIFTEEN
DAYS LATER JUST DO IT YET
AGAIN. THERE'S ACTUALLY FOUR
POINTS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO ASK
PERMISSION THAT FIFTEEN DAY CAN
BE VERY COMPLICATED FOR PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IF THE FIRST
POSITION THEY ASK- DOES NOT
PARTICIPATE TAKES A WHILE TO
FIND ANOTHER ONE AND THEN
ANOTHER FOR THAT. FIFTEEN DAYS
LATER- I GUESS AS YOU AS A
STUDY AND THE WE'VE- OFTEN
PEOPLE DIED. IN A EXACTLY THE
WAY THAT THEY FEAR DYING BEFORE
THEY'RE ABLE. TO USE THE LAW
THAT WAS PASSED FOR THEM NOT TO
BE ABLE TO DIE IN WAYS THAT.
THEY DON'T CARE FOR JUST
RECENTLY SO WE'RE ASKING- TO
BROOD REDUCE THAT DOWN TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS VERSUS FIFTEEN
DAYS- JUST RECENTLY NEW MEXICO.
PASSED AND OF LIFE LEGISLATION
THAT INCLUDES A FORTY EIGHT
HOUR WAITING PERIOD BETWEEN THE
ORAL REQUEST FOR AID IN DYING
MEDICATION. WE THINK THAT WILL
NOT GO FAR FOR AND PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO AND GET PEOPLE CAN'T
TAKE UP TO FIFTEEN DAYS BUT
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO USE IT IN
IN TWO DAYS. IF NEEDED TO DO
THAT SECOND REQUEST. IT IS ALSO
BECOME VERY CLEAR THAT THAT
SECOND WRITTEN REQUEST
DESCRIBED AS THE FINAL
ATTESTATION. IS UNNECESSARY IT
IS GIVEN TO THE PATIENT BY
THEIR ATTENDING PHYSICIAN AND
THEY MUST. YET ONCE AGAIN WHEN
THEY'RE ALONE SIGN TO SAY YES I
AM YES I'M STILL SURE- AND THAT
AGAIN WE DON'T THINK THAT
FOURTH TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
IS REDUNDANT. FAMILIES FIND IT
OFFENSIVE- IF YOU WILL- AND SO
WE'RE SAYING THAT THAT SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GO THERE ARE ENOUGH
STEPS IN PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE TO ASK PERMISSION. BOTH
ORALLY AND IN WRITING THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN
AT THE VERY END- CURRENTLY THE
END OF LIFE OPTION ACT REQUIRES
THE ATTENDING PHYSICIANS TO
REMIND QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
DO NOT ADMINISTER THE SELF
ADMINISTER IT IN PUBLIC PLACE-
WHICH WE MEANT TO MEET MORE AT
A PARK THEY MAY USE IT AT A
HOSPITAL AND SO THIS JUST GO
VERIFIES THAT FOR PEOPLE-
ANOTHER INC INCONSISTENCY. IS
THE IN WHICH OR REQUEST FOR AID
IN DYING R. D. DATED AND
DOCUMENTED ON A PATIENT'S
MEDICAL RECORD SO OFTEN TIMES
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW. WHEN THEY
BEGAN SO WE'RE SAYING- THAT
PEOPLE MUST AT THIS BILL
MAINTAINS THE COR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT ONLY TERMINALLY
ILL. ADULTS ARE ABLE TO DO THIS
ALL OF THOSE THAT THINGS WILL
REMAIN THE SAME- ALL PATIENTS
WILL STILL HAVE TO MAKE TWO OR
REQUEST A WRITTEN REQUEST AND
BE EVALUATED BY TWO SEPARATE
POSITIONS. AT TO BE ABLE TO
CERTIFY THAT THIS IS A PERSON
WHO IS TERMINALLY ILL FROM
WHICH NO CURE IS EXPECTED WITH
SIX MONTHS OR LESS TO BE ABLE.
TO LIVE- SO WE THINK THESE ARE
REASONABLE THAT REQUEST AND
THEN FINALLY WE ARE ASKING TO
REMOVE THE SUNSET ON THIS- THIS
BILL HAS BEEN EFFECT SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND WE HAVE
OVER TWENTY YEARS OF
DOCUMENTATION AND DATA FROM
OREGON- AND WELL OF MORE THAN
THAT WORLDWIDE OF THE LACK OF
ABUSE IN THIS- WE KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO. TEND TO USE THIS
THERE WAS A- FEAR ABOUT IT'S
GOING TO BE POOR PEOPLE OR- ARE
DISABILITIES PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- OVERWHELMINGLY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN USED BY. THE
MAJORITY OF A CAUCASIAN UPPER
MIDDLE CLASS EDUCATED PEOPLE
WHO HAVE AN- AGENCY OVER THEIR
LIFE THEIR WHOLE LIFE AND AT
THE VERY END. OFTENTIMES AND
MAKE THIS DECISION. SO THERE'S
BEEN NO DOCUMENTATION OF
COERCION OR ABUSE AT ALL. WE
KNOW ABOUT TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
HAVE ACTUALLY USED IT I WE ALSO
KNOW THAT PEOPLE OFTENTIMES
WHEN THEY GET THE PRESCRIPTIONS
THEY DON'T EVEN USE IT BUT IT'S
KNOWING THAT IS THERE. THAT
GIVES THEM THE PEACE TO BE ABLE
TO DIE ON THEIR OWN TERMS- WE
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AND HAVE TAKEN.
AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOW BOTH OF
THEM TO BE OKAY WITH THIS BILL
AND BE NEUTRAL. WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORTERS DR
KATHERINE FORREST W. C. S. F.
AND KIMBERLY CATTLEMAN WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
COMPASSION AND CHOICES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WILL OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. WHENEVER THEY'RE
READY HI MY NAME IS DR. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT HI MY NAME IS DR
CATHERINE ZAHN PUTS FORTH IN A
CLINICAL ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY MEDICINE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH SPECIALISTS.
CALIFORNIA END OF LIFE OPTIONS
EXPECT FIVE YEARS AGO THIS
MONTH I PRESCRIBE MEDICAL AID
IN DYING FOR NUMEROUS
TERMINALLY ILL CALIFORNIANS IN
TRAINING HUNDREDS OF POSITIONS
ON BEST PRACTICES FOR IT. ABOUT
THE TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MANY
TIMES SUPPORT MEDICAL AID IN
DYING. RIGHT NOW I'M HERE IN
THE SOUTH OF THE MANY DYING IN
HOSPICE CARE- TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY. IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR. WELL FOR.
MY BELOVED OF THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS WAS DIAGNOSED WITH ALS.
ALSO KNOWN AS LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE HE WAS ADMITTED TO
HOSPITAL NAY. RETURNING NAY ON
THE WAY A LITTLE AFTER THE WITH
THE DIVISION AND TOLD ME.
CHAPLAIN IF YOU'VE NOT COOPER
THE LEGAL RIGHT TO USE MEDICAL
AID IN DYING HASTEN MY
INEVITABLE DEATH FROM THE
SUFFERING. I WOULD BE TERRIFIED
RIGHT. NOW I'D BE ABSOLUTELY. I
THANK YOU. AB ALTHOUGH THE
BILLION PUBLIC SCIENTISTS MINE
WHICH OCCURRED CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE TIRELESSLY FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEAR OLD REMAIN ON TOP.
THE BODY MUST LOOK AT YOUR YOU
RAPIDLY UNTIL WE CANNOT
FUNCTION AT ALL ULTIMATELY HE
WILL LOSE THE ABILITY TO GRIEVE.
R. EIGHT. WELL BACK. ON
IMAGINABLE SUFFERING. AND HE
WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE MEDICAL
AID IN DYING BEFORE THAT LITTLE
BUBBLE LEVEL ACCEPTING A KERR.
BUT THE ACTUAL STEPS FOR
ACCESSING THE OPTION WERE NOT
EASY EVEN FOR UP. THE NUMBER
ONE BARRIER OUR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN OFFICES ARE NOW OWNED
BY A CATHOLIC SYSTEM WOULD
CREATE WITH THE DOCTORS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN MEDICAL AID IN
DYING THEREFORE HIS PCP COULD
NOT BE A PRESCRIBER. NUMBER TWO
BARRIER IT'S HARD TO FIND OUT
WHICH PARTICIPANTS PARTICIPATE
MEDICAL AID IN DYING. LUCKILY
WILL WAS ALREADY A PATIENT AT
STANFORD FOR ANOTHER SPECIAL
CARE AND PAPER PARTICIPATES IN
MEDICAL AID IN DYING. IN FACT I
HELP SET UP THAT SYSTEM WHEN I
WAS ON FACULTY THERE CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF YOU DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH OR DON'T KNOW HOW HOW
IT WORKS TO ACCESS. MEDICAL AID
IN DYING. IN THE NUMBER THREE
BERRIER DELAYS IN CARE THE LAW
REQUIRES PEOPLE OF APPOINTMENTS
FOR BUSINESS TO CONFIRM
DIAGNOSIS. AND PROGNOSIS AT
LEAST FIFTEEN DAYS APART
HOWEVER. FOR WELL IT TOOK OVER
A MONTH AND SHE SUFFERED AN
ANXIETY ABOUT WHAT HE'S ABLE TO
ACCESS MEDICAL AID IN DYING
THANKFULLY WE NEED TO START THE
PROCESS EARLY. BUT MOST PEOPLE
DON'T. MY UP TO DATE. YEAH SB
THREE EIGHTY AND MAKE THE END
OF LIFE OPTION ACKERMAN. AND
REMOVE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS.
THANK YOU FOR FIFTEEN DAYS HERE
TO READ IT. BECAUSE
TRANSPARENCY. AND EVERYTHING TO
CONTINUE WHAT BY NOT ONLY FOR
THE DEATH PAY PEOPLE BUT HER
FAMILY MAX OFTEN MY TRUE LOVE
IN LIFE WELL. THANK YOU. I YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO OUR NAY
WITH IN SUPPORT. HI CALLANAN
AND I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
THE COMPASSIONATE CHOICES
ACTION NETWORK- AND- I'M
REPRESENTING MANY TERMINATE
WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS JUST
LIKE THE STORE YOU JUST HEARD
FROM DR FARRIS I'D LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR EXPENDITURE WOULD
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THE
pBILL AND- EXPRESS MY THANKS TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR CONSIDERING MAKING THE
CALIFORNIA END OF LIFE OPTION
ACT PERMITTED CAN IMPROVE THE
NEXT BATTLE. I DO KNOW IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN- AND MANY OF
YOU- CRAFTED THIS LAW AND IT
HAS RESULTED IN MUCH GREATER
HUMANITY AT LIFESPAN SINCE THE
LAW TOOK EFFECT NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE
REALIZE PEACE OF MIND AFTER
GETTING. A PRESCRIPTION FOR
MEDICAL AID IN DYING. A LOT HAS
ALSO INDIRECTLY BENEFIT MANY
OTHER TO. ILL READ THE BY
IMPROVING ACCESS HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE AS HAS BEEN
REPORTED IN THE LA TIMES. THE
REVISIONS THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SB THREE EIGHTY REALLY
VERY MODEST THEY ARE DESIGNED
TO HELP ACHIEVE THE ORIGINAL
INTENTION OF THE BILL- BE
STRANGER CAME ABOUT AS THE
RESULT OF INPUT FROM HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FROM HOSTAGES FROM
PHYSICIANS AT A HALF A CENTURY
COMBINED DATA AND EXPERIENCE
FROM CALIFORNIA AND EIGHT OTHER
AUTHORIZED JURISDICTION. WE
THEY CAME FOR THE DIRECT YOU
BACK TO PATIENTS THAT WERE
TRYING ACCESS THE LAW WE ALSO
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION TO
GET THEIR INPUT ON THE BILL.
AND AS A RESULT BOTH HAVE
WITHDRAWN THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION. SB THREE
EIGHTY REMOVE UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO MEDICAL AID IN
DYING BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
I FELT THAT IT MAINTAINS. ALL
THE IMPORTANT PATIENT
SAFEGUARDS OUR GOAL IS SIMPLY
TO ALLOW MORE DYING CALIFORNIA
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE OPTION. WHILE STILL
ENSURING THAT EIGHTY ABOUT OLD
BUILDING BUT POPULATIONS ARE
PROTECTED. A PATIENT MUST STILL
BE TERMINALLY ILL MENTALLY
CAPABLE DATE MARK TO
VOLUNTARILY REQUESTED MEDIC.
MEDICATION MULTIPLE TIMES IN
THE WRITING AND- VERBALLY AND
THEY MUST BE ABLE TO SELL THE
GAS THE MEDICATION- I COMPLETE.
THE THIRTEENTH STEP PROCESS. IT
IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT IF. ARE NOT FOR
MEDICAL AID IN DYING BECAUSE OF
EACH- DISABILITY THEY MUST BE
IMMINENTLY DYING. AND WE KNOW
FOR SURVEYS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES SUPPORT
MEDICAL AID IN DYING
LEGISLATION. TWO DIFFERENT
POSITIONS MUST BE EVALUATE THE
PATIENT ASK OUR MAY NEED
DISTRICT CRITERIA. ADDITIONALLY
JUSTICE AND ALL THE OTHER OFF
THE COAST OF THE OTHER ALL
RIGHT STATE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH PLUS
COLLECT AND PUBLISH IT TO
MONTANA TO MONITOR THE LAW
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH. HAS BEEN DOING SINCE
THE BEGINNING. AS SENATOR
EGGMAN MENTIONED- THERE THE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHANGES SERVICES
REDUCING THE FISCAL DAY WAITING
PERIOD DOWN TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS AS YOU HEARD FROM DR
FARRIS IT TAKES PEOPLE. A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
GET THROUGH THIS PROCESS EVEN
WITHOUT A WAITING PERIOD. BEING
PUT INTO THE LAW. I IT WORKED
OUT FOR A MAN THEIR TO YEARS
AGO ALLOW. ON FOR. TO WAIT THE
WAY PERIOD AND IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF THAT LAW BEING PUT TO
WORK BACK SEVENTY FIVE PATIENTS
20% OF THE PEOPLE WERE GIVEN
EXCEPTION. IT DEMONSTRATES JUST
HOW MUCH OF A BURDEN THE
FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD IS
ON A DYING PERSON. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. BOTH LINES ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KARLEY AT ALL THREE I AM A
LUCKY NOW PROUD MEMBER OF THE
LOS. STODDARD TO AN ELDERLY
MOTHER THAT NATION WITH ME. AND
ALSO I AM A REGISTERED NURSE
WITH HONOR TO WORK WITH MY
BIRTH FAMILY GUILBEAU A
NEIGHBORING AREA. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL HOLD OR STAY
OFFICE FELL. APART THE
CONVERSATION IN MY FAMILY ROOM
NEAR CIRCLE LEFT INDELIBLE MARK
IN MY PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
LIFE. I'M FRAZIER ELDERLY AND
DEEPLY IMPOVERISHED PATIENTS IN
THE PRACTICE OF HER GRAND CHILD
SEX ME. SO YOU'RE NOT STARTING
UP AT AND FROM MEDIA. I AM A
BURDEN TO MY FAMILY. HER
GRANDDAUGHTER EMPHATICALLY
REPLIED I WOULD NEED THAT YOU
ARE THE ONLY ONES BELONG TO ME
YOU'RE LISTENING TO ME YOUR
UNDERSTAND ME. YOU HAVE HìNH A
LITTLE TRYING YOU HAVE FOR ME
MAKE EVERYTHING. YOU TELL ME A
STORY THAT MAKES ME LAUGH. IN
SPANISH SHE SAID TO HER
GRANDMOTHER I WAITING. LATER
NOT ONLY GOT BASED ON ACTUALLY
MAKE GETTING IN MY SCHOOL TRACK
CAN MAKE ONE FOR ANYBODY. AND
PICKING UP THE AMPLE FIFTY CARE
ACT. ALLEN MITCHELL PARDON ME
NICK WENT BACK TO RESTORE YES
YES I THOUGHT IT MATH AND STILL
GRADE. MAYES PATIENT MIGHT
PATIENTS SO MANY OTHERS LIKE
HER BY VIRTUE OF HER HUMAN
WORTH AND DIGNITY. THE THIRD
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PAIN MANAGEMENT
SUPPORT. AND QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. NODDING EXPEDITED
PROCESS. WITH LITTLE TO NO
SAFEGUARDS THAT CAN LEAD. TO
THE ULTIMATE IN EVERITT FOCAL
BOLD DECISION TO TERMINATE THE
LIGHT. I URGE YOU TO THAT
CHRONIC USE OF SOME DRUGS. CAN
LEAD TO BOTH SHORT AND LONG
TERM CHANGES IN THE BRAIN WHICH
CAN LEAD TO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES INCLUDING DEPRESSION.
EXTRADITING THE TIME FRAMES.
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR PROPER
REPEAT PROPER ASSESSMENT
BACKING ADDRESS POSSIBLE
PHARMACOLOGICAL CLASSES OF THE
VERY FEW PRACTICE STATUS THAT
MAY BE A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO
A DECISION TO TERMINATE LIFE IS
DEEPLY ALARMING TO ME AT
PALATINA. AND AT THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER. YEAH A SWAY BUT HAVE
BEEN PHYSICALLY. THAT AT THE
ONE IN TEN. OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY FIVE **** FROM ELDER
ABUSE EVERY YEAR. YOU'RE BOTH
CAN HAVE A DEVASTATING EFFECT
BACKING LEAVE OUR ELDERLY
VULNERABLE TO IMPLICIT OR
EXPLICIT EMOTIONAL COERCION
FROM AN ABUSIVE CARE GIVER. AND
WHILE THE HEARTFELT-
TESTIMONIALS FOR THE PEOPLE
ARRIVING HERE TODAY ARE
PROFOUNDLY MOVING AND I HONOR
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD TODAY NOT
EVERYONE CAN CARE FOR THE
TERMINALLY ILL. ARE ACTING IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY CARE FOR. I
NEED FOR YOU TO CONSIDER THE
CRIPPLING POVERTY AND SELF
SACRIFICING NATURE OF SO MANY
ELDERS IN MY LATINO COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS A LACK OF SAFETY NET
SERVER SAYS MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND DOOR. I WONDER IF I
CAN TELL YOU THIS EXPEDITED
PATHWAYS SIDE IT'S A
DEVASTATING INDUCEMENTS THAT
WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
OUR LATINO OUTDOORS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR ALLOWING
US TO SHARE TESTIMONIALS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE WHITE HIM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA AND WE ALSO REGRET
TO INFORM YOU THAT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SP THREE EIGHTY I'M
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND- OUR BOARD D. R.
C. COMPRISES THE PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS. OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES ADOPTED PRINCIPLE
ON PHYSICIAN ASSISTED SUICIDE
WHICH SPECIFIED THE PROTECTION
WHICH SHOULD BE IN PLACE.
GUIDED BY THE PRINCIPLES WE DO
BELIEVE THAT SB THREE EIGHTY
LACK SUFFICIENT CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE THE
SAFETY OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. FOR EXAMPLE. THE
FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
BETWEEN ORAL REQUEST. SERVES AS
A VITAL PATIENT FACE CARD. A
LANCET STUDY FOUND THAT A
PATIENT WILL TO LIVE COMPLEXION
WEIGHT 30% IN A TWELVE HOUR
PERIOD IN BETWEEN 6270% OVER
THIRTY DAYS. MANY PEOPLE
REQUESTING ASSISTED SUICIDE
HAVE CHANGED THEIR MIND SOME
LIVING DECADES BEYOND THEIR
PROGNOSIS HAVING ACHIEVED A
CURE FOR THEIR SUPPOSEDLY.
TERMINAL ILLNESS. REDUCING THE
WAITING PERIOD TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS PUT THE LIFE OF PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES AT RISK.
FURTHER REMOVING THE
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS PUT
THE PATIENT AT KANEMI AT RISK
OPENING THE DOOR TO ABUSE BY
GREEDY HIRES OR ABUSIVE
CAREGIVERS. NO RECORDING NO
THIRD PARTY WITNESSES AT THE
TIME OF DEATH MAKE IT SO NO ONE
WOULD EVER KNOW IF THE PERSON
CHANGE THEIR MIND OR IF THERE
WAS COERCION SHE REMARKED
ADVOCACY WOK WE KNOW THAT IN
MEDICAL STUDIES THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
NOT ALWAYS VALUED AS HIGHLY AS
BOTH PEOPLE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES. WHICH HAS LED TO
THE FAILURE TO OFFER FOR THE
DENIAL OF MEDICAL TREATMENT
SUPPORT AND SERVICES SH. THE
WEBSITE IS NOT ABOUT CHOICE
WHEN PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
LACK ACCESS TO SUFFICIENT
MEDICAL CARE THE COCA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RELIEVE LONGSTANDING
DISPARITIES IN OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM AS WE WITNESSED
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
INFECTION AND MORTALITY IN OUR
AGING AND DISABILITY COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS ARE BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES. NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES. IN OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
FINALLY IN CALIFORNIA. PATIENTS
REASONS FOR RESTORE TO ASSISTED.
OR NOT. TO THE PUBLIC IN FACT
THERE ARE. CRUCIAL DATA POINTS
THAT ARE LIFTING AND MOST TO
GREG GREG GREG YES CALIFORNIA
HAS ADMITTED TO THE DESTRUCTION
OF THE UNDERLYING DATA EVERY
THREE YEARS. AT A RECENT
OVERSIGHT HEARING. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SHARED THAT DATA
COLLECTION THE STATE DOES TWO
SHOWS LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW BUT THE STATE HAS NO
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. IN CLOSING
WE DO BELIEVE IT IS PREMATURE
AND DANGEROUS TO REMOVE THE
SUNSET CLAUSE. AND WE URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE
TO THE GALLERY FOR. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
OPEN FOR US AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MY NAME IS JONATHAN KELLER AND
THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL HERE SPEAKING
TODAY. ON IN ON BEHALF OF BOTH
OUR ORGANIZATION AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION. RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING YOUR NO VOTE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GREG BIRD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I'M LIANE TO LEBANON
WITH BARE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL AND I AM WITH
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY. WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES WE AS I SAID
EARLIER WILL BE LIMITING- THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
MINUTES AND WE'LL BE KEEPING
TRACK SO ONCE AGAIN PLEASE-
RESPECT OUR PROCESS NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION- IF
YOU GO BEYOND THAT WE WILL
TERMINATE THE CALL- IN THE
CALL. AND SO WE ALLOW AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE TO TESTIFY
JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL WITH THAT-
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON ASK THE THREE EIGHTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT LINES IN Q. OR TO LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS BARBARA GLAZER
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- I JUST WANTED TO
LET OU KNOW THAT WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE EIGHTY WE ARE NOW NEUTRAL
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR STAFFING THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH THE
FROM THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT NEXT. THANK
YOU I WON THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS KAREN
MOORE AND I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE HOSPICE NURSE AND I'M
WITH THE LA PATIENT ADVOCATE
AND I AM FULLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I TWO
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ROCKSTAND COOL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE NINE
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
PLACERVILLE FROM CALIFORNIA
LUWAK AND I AM OPPOSED TO BEING
THIS WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
ENERGY HONOR SCHOLAR PLEASE
AFFECTING THANK HELLO NEXT CALL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY BE IN A
HURRY TO KILL SOMEONE IN TWO
DAYS NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN TO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS LISA
PAPUA WITH THE BILL IMPACT AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AT NINE TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER KIRK RJ AND I AM A
MEMBER OR RESIDENT OF A GERMAN
WOODS DISTRICT HELLO- I AM A
BIRTH DOULA AND A CARE GIVER
FOR ELDERLY PEOPLE ALSO. AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE GO NOW THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TO A LOT OF
ENTRIES GLAD. YES THIS IS
THERESA BRENNAN PRESIDENT OF
THE RIGHT TO LIFE WE WERE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AND URGE A NO
VOTE ON SB THREE EIGHT OKAY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ROBERT
BYRD AND THEN THE DAY AREA
RESIDENTS. AND I AM VERY CHANGE
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT TO SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY HARRINGTON
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FINE ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH DAHLE
MORGAN SANTA CLARA COUNTY I'M A
CARE GIVER AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION THERE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS
IS DOCTORS ZERO TENDER HOSPICE
BEREAVEMENT COORDINATOR AND
DISABILITY SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS I E. DS
PS ORGANIZER AND CARE GIVER
REPRESENTING PARA POLICE CHECK
CATHERINE THERESA MCCAFFREY AND
THIS DISABILITY COMMUNITY
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY TWO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DR RYAN SPIELVOGEL
POSITION IN SACRAMENTO AND
HAVING EVALUATED OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PATIENTS FOR AID IN
DYING IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
THREE EIGHTY. YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T HAVE
MY NUMBER RETIRED. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM I'M DEBBIE
DIAMOND AND I'M A RETIRED NURSE
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE EIGHTY IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED VERY BADLY. GOAL.
YOU MIGHT JUNE NINETEENTH. NINE
THREE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS BOB NEAL
REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD AND
COMPANY OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BRIAN TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN TWO SEVEN ONE. LOW
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DR DEBORAH
WEINSTEIN I AM WITH COMPASSION
AND CHOICES AND I AM STRONGLY
IN FAVOR OF SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TRYING TO EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JULIE. FROM BAKER FELT IT WRONG
OPPOSITION YEAH B. THREE EIGHT.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES ONE KERN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVEN THREE.
TO ME TO SEE WHAT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A MARK
BLOOMBERG IN MEMORY OF
BLUEGRASS THE SAN FRANCISCO
TAXI DRIVER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TRYING
TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATIE. MY NAME
IS KATIE HOGAN AND- FIFTY TWO
YEAR OLD CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENT. CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT ONE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT. ONE
THREE TWO. ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE EIGHT
ONE. HELLO B. CARLSON FROM TO
HATCH A P. CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT WITNESSES TO LIE AND
I'M IN VERY STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND TO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEPHANIE CAMPBELL- MY HUSBAND
USED END OF LIFE OPTION ASK CAN
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARON
FELT SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN HONOR
OF MY HUSBAND LARRY FELT. TO
USE THE ACTIVE BUT DENY AM
HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR JAMES
SANTIAGO BRASILIA I'M DE
CALIFORNIA CHAIR OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF MEDICAL
ETHICS SPEAKING STRONGLY- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
INSUFFICIENT DATA COLLECTION
AND ELIMINATING THE SUNSET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. RYAN TO FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CAROLINE KELLER I AM A CLINICAL
NURSE SPECIALIST IN PATIENT
CARE ADVOCATE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY LINE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT CHIU FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAN
DEALS I AM BRITNEY MINARD HAS
BEEN CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TRYING TO EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH ALLOCATE GO I'M AN
EDUCATOR AND CARE GIVER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS FRED
CIRCUMVENT SOME RESIDENTS OF
THE L. A. COUNTY AND I URGE OF
A FAVOR OF SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT IS JUST A VERY OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWO SIX THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THERE AM
I AUDIBLE. YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU-
MY NAME IS STILL PACKAGE- IN
MEMORY OF MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY
YESTERDAY AND WISH YOU HAD THE
OPTION TO USE THE ACT OCCURRED
WITH THE FIFTEEN DAYS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR CALL
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. THANK YOU.
TRYING TO R. NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS EILEEN PRICE
I'M CALLING IN HONOR OF ONE TO
CAROLINE PRICE WITH THE
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY IN
ADDITION TO RIGHT TO LIFE KERN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TRYING TO EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GLAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JEFF DANCING- I'M THE
RABBI AT TEMPLE BETH EL IN
RIVERSIDE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIE
STROUD AND THE DAUGHTER OF A
LONGTIME DC BERKELEY PROFESSOR
WHO ACCESS BUT DID NOT UTILIZED
MEDICAL AID IN DYING IN THE
STATIC SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK THANK YOU NEXT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TRYING TO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS NEARING THE SHARK
DIRECTOR RIGHT TO LIFE AND KERN
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION TO
CURTAIL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. RIGHT TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS.
HELLO I'M A WRECK. AB CAPITAL
APPOINTMENT AND I AM A GREAT
TEAM MEMBER AND PAT ENJOYED IT
AND I FULLY SUPPORT IT FELT.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND TO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JACQUELINE WEYER IN SUPPORT OF
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT TO SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
SEVEN EIGHT. RIGHT TO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR ROBERT
OLVERA I AM CALLING IN BEHALF
OF MY DAUGHTER EMILY ROBERT-
WHO DIED SUFFERED GREATLY
WALKING THE END OF LIFE ISSUES
TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD SHE WANTED
THE OPTION I REPRESENT MEMORIAL
YOU BET CARE MEDICAL GROUP. AND
I AM STRONG SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRITAIN'S DATE FROM SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWO SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SEVEN FIVE. THIS IS REGINA
SPACE IT'S A QUIET STYLE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE CALL HAD. MIKAELA
SHIFFRIN'S REPRESENTING THE
PATIENTS RIGHTS ACTION FUND WE
OPPOSE SB THREE EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE ZERO FOUR.
HELLO. PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH AND
THAT'LL STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. CRISTINA
FUNDERBURK KERN COUNTY RESIDENT
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND TWO SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GLAD. HI MY NAME AT
ALL AND MICHAEL I'M- IT AT.
THAT AFTER ALL. PEOPLE THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE TWO
IS GOING. CHARLES JOHNSON WOULD
CALVARY LOS ANGELES STRONGLY
OPPOSE I'VE MATTER THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY YEAR OLD WITH CAPITOL
RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS. MY LED
CHARACTER CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF CONCERN. ON BEHALF
OF I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIANA SCHAEFER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I HAVE
MULTIPLE CLEROSIS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. THREE
EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DOREEN WHITWORTH FROM MADERA
COUNTY I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THE- THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JACKIE MINER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALBERS
ACQUIRED ON BEHALF OF SENIOR
THAT THE NEXT FELLOWS OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR NONVIOLENCE
FOUNDED BY NATIONAL HEALTH
POLICY EXPERT ABOUT THE DOOR
ALVAREZ IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE CALLER
LAST IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
SO THAT MY NUMBER. THANK YOU. I
HAVE TO RUSSIAN Q. OVER TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY. THIS IS TO RECTIFY
THE REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
CATHOLICS FOR THE CLINICALLY
DEPRESSED WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK. NEXT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KARISHMA KIßM
REPRESENTS INYO COUNTY
BREASTFEEDING COALITION WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMECREATOR.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER VICE CHAIR.
YEAH I JUST- THINKING BACK ON-
THE MY FIRST TERM IN IN OFFICE-
REMEMBERING- THIS BILL WHEN IT
CAME BEFORE US AND- I REMEMBER
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
WHEN YOU WERE- IN THIS THIS
HOUSE- AND- AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THOSE OF US ON ONE HAND
THIS IS THE MOST DIFFICULT BILL
THAT AT THE TIME IT ACTUALLY
SAYS ACTUALLY MOST DIFFICULT
BILL WHATEVER VOTED ON- AND I
ALSO THINK THAT THIS BODY-
ROSE. TO THE OCCASION CHAU
DEMOCRACY AT ITS FINEST I STILL
REMEMBER- THAT DAY WAS JUST-
TALKING TO ANOTHER MEMBER ABOUT
THE THAT DAY THE BEST SPEECH ON
THE FLOOR- IN SUPPORT- I
THOUGHT CAME FROM REPUBLICAN
THAT DAY AND- I THOUGHT THE
BEST SPEECH OPPOSED CAME FROM
OF THE DEMOCRATIC THAT DAY-
AND- IT WAS- TWO AND A HALF
HOURS IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY
OF FLOOR DEBATE- AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT. I VOTED NO- THEN-
AND I WAS WAVERING ALL OVER THE
PLACE ON- ON ON THE BILL- I
WENT FROM BEING I SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TO END UP- ULTIMATELY.
VOTING VOTING NO ON THE BILL
AND I WONDER IF THAT BILLS
BEFORE US TODAY- WHAT I SUPPORT
AND I THINK I PROBABLY I
PROBABLY WOULD AND- ALTHOUGH I
VOTED NO AT THE AT THE TIME- I
THINK THE QUESTION AND- AND
MAYBE WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS
AND-- IT'S-
THAT QUESTION A FIFTEEN. TO
FORTY EIGHT HOURS AND REALLY
THE QUESTION OF. OF SAFEGUARD-
AND- AND THEN THAT ISSUE
ATTESTATION- I SEE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S NOT AN ATTESTATION
THERE'S STILL SORT OF A
WRITTEN. A WRITTEN SO CAN YOU
CAN YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT ABOUT
THAT- I'D LIKE TO THAT THAT TO
ME SORT OF THE HANG UP IS
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE STILL
PROPER SAFEGUARDS. YES THE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
DON'T THINK A ANYBODY WHO WAS
HERE IN THAT ROOM THAT THEY
WILL WILL EVER FORGET THOSE A
LOT OF EMOTIONS- I'M BERNARD
HAD BECAUSE IT'S AN ISSUE OF
LIFE AND DEATH RATE THAT I
DON'T THINK WE EVER DEBATE
THINGS MORE- THAT ARE MORE REAL
TO US- THEN. SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL EXPERIENCE RIGHT WE ALL
EXPERIENCE BIRTH WE ALL
EXPERIENCED DEATH- AND WHILE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT IT
BECOMES VERY EMOTIONAL FOR
PEOPLE. OF WE PUT A LOT OF SAFE
GUARDS INTO THE BILL IN ORDER
TO. MAKE MAKE SURE THAT. THE
THAT THE THERE WOULD BE NO
ABUSE THAT'S A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT IF YOU RECALL
PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT. COERCION
POVERTY DISABILITY ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WERE. WERE SB
HAVE SAID IN THEIR RIGHT MINDS
WHEN THEY DO THIS YEAH- SO
THAT'S WHAT THE FIFTEEN DAY
WHAT KIND OF SET OUT TO DO BUT
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT IT
HAS BECOME A BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS EVER THE INTENTION OF THE
FIFTEEN DAYS WAS A SAFEGUARD.
BUT NOT THAT IT SERVES AS A
BARRIER- THE DATA SHOWS US- AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH COLLECTS THE DATA
HAS SHOWN US. THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THE PEOPLE. PART OF ME HERE-
ARE THOSE THAT ARE- IN HOSPICE
CARE SO OVER 85% ARE IN HOSPICE
CARE SO IT'S NOT LIKE YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHO WAKES UP
PEOPLE LIKE TO GIVE THE
IMPRESSION AS YOU WAKE UP ONE
DAY AND SAY. I'M HAVING A BAD
DAY I THINK I'M JUST GONNA GO
GET THE PRESCRIPTION PEOPLE
HAVE LIVED YEARS OFTENTIMES IN
IN IT ACTIVE TREATMENT TRYING
TO FIND A WAY RIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY I WOULD GET I WOULD
OFFER YOU WHO HAVE HAS USED
THIS. THAT WANTS TO DIE. RIGHT
BUT WE ARE ALL GOING TO DIE.
AND THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE WHO HAVE A TERMINAL
ILLNESS FROM WHICH NO CURES
EXPECTED. WHO WISH TO USE THIS.
SO THAT FIFTEEN DAY THAT ACTED
WE YOU KNOW WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS. THAT THAT
SLIPPERY SLOPE DID NOT EXIST
THE DATA HAS SHOWN US THAT THAT
DOESN'T- IT IT TENDS TO BE I
GET A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE
THEY TEND TO BE. EDUCATED HAVE
INSURANCE BE IN HOSPICE.
INTENDED BECAUSE CAJUN- IS WHAT
WHAT THE DATA HAS SHOWN US BUT
AGAIN THAT. TO SHORTEN IT TO
TWO DAYS AND AGAIN THIS WAS
NEGOTIATED WITH. WITH
PHYSICIANS SO IT WENT DR PAN-
AND IT'S AND THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE IN- IN NEW
MEXICO. AND IT DOES IT DOES
SHORT AS SIGNIFICANTLY BUT
AGAIN IT DOSN'T HAVE TO BE.
TWO DAYS RIGHT IT CAN BE
FIFTEEN DAYS IT CAN BE LONGER
THAN THAT. IF PEOPLE WANT- BUT
THE BUT BUT THAT HAS JUST
SERVED AS A BEAR YOU HEARD- DR
FORREST. WHOSE HUSBAND HAS. A
LS RIGHT SO L. AS WE KNOW. WHEN
IT IS SEVERE LIKE. IT ALMOST
ALWAYS IS. BUT WILL OFTENTIMES
AND PREVENT YOU FROM BREATHING
PROVENCHER FROM SWALLOWING
PREVENT YOU FROM BEING ABLE TO
USE YOUR HANDS. SO IF SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY AND THAT IS THE LAW
SAYS YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE IT. AND IT JUST IT
YOURSELF. CAN YOU IMAGINE. SO
DAYS OUT TO DAYS OUT AND YOU NO
LONGER USE YOUR HANDS. AND YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW THE AND THAT IS
COMING THE ACTUAL AND THAT YOU
DIDN'T WANT. SO AFTER THAT
NEGOTIATION IS HOW WE SAID WELL
LET'S LET'S. FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
SO THAT THAT IS WORKING FROM
SOME PEOPLE YOU KNOW MAY STILL
NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE MEDICAL
SOCIETY AND WHAT PATIENTS- AND
AGAIN WE HEARD THAT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THAT SOMEBODY WENT
TO THEIR POSITION. THEN THE
POSITION SAID OH I'M SORRY. I
KNOW YOU WANT TO USE IT BUT-
BUT I'M NOT GONNA DO IT FOR YOU
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO TRY TO GO
FIND SOMEBODY ELSE. AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO FIND SOMEBODY ELSE
FIFTEEN DAYS LATER. AGAIN THESE
ARE PEOPLE WITH A TERMINAL
ILLNESS OFTENTIMES THEY- HAVE
THOUGHT WELL I'LL DO IT LATER.
AND BY THEN IT BECOMES TOO LATE
AND PEOPLE DIE IN WAYS THAT
THEY DON'T WANT. THAT LAST
ESTá STATION AGAIN THEY HAVE
TO- THAT. GO TO THE PHYSICIAN.
AND THEN PUT IT IN WRITING. AND
THEN GO TO ANOTHER ONE AND IF
ANYONE FEELS THAT PERSON IS
DEPRESSED OR HAS ANY MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. THEN THEY ARE
REFERRED TO A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER WHO THEN HAS TO SIGN
OFF. THEN THEY HAVE TO GO GET
THE PRESCRIPTION. AND SIGNED SO
ARE THERE ARE STILL MULTIPLE
STEPS ALONG THE WAY AND THAT'S
WHAT FAMILIES. AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS HAVE SAID TOO THAT
THE THIS THE STEPS. TO
SAFEGUARD TO BECOME BARRIERS
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND
PEOPLE CAN'T ACCESS THE LAW
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE. TO GIVE
PEOPLE PEACE OF MIND. THAT YOUR
QUESTION IT DOES I JUST WANTED
TO SAY FACT I'VE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED WORKING WITH YOU
OVER THE YEARS BACK WHEN YOU
WERE OUT. HERE IN THIS HOUSE
AND- ONE THING I'VE ALWAYS-
REALLY RESPECTED THAT IS THE
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ENERGY AND
EFFORT THAT YOU PUT IN- TO NOT
JUST- THIS ISSUE BUT OTHER
ISSUES AS WELL YOU'VE DONE YOUR
HOMEWORK- YOU'VE TAKEN. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF. OF FIRE-
FROM FROM ALL OVER THE PLACE
BUT YOU'VE YOU'VE WORKED
THROUGH ALL OF THEM- AND JUST
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE RUNNING
THIS AT TODAY GIVES ME. A SENSE
OF- OF PEACE- IF YOU WILL- AND
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANTED TO ALSO COMMIT ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES' SENTIMENT- FROM
PALM SPRINGS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS PUTTING
YOUR HEART AND SOUL INTO EACH
OF THE ISSUE AREAS THAT YOU
WORK AND THANK YOU FOR ALSO.
PUTTING IN YOUR THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT PRIOR TO BEING
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL YOU HAD
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN AND SO
YOU'RE BRINGING YOUR EXPERIENCE
TO THE FOREFRONT- I HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS TODAY HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH OF ONE OF THE
GROUPS THAT WERE OPPOSING AND-
EIGHT TO MADE ME REALIZE THAT I
NEEDED TO DO A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESEARCH AND MY- AND I CAME
ACROSS. A REPORT- WHICH I HAD
NOT SEEN BEFORE- FROM CDPH FROM
JULY TWENTY TWENTY. THAT LISTS
AND ENUMERATES ALL THE
DIFFERENT DATA. FOR THE SERIES
OF QUESTIONS INCLUDING AGE
GENDER LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
ETHNICITY RACE- UNDERLYING
ILLNESSES. AS WELL AS INSURANCE
HOSPICE CARE. A LOT OF DATA
POINTS THAT I THOUGHT WERE
CRITICAL. AND MAKES THIS
DECISION A LOT EASIER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. A THIS ISSUE. ABSENT
THIS DATA IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
TO- THE I WAS STILL GOING TO BE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE ISSUE AS
I WAS. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT I JUST
WONDERED. WHY NOT COLLECT SOME
MORE DATA- BUT AFTER I SAW THIS
EIGHT AM. I JUST WANTED TO AS
AN INDIVIDUAL BRING THIS UP
THAT IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE
OPPOSITION. TO BE LOOKING AT
THIS DATA. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO KNOW EXACTLY- WHEN WE
ARE USING FEAR TACTICS AND WHEN
WE ARE- ACTUALLY LOOKING AT.
IMPORTANT INFORMATION AND NOT
JUST CREATING MYTHS- THIS WAS
VERY EYE OPENING TO SEE THAT
87% HAS BEEN WHITE. OVER 50%
HAS HAD A EITHER DOCTORAL
MASTER'S OR BACHELOR'S DEGREE-
AND OVER 53% WERE EITHER IN
THERE BETWEEN THERE SEVENTIES
AND NINETIES- SO A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS. THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP DON'T SEEM TO MATCH
UP WITH THE DATA THAT'S
PRESENTED- BUT I ALSO. GIVEN
HOW SENSITIVE THIS ISSUE IS I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO
ALWAYS HAVE A VERY CAREFUL AND
OBJECTIVE ASSESSMENT. SO THAT
THE INITIAL NUMBERS WHICH SEEM
TO PROVE ARE YOUR POINT- WE
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALWAYS
DOING IT WITH A CAUTIOUS LANDS
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT NEVER
STRAYS FROM WHO IT IS THAT
REALLY WANTS THIS TO HAPPEN AND
GETS THE ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
NEED SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
MISS BURKE- SO WE MAKE A LOT OF
DECISIONS ON THIS FLOOR IN OUR
COMMITTEES AND- AS A FRESHMAN I
WAS A CO AUTHOR WITH YOU ON
THIS BILL AND I HAVE NEVER ONCE
REGRETTED IT THERE ARE HARD
CHOICES FOR FAMILIES AND NO ONE
TAKES THEM LIGHTLY- YOU HAVE
BEEN AS OUR PLACES SAID A
TRUSTWORTHY AUTHOR AND THE
DATA. PROVES THAT YOUR WORK IS
SHOWING TO BE REAL AND- REALLY
BEING ON THE FOREFRONT OF WHAT
IS HONEST AND TRUE. AND SO I
WOULD I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT I GET TO JOIN YOU
AGAIN AS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
MEASURE IT IS- LIFE CHANGING
FOR FAMILIES WHO. HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THESE. TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS IT IS- EMOTIONALLY
TRYING. AND TO JUST KNOW THAT
THE SUPPORT IS THERE FOR YOUR
LOVED ONES. TO TRANSITION IN
THE WAY THAT THEY CHOOSE- AND
IN A SAFE MANNER THAT YOU HAVE
LAID OUT VERY VERY WELL AS YOU
SAID YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT
IN FORTY EIGHT HOURS IT'S AND-
IT JUST CHANGE MAKES IT AN
OPTION- FOR THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE HAD FAMILY THAT HAVE HAD
TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT OPTION
IS STILL FIVE. I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN THIS IS WAS A
HARD. TRIED TO THE FIRST TO
ANSWER- HOWEVER HE REALLY GOT
BROKEN UP. IT WAS HARD THEN I
KNOW IT CONTINUES TO BE
DIFFICULT NO ONE WANTS TO MAKE
THESE CHOICES BUT THANK YOU FOR
BEING ON THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
WORK IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT
AND VERY MEANINGFUL. TO A LOT
OF US THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MAY. THREE
NINE- THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN-
YEAH I SUPPORTED YOU THE FIRST
TIME AND MY SUPPORT HAS BEEN
UNWAVERING SENSE- MY DAD DIED
OF CANCER ABOUT TWENTY SIX
YEARS AGO. AND THE LAST WEEKS
AND MONTHS WERE REALLY ROUGH HI
I WONDER. AND HAD HE HAD THE
CHANCE TO DO THIS WOULD HAVE
DONE IT. I DON'T KNOW. BUT I
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR ANYBODY
WHO'S WATCHED A FAMILY MEMBER
SUFFER IN THOSE LAST DAYS. I
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS AND
HOW DIFFICULT THESE DECISIONS
ARE- I RESPECT EVERYBODY'S
OPINION. WITH THE SUPPORT THIS
BILL YOU DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL BUT I DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AND I'M PROUD TO BE. YOUR
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL- AND I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- ONE
OF MY PREDECESSORS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTY BURKE. WHO WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE WHICH FROM TWO THOUSAND
TO TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND
I WHEN I CAST MY VOTE TODAY I
WANT TO DO THAT IN HONOR OF HER.
AND- MY FATHER. THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF WE- YEAH BUT WITH THAT
MOTION ORDER YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. THE MOTION FOR MYSTERY
WITHOUT MUSHROOMS RECRUIT THANK
YOU MUCH DIFFERENCE CARILLO A
SECOND FROM IS BURKE- WHICH I
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS IN AND AS ALWAYS I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION I THINK YOU FOR
ACTUALLY DIGGING INTO THE DATA-
THAT ADDRESSES BY TO PASS GOOD
LEGISLATION AND THAT
LEGISLATION WE PASSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE PUT THOSE SAFEGUARDS
IN AND WE HAD ALL THAT DATA
COLLECTION SO WE COULD MAKE
SURE. THAT IT WAS OPERATING AS
WE INTENDED AND THAT'S WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO THIS VERY IN
DETAIL FOR YOU IT IS IT IS S.
AS MUCH AS WE THOUGHT- IN LIFE
BUT IT IS INTERESTING WE LIVE
AS WE DIVE RIGHT AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WITH A HIGHER DEGREE
OF EDUCATION INTENDED BECAUSE
CAJUN HAVE AT AGENCY ALL THEIR
LIFE AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS AND OFTEN
WANT TO DO THAT AT THE END.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE REST OF
US WHO ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
COME FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS
MIGHT NOT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
USE THAT SOME DAY AS A WEEK AS
WE CONTINUE TO GAIN AGENCY IN
THE WORLD- AND CONTINUE TO
REDUCE EQUITIES THIS THIS WILL
THEN BE AVAILABLE PERHAPS
TOWARD MORE BUT IT IS ALWAYS
JUST. AN OPTION AND I KNOW
AGAIN ANY TIME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OPTIONS AROUND LIFE AND
DEATH- THEY ARE DIFFICULT
MEMBERS BUT THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE- WHO. YOU'D
LOOK AT THIS AS A AS A AS HOPE
AS A WAY OF PROVIDING PEACE FOR
THEM AGAIN WE ARE ALL GOING TO
DIE AND SOME PEOPLE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT AGENCY AT
THE END OF THEIR LIFE- AND I
WILL JUST- IN THE END WITH A
QUOTE FROM JERRY BROWN WHO WHO
HAND WROTE A- A MESSAGE AND
SAID. I DON'T KNOW WHAT. I
WOULD DO. AT THE END OF MY LIFE.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT SOMEBODY
ELSE WOULD DO EITHER. BUT I
WOULDN'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY
THEIR OPTION. I ASK FOR YOUR
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
HAVE A MOTION PRIVACY. FOR
MYSTERY OF A SECOND WAS REMISS
BURKE. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WOOD I
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA. BIGELOW BIGELOW NO
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING. WALDRON.
SEVEN ZERO I'M SORRY SEVEN ONE.
THIS EGGMAN YOU'RE A BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW MOVES TO SENATOR SKINNER
YOU HAVE TO BILL SENATOR
SKINNER. GO AHEAD WITH THE SB
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
ON THIS BILL IS ABOUT BIRTH SB
SIXTY FIVE RECOGNIZES THAT
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN WITH OUR
ADVANCED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OUR
WEALTH AND OUR EDUCATION THAT
INFANT MORTALITY AND MATERNAL
REPORT MORTALITY. ARE HIGHER IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE US THAN ALL
OTHER. COUNTRIES IN OTHER WORDS
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE COMPARABLE
FIVE ECONOMIC- ADVANCEMENT AS
WE HEAD OUT. SO DEATHS ARE FOR
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL TO ADDRESS THAT- IT BUILDS
ON LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE
DONE THAT SENATOR MITCHELL
THERE WAS PASSED THAT
ESTABLISHED IN IMPLICIT BIAS
PROGRAM FOR PERINATAL CARE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
THESE HIGH RATES. OF INFANT
MORTALITY MATERNAL MORTALITY
FALLS MUCH MORE A MONTH BLACK
PARENTS AND THEN BROWN PARENTS
AND IN OUR NATIVE AMERICAN OR
INDIGENOUS PARENTS. SO WHAT SB
SIXTY FIVE DOES. IS IT CREATES
A PREGNANCY ASSOCIATION
MORTALITY REVIEW BOARD. AND IT
REQUIRES SOME DATA COLLECTION
SO THAT THAT REVIEW BOARD CAN
LOOK AT THAT COLLECT THAT DATA
AND TRY TO GET US A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S CAUSING
THESE THINGS SO WE CAN ADDRESS
IT IS THE FUTURE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. IT ALLOWS WORKING
PEOPLE TO STAY ON MEDICARE ALL
OF YEAR AFTER BIRTH AND IT
EXTENDS CAL WORKS TO LOW INCOME
PREGNANT PEOPLE WITH SOME
HIGHER MONTHLY STIPENDS AND
MAKES WORK OPTIONAL AND AS WE
KNOW OFTEN THINGS THAT
COMPLICATE BIRDS ARE LIKE HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE PREGNANCY
DIABETES OTHER ISSUES THOSE ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH IF
YOU'RE ALSO BEING REQUIRED TO
WORK TO AND KEEP YOUR MEDICAL
BENEFITS. THE LAST THING IT
DOES IS ALLOWS MEDICARE TO
COVER DO YOU LIKE HERE- FOR- TO
SUPPORT THOSE ARE NEW PARENTS
IN THOSE EARLY DAYS AND WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR MY
THREE TWO COULD YOU MOVE FROM
THE MARCH OF DIMES GEN LAURIE.
FROM WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE AHEAD WHEN YOU READY.
YOUR DOCTOR WHETHER MEMBERS FOR
HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS MUCH
AND IF YOU COULD BE IN LINE AND
THE MARCH OF DIMES MATERNAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU KNOW MARKET
I'M ONE OF THE OLDEST AND
LARGEST NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FIGHTING FOR THE HEALTH OF ALL
MOMS AND BABIES ON OUR ON GOING
WORK TO IMPROVE MATERNAL AND
INFANT HEALTH IS MORE IMPORTANT
NOW THAN EVER BECAUSE OUR
NATION IS IN THE MIDDLE THAT
DIRE MATERNAL INFANT HEALTH
CRISIS. MASON PRETEND BIRTH AND
MATERNAL MORTALITY ARE RISING
THAT'S ANOTHER THING TO
MENTION. DONNA FROM THE MARCH
OF DIMES SHOWS THAT THE PRETERM
BIRTH RATE. WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH AND
DEATH HAS TO RECKON FOR THE
FIFTH STRAIGHT YEAR AND THE US
CALIFORNIANS L. A. COUNTY.
EVERYTHING DATA MATERNAL
MORTALITY IN L. A. COUNTY
SUGGEST THAT THE. RATES ARE
RISING AS WELL. FURTHERMORE
THERE ARE. RACE THIS. COMPLY
OUTCOMES. LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
THE PRETERM BIRTH WE ROSE ONE
ALL RACIAL GROUPS STOPPER WHY
WOMEN IT'S A PATH ALL ESTO SHOW
THANK YOU AND MODEL COSTS FOR
BABIES BORN PRE. IT'S THREE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION
THE COMPANY TO PENTAMETER ONLY
WORK ON THE CRISIS AS PREGNANT
LATINA WOMEN WERE EXPECTED TO
HIGHER RATE. AN EDUCATION TO
CARE IN HEALTH BEHAVIOR COULD
NOT EXPLAIN THE BLACK WHITE GAP
AND BIRTH OUTCOMES. I HAVE
THREE SISTERS WE HAVE COLLEGE
DEGREES FROM UC BERKELEY
STANFORD AND DUKE WHERE BLACK
WOMEN NOT A PHYSICIAN SCIENTIST%
LOCAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. ALL HAS A THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WEEKS OUR LIVE
INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR WEEKS TO
TWENTY SEVEN WEEKS AND THIRTY
WEEKS STAR EDUCATION HEALTHY
DIET AND PRIVATE INSURANCE DID
NOT PROTECT US FROM DIFFICULT
CARE. AND POOR OUTCOMES. SHOULD
DRIVE VERY WHEN YOU
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSES BY
POLICY MAKERS. WE MUST IMPROVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY WITH BACKBONE
RESPONSIVE PERINATAL CARE
INCREASE ACCESS TO DEAL IN THE
REFEREE CARE INTERPRET THE FIRE.
PERINATAL CARE WORK WORK. YOU
MUST EXTENT FOR PARTY CARE TO
DRAFTING. MENTAL AND HEALTH
CONDITION. SUCH AS THE HYPE
PRESSURE. AND THE POST PARTUM
PERIOD. WE MUST MITIGATE SOCIAL
WITH THE HOW LIKE POP AND
STRESS. WE ALSO NEED IMPROVE
COLLECTION PERINATAL MORTALITY
MORBIDITY TEMPLATE.
INTERVENTIONS POLICY AND
SYSTEMS CHANGE AS- MARCHING
BAND PLEASE AT THE COURT AT
ACCUSED BY. WHAT YOU EXPECT AND
BASS THERE PROVEN HEALTH ISSUES
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH THE- WITH
SIXTY FIVE MATERNAL AND HELP.
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATORS WE
WANT TO MAKE STRIVE FOR THAT
PRETERM BIRTH PREVENTABLE
MATERNAL DEATHS IN THE DRIVE
PUBLIC BAGGIES THAT IMPACT ALL
CALIFORNIANS MARKET I'M READY
TO WORK WITH YOU TO ACHIEVE
THESE. GOALS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND OUR NEXT WITH PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR WEDDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M CHEN
CHLORINE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY ONE OF SB SIXTY
FIVE MANY CO SPONSORS TWO YEARS
AGO OVER A HUNDRED BLACK WOMEN
CAME TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DIGNITY IN PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH BACK AND STOOD UP
AND SAID BLACK WOMEN DESERVE
BETTER REFERRING TO THE
CHILDBIRTH EXPERIENCES THEY ARE
THEIR LOVED ONE CAN PASS.
FORTUNATELY NOT ONLY DID THIS
COMMITTEE DID A GREAT BUT SO TO
THE REST OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE GOVERNOR AND NOW PERFECT
NEEDLE PROVIDERS HAVE STARTED
UNDERGOING IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING. HOWEVER FOR GOING TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON DISPARITIES
THAT BLACK AND INDIGENOUS
BREAKING PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR
FAITH IT'S NOT JUST PROVIDER
TRAINING THAT IS NEEDED SB
SIXTY FIVE TO CALIFORNIA MOM
THE BEST BILLS INSPIRED BY
FEDERAL MOM THE BEST EFFORT
CAME FROM THE COSPONSORED MANY
SUPPORTERS AN AUTHOR PUTTING
OUR HEADS TOGETHER AND
THINKING. IF WE REALLY WANT TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON MATERNAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES WE'RE STILL
FACING IN THE STATE WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE WHY IS IT THAT DESPITE
HAVING SOME OF THE LOWEST MUCH
THAT MATERNAL MORTALITY AND
MORBIDITY RATES IN THE COUNTRY
WE'RE STILL FAILING WHEN WE
BREAK. THOSE STATISTICS DOWN BY
RIGHT. NOW WE'RE HAVING A NOW
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE PURVEY.
OF RACISM AND ITS EFFECTS ON
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDBIRTH IS THE JOY OF PROFIT
THAT SHOULD BE. NOT A PROCESS
THAT INVOLVES THE LOSS OF A
FAMILY MEMBER OR EVEN A NEAR
MISS. SB SIXTY FIVE ADDRESSES
THESE QUESTIONS TO THE-
FOLLOWING. WEEK CODIFYING
DISPATCHING A MATERNAL
MORTALITY REVIEW COMMITTEE MUCH
LIKE THE CURRENT ONE. THAT WE
CAN FOCUS REQUIRE A FOCUS ON
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND MORBIDITY AND
BRING ORE PEOPLE TO THE TABLE
TO EXAMINE THESE ISSUES TO
AVOID FUTURE MISTAKES. WE HAD A
FLOOR TO THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE FETAL
INFANT MORTALITY REVIEW
PROCESS. TO ENSURE THAT COUNTY
PARTICIPATING CAN GET THE DATA
THEY NEED AND WE'RE REVIEWING
ENOUGH CASES. WE EXPAND MEDI
CAL THE ALL PEOPLE FOR TWELVE
MONTHS AFTER THE PREGNANCY AND
TO PROVIDE MORE STABILITY AND
SECURITY AND ENSURE THE
MOTHER'S HEALTH NEEDS ARE
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED. WE
OFFERED YOU A TEN MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS TO HELP TRANSLATE
THE NEEDS OF THE PATIENT AND
ENSURE THAT SHE UNDERSTANDS HER
CHOICES. AND HER THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. WE HAD A FUNDED
TRAINED MIDWIVES TO ADDRESS THE
MATERNITY CARE SHORTAGE
CALIFORNIA FACING WHILE
REQUIRING A FOCUS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND WE
OFFER INCOME SUPPORT THROUGH
REFORMS TO THE CALYX PROGRAM
INCLUDING EMERGENCY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND A GUARANTEED
INCOME PILOT. STRUCTURAL RACISM
IS ENDEMIC IN OUR SOCIETY. AND
DOING IT THE FACTS AND REDUCING
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES
FACED BY BREAKING PEOPLE
REQUIRES A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH. FOR THESE REASONS WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY REGISTERED WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SO. BEING A
SECOND AB MOTION BY MISS-
AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY MISS
BURKE. WILL MOVE TO THE GALLERY
FOR ANYONE ELSE. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY. SEE NO ONE WILL MOVE
TO THE- PHONE LINES SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE. Q. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON SB SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY SIX
IN Q. OR TIMELINE TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT TRYING
NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS BUT THE ARMSTRONG
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WE ARE ACTUALLY IN
THE PHARMACY SUPPORTERS AMENDED
COMMISSION AS OUTLINED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS- BUT REMAIN COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS AND REALLY
HELP TO GET YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BYE ONE
NINETEEN FEES FOR HAS. THIRTY
ENTERED THE CALIFORNIA RECURSOS
CREATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
REMEMBER CATHY MOSSBERG WITH
THE CENTRAL ACCESS HELP AND
FIRST BY THE SITUATION OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE UP INTO
BLUE CROSS YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KELLY BROOK FROM THE HELP OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER THIRTY NINE EVENTS ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION BOTH PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PROBABLY BEING WITH HEALTH NOT-
IN SUPPORT SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT THREE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DIANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE ONE SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON- ALL REPUBLICANS HAVE
PLAYED CALIFORNIA WERE INSTRUCT
THE PART ABOUT THE FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
CALL I HAVE. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON FIFTY FOUR AND A HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MISSION ON
SAKHALIN GIRLS AND- INSTRUCTED
FOR SB SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN
KIRSTY WITH MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCIDENTS IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE TWO
EIGHT. BLANK THREE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE ZERO
FOUR. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD- ALAGI
PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND TWO
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE WORD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ALL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THEY ENDED
UP GOING OUT OF WHAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EMIGRATE
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY YOU DIDN'T EVEN
SAY MY NUMBER. IT'S SKIP OKAY I
DON'T REALLY THINK YOU GUYS
CARE ABOUT ANY WOMAN OTHER THAN
BLACK AND ASIAN I JUST WANT YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOHN MCCARTY
ON BEHALF OF THE PROBLEM THE
PRACTICE PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS FROM KATY BALLS
PRESIDENT AND CEO AFLAC
WELLNESS AND PROSPERITY CENTER
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF
FRESNO AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY
ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S MORGAN
WHITE GOOD AFTERNOON I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE BIRTH LIKELY
ADVOCACY PROJECT WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FIVE
AN AXE HERE ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE FIFTY ONE THREE FOUR
HAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ASIA OUTWARDS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL CALIFORNIA
DILLON THIRTY FIVE LOCATION
EDUCATION SPECIALIST AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL THE GATE
CLOSED BANKS THEIR APARTMENT
BURKE BUT MONITOR ACTION
PATRICK AT THE CUT BANK THERE
INSTRUCT THE PLAN SB. SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINANCIAL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ADRIANA JONES L. A. COUNTY-
AIMS AND MISSIONS GOOD
AFTERNOON AMERICAN INTO THE
MATERNAL MORTALITY INITIATIVE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
TWO OR NINE THREE IS FOR HAD.
MY NAME IS EILEEN RIGHT I
REPRESENT EMBRACE GREEK
MINISTRIES THE CANYON HELP THE
VOICE OF GOD AND KERN COUNTY I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE SELF THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THE BRIGHT GREEN JEEP.
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
DELTA RODRIGUEZ WOULD BE EITHER
YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE
LINE TWO OR THREE THREE IS GLAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MAC MILLER AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MARCH OF DIMES AND
ALSO THE CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
CARE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I AM SURE TO PLEASE
GLAD. FOUR NINE WHERE TEACH
TRAINING EARLY ABORTION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE THREE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ONE OF OAK- WITH THE ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF IT DIFFICULT BUT- THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE GONZALEZ
MY MENTAL SUPPORT SB SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE TWO EIGHT. WELL
YES PLEASE YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON- TURN MEMBERS THE
BACK OF TO THE LEFT I THINK YOU
ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF GENDER
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES AND THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT YEAH THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GLAD.
HELLO YES YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WEBN FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING IN A STRONG
SUPPORTER SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. OF US ARE A- WAS
QUICK IT WAS TOO QUICK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE SORRY
MAIL BE QUICK- I WHEN IT IS OUT
ON AS A CO AUTHOR I THINK ALL.
BECAUSE CERTAIN TESTIMONY
MANAGED EVERYTHING ELSE. I MEAN
CLEARLY YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
THAT. AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE A
TWICE AS HIGH IN THE CURRENT
MORTALITY RATE AND THAT'S A
CONTINUE CONCERNED THIS BILL
THEM ON A BUS FELL. FOR SOMEONE.
WHO'S NEVER ACTUALLY GIVEN
BIRTH TO A CHILD I. THE BOARD.
BUT ALSO REALLY IMPORTANTLY
JUST NEVER GOTTEN TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE MORTALITY RATE FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND IT'S LONG
PAST DO SO THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY THE FIGURE CURRY.
WELL FIRST I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE SENATOR OF SKINNER
ON THE ARRIVAL OF HER NEW
GRANDDAUGHTER FIRST OF ALL.
SECOND OF ALL IS THAT I'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
WITH A GLADLY. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. SEE NO ONE THE BILL- THE
JOYS OF DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
IT- WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE
YORK CURRY A SECOND BY- MISS-
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
HUMAN SERVICES WHICH LIKE CLOSE
THANKS SO MUCH I THINK WE KNOW
THAT THIS UNFORTUNATELY THAT
DISPARITY IS REGARDLESS OF
INCOME OR EDUCATION OF THOSE OF
US WHO FOLLOWED THE BIRTH OF A
SERENA WILLIAMS EXPERIENCE
READING BEYOND TODAY'S. AND US
CERTAINLY- WE WANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO SUPPORT ALL BIRTHING
PARENTS SO WITHOUT ASTEROID
VOTE AND DEFINITELY WILL
INCLUDE THE TO CALL OUT TO
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU A
MAN SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WHAT I MAYES.
MAYES I THANK YOUR CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I GARCIA. BIGELOW
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO
EYEING FLORIDA. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. SIX ZERO IF SIX VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL AND
WILL- IT'S LIKE TO GO ON TO
YOUR NEXT BILL SB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR THANKS SO MUCH SHARE- I
THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT
IF WE IF ANY OF US HAVE A
PHARMACIST OR PHARMACY THAT
WE'VE HAD A LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WE HAVE
USED TO GET OUR PRESCRIPTIONS
FILLED AT THE PHARMACY IS
WITHIN OUR HEALTH INSURANCE
NETWORK THE WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO USE IT. AND SO WHAT SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR DOES IS IT
PROHIBITS PATIENT BENEFIT
MANAGERS PATIENT BENEFIT
MANAGERS OR ENTITIES THAT
HEALTH INSURERS SOMETIMES
CONTRACT WITH AND- THERE THE
PURPOSE IS TO YOU KNOW HELP A I
ENSURE THAT WE GET COSTS AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR HEALTH INSURERS
WANT TO DO THAT- BUT THOSE
PATIENT BENEFIT MANAGERS HAVE
GONE IN THE DIRECTION OF TRYING
TO STEER PATIENTS TO PARTICULAR
PHARMACIES AND BASICALLY
TELLING THE PATIENT THAT YOU
CAN USE NO PHARMACY EXCEPT. X.
AND THE OTHER UNFORTUNATE FACT
IS THAT MANY OF THESE PATIENT
BENEFIT MANAGERS ARE ACTUALLY
THE OWNERS OF PHARMACY ENTITIES
LIKE CVS. NOW CERTAINLY IF YOU
USE CVS. YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
AND YOU WANT TO GREAT. BUT TO
BE REQUIRED TO USE A PARTICULAR
PHARMACY WHETHER IT'S A MAIL
ORDER ONE OR WHAT. WHEN YOU
HAVE A PHARMACY IN YOUR NETWORK
THAT IS PREFERABLE TO YOU.
THERE IS NO REASON THAT YOU
SHOULD BE FORCED TO NOTE THIS
BILL. ALLOWS STILL THE PATIENT
BENEFIT MANAGER OR THE INSURER
TO OFFER A DISCOUNT THROUGH
THEIR PREFERRED PHARMACY
THERE'S NO PROHIBITION ON THAT
IT JUST PROHIBITS. REQUIRING
YOU TO GO TO ONE PHARMACY ONE
PHARMACY ONLY AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO HAVE MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND THAT IS JIM GROSS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AND CRAIG POST FOR
FROM A P. LA HEALTH. FOR WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
SKINNER I WILL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. HI THIS IS A JIM GROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION. AND
PERSON WANT TO THANK GOD
SENATOR SKINNER FOR TAKING ON
THIS ISSUE. I ALSO WANT TO-
COMPLEMENT THE- COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND VERY THOROUGH AND
VERY WELL DONE AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT- THE- PATIENT'S
JERRY SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT.
EVERY DAY IT'S EXPECTED ACCESS
MEDICATION ADHERENCE. IN THE
FUTURE OF A ROBUST MARKET OF
PHARMACY SERVICES WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT OUR DIVERSE.
COMMUNITIES- THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT NOW AND SO OF THEIR
HELP PARTNER. ARE DENYING THE
RIGHT USE THE PHARMACY OF THEIR
CHOICE AND TO MAKE CLEAR EVEN
THOUGH THOSE PHARMACIES HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THOSE PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGERS AND HEALTH
PLANS TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT A CONSUMER CAN
USE A PHARMACY THAT IS NOT IN
THE PHARMACY IN THE PLAN'S
NETWORK THESE ARE IN THE PLAN'S
NETWORK EACH SIGN CONTRACTS. BE
GOT CONSUMERS THE ENROLLEES
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT AND THEN
GENERALLY SPEAKING OUT OF THE
BLUE AND WE HAVE PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE THAT WE PROVIDED. A
CONSUMERS TOLD THEY MUST GO TO
A DIFFERENT PHARMACY WAR
THERE'S A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
FOR SOME REASON THAT PHARMACY
IS NOT ALLOWED TO DISPENSE THAT
DRUGS AND IF YOU WANTED FROM
THAT PHARMACY THAT YOU'VE BEEN
GOING TO FOR YEARS YOU'LL HAVE
TO PAY OUT OF POCKET ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. YEAH WE KNOW
THE PBMS HAVE. SAID THAT THIS
BILL IS DENYING CONSUMER CHOICE
AND THAT'S JUST NOT ACCURATE
IT'S ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE THAT
PATIENCE. IS DENYING THE CHOICE
BECAUSE IF IN FACT YOU ARE
GIVEN NO CHOICE BUT TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE EVEN THOUGH YOU
HAVE A RIGHT BY CONTRACT. TO GO
TO THE PHARMACY BEEN GOING TO
THE CHOICE IS BEING DENIED BY
THE PBM OR THE HEALTH PLAN. AND
I THINK THAT THAT. WE REALLY
BELIEVE THEY WANT TO CONTROL
THE PHARMACEUTICAL DOLLAR- D.
OWNERSHIP BY ONE ENTITY ABOARD
A PBM AND A PHARMACY AND AN
INFUSION PHARMACY AND EVEN
HEALTH PLAN TOGETHER. AND THAT
DOES EXIST IN THE MARKET THAT
KIND OF CONTROL REALLY MAKES IT
SO THEY WANT TO STEER THE
PATIENT TO MAIL ORDER OR BRICK
AND MORTAR DETAIL. AND THAT
TAKES AWAY COMPETITION AS WELL.
NOW SENATOR SKINNER SAID. IF
THESE PHARMACY BENEFIT. AND
HEALTH PLANS ONE THOSE CA. THEY
CAN ALL THEM FINDING IT'S SUCH
A REDUCTION IN OR LIVE OF A CO
PAY- TO GO TO THAT FOR. THAT
THERE TO THE TWO AMERICANS. IF
YOU DO THIS THIS ISN'T THE- IN
SENATE DID YOU GET NOW WE HAVE
THAT SPECIFICALLY IN THE BILL
BUT IT HAS TO BE A DIRECT
BENEFIT TO THE CONSUMER CAN'T
BE AT THE REAL WE SAVE LOTS OF
MONEY. BOB I THINK THAT THE
OLDER. MARKET IS THAT. WE ARE
BEING PUT IN A POSITION AS
PHARMACISTS. TO NOT ONLY LOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
CUSTOMERS THAT WE BELIEVE WE
ARE TIRED OF THE BY CONTRACT.
WILL PUT IN A VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION OF SANE TO OUR OWN
CUSTOMERS. I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO DO THAT ANYMORE YOU
HAVE TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE OUT
SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT YOU KNOW
ORDER WHICH- CAN BE DEFINED FOR
SOME- CONSUMERS BUT NOT FOR
OTHERS OR TO BE A PHARMACY.
THAT IS ACROSS TOWN FOR ONE
THAT IS IN A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
FOLKS. ARE NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
THERE ARE VARIOUS REASONS WHY
PEOPLE CHOOSE A PARTICULAR
PHARMACY WE ARE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND IF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE BELIEVE WE'RE
PROVIDING VALUE. AND THESE
MONOPOLISTIC. PARA BUYERS. YEAH
ARE YOU THESE- ARE NOT IN THE
BEST AND OF THE KIDS. SO WE ASK
YOU I DON'T. THANK YOU SO MUCH
IN CENTER SKINNER I THINK WE
HAVE A SECOND WITNESS IN
SUPPORT IS THAT CORRECT YES
THERE'S A SECOND WITNESS THANK
YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRACKPOTS FROM
BEHALF OF THE KLA HEALTH AND
ACCURACY IN ONE OF THE LARGEST
HIV SERVICE PROVIDERS AND L. A.
COUNTY. TODAY OKAY MY COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY ON HOW PATIENTS
DURING THE IMPACT PEOPLE WITH
HIV. AND OTHER CHRONIC
CONDITIONS- MOST IMPORTANTLY
THIS PRACTICE UNDERMINE THE
REALLY CRITICAL RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN PATIENTS AND THEIR
PHARMACISTS. MANY PATIENTS
DEPEND ON THIS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP SOMEONE THEY'VE
KNOWN FOR YEARS. TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT SIDE
EFFECTS. AND TO HELP THEM
REMAIN INSURANCE THEIR
MEDICATION. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR PEOPLE WITH HIV AND
OTHER CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
PATIENTS DERIAN PREVENTS
PATIENTS FROM FILLING THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS WITH A PHARMACIST
THEY KNOW. AND YOU UNDERSTAND.
THEIR UNIQUE MEDICAL HISTORY.
CATIONS HEARING ALSO OCCUR UP
PRIVATE ISSUE ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN THOSE LIVING IN MORE RURAL
AREAS. IF THE PATIENT CAN'T
PICK UP THE MEDICATION AT THE
PHARMACY OF CHOICE. AND
ESPECIALLY IF THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO USE MAIL ORDER SOMEONE COULD
FIND OUT ABOUT THEIR MEDICAL
CONDITION WHICH COULD LEAD TO
DISCRIMINATION FAMILY REJECTION
AND EVEN VIOLENCE AND IT IS
PRECISELY FOR THESE REASONS THE
MANDATORY MAIL ORDER
REQUIREMENTS. HAVE LONG BEEN
RECOGNIZED TO BE AN APPROPRIATE
EVENT I'M LAWFUL FOR PEOPLE
WITH HIV. AND LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE
OF PATIENTS BEEN ABLE TO PICK-UP THEIR MEDICATION AT THE
PHARMACY WHERE THEY FEEL SAFE
WHERE THE PHARMACIST SPEAKS OUR
LANGUAGE. AND WHERE THEY KNOW
THEY'LL BE TREATED WITH RESPECT
NOT HAVING A CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROVIDER IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST REASONS THE PEOPLE
FALL OUT OF CARE. THE ENGINEERS
OF COLOR AND PATIENT MUST BE
GIVEN THE OPTION TO RECEIVE
THEIR MEDICATION FROM A
PHARMACY WHERE THEY WILL KNOW
WHERE THEY KNOW THEY WILL
RECEIVE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
CARE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
PRESS P. FIVE TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE- TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I THINK WE HAVE- MISTER BILL
HAD. MISTER BAD CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME IS BILL HAD SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL
CARE MANAGEMENT. ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR. WE STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH
THE PREMISE OF PATIENT STEERING
WHEN A HEALTH PLAN OR A PBM ON
THE HEALTH AND BEHALF OF A
HEALTH PLAN. COMMUNICATION TO
BENEFICIARIES. WE ARE SIMPLY-
COMMUNICATING THE PLAN BENEFIT
DESIGN OUTLINED IN THE PLAN
THAT THE PATIENT AND WALDRON SO
THIS HAPPENED OUT OF THE BLUE.
OR VIOLATION OF THE CONTRACT IN
RALEIGH- OF THE BENEFICIARY AND
WALDRON ON THE CONTRARY IS
CONVEYING EXACTLY THE BENEFIT
DESIGN THAT INDIVIDUAL CHOSE TO
LIVE IN ROME. SB FIVE POINT
FOUR WOULD LIVE THE- PM CAN
OFFERED TO HELP PLAN SPONSORS
SUCH AS POTENTIALLY EVEN OPT
OUT MAY FOURTH. THIS IS
IMPORTANT HEALTH PLANS USED TO
DESTRUCTION THEIR HEALTH PLAN
DOLLARS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE BENEFICIARIES HAPPENED
DOLLARS. THAT ABILITY IS NOT
GOING TO DECREASED AFTER
PASSING THE CONTRARY THE CENTER
INCREASED TAX MATTERS FOR THE
HEALTH PLAN. FOR THE
BENEFICIARY AND LIMITING THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS WERE FURTHER
IMPEDE HEALTH PLANS ABILITY AND
PM CENTER WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
PATIENTS AND HEALTH PLANS. TO
ATTEND PASSED- WE CERTAINLY BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE
ON AMENDMENTS TO IMPROVE THE
BILL BUT THIS TIME. THERE'S A
COMMITTEE TO ANOTHER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK THE
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESS WAS-
PRESTON YOUNG. UP IN THE
GALLERY MISTER ROGER ALL THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE TO FOUR. NOW THE
OVERARCHING CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE WITH SB FIVE TO FOUR AND
THE REASON FOR OUR OPPOSITION
IS THAT THE BILL WOULD ERODE
THE INCENTIVE EMPLOYERS HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS HAVE. TO
DESIGN A PARTICIPATING PHARMACY
NETWORKS. IS NETWORKS INCLUDE
MAIL ORDER PHARMACIES CHAIN
PHARMACIES AND INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES. AND THEY HELP
CONTROL PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS
FOR PATIENTS IN ADDITION TO
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES. SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR DISRUPT THIS
BENEFIT DESIGN AND THE CHOICES
PLAN PARTICIPANTS MAKE TO
REDUCE PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS
WHICH ARE SUBSTANTIAL.
ACCORDING TO THE DAMAGE THE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ACCOUNTED
FOR TWELVE POINT 7% OF TOTAL
HEALTH PLAN PREMIUMS. IF THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS IN THESE
NETWORKS ARE REDUCED. THE COST
CONTROLS OF THE WEEKEND AND
UNFORTUNATELY WALL SB FIVE TO
FOUR IS WELL INTENTIONED. IT
WILL ACT AS A HEALTH CARE COST
DRIVER. IN ADDITION ARE. COST
CONCERNS WERE ALSO OPPOSED SB
FIVE TO FOUR BECAUSE IT
ATTEMPTS TO REGULATE. HOW SELF
INSURED PLAN DESIGNS BENEFITS
THIS IS GOVERNED BY A WRITTEN A
RESIDENT FREE UP TO BUY FEDERAL
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED SB FIVE TO FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY. ON THIS BILL SEE NO
ONE WILL GO AHEAD MOVED TO THE
PHONE LINES MADAM OPERATOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HIS NAME AN
ORGANIZATIONALLY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON SB FIVE TO
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT TEN LINES IN Q. WILL GO
TO RYAN AT THREE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND TO ALL FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEFF HANDOUT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE TO FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK THREE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR DESK WELCOME AT ALL BUT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU NINETEENTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANKS TWO ONE NINE. OR
NOT. LET ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER GETTING IT RIGHT
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH YES
PLEASE DON'T FIND ANYTHING MY
NAME IS DANIEL AND I THOUGHT HE
THREW THE BALL. YEAH TWO SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOUNG
REPRESENTS YOUR LIFE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THEIR MEMBERS JUSTIN
RANDALL CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH COMMITTEE ON GAP
OF CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE ORANGE COUNTY
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND SAN DIEGO HISPANIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE PEOPLE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
CHORE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE NEW ALLENSTEIN REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RYAN ONE EIGHTY NINE
THE SCHOOL HAS. ONE ONE EIGHT
NINE HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYONE WHO IS
TRAIN SHOULD BE INCOMPETENT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THANK YOU
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ONLY FACTOR ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN G. A
PLAN AND W. P. P. UC SANTA
MARIA AND LEE LAST. IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS ERIN RIGHT WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURERS INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
WELL THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. C.
SEVEN OR- SEEING NONE- WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS THE BILL ENJOYS
A TO PASS RECOMMENDATION WHICH
I TO CLOSE SENATOR THANK YOU I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTETHANK YOU
VERY MUCH SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROL WOOD HI. WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA. GARCIA I BIGELOW BURKE
BURKE I'D CARILLO. FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
SIX ZERO SIX BOTH WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU THINK
HERE. AND NEXT UP IS A SENATOR
SENATOR DORADO. SB FIFTY SIX
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MEMBERS SB
FIFTY SIX HEALTH FOR ALL
SENIORS IS A BILL THAT WILL
INCLUDE SENIORS AGES SIXTY AND
UP IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
REGARDLESS OF STATUS WHO MEET
ALL OTHER REQUIREMENTS. MEMBERS
THESE ARE CALIFORNIANS THAT
OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM TO MAKE LESS THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR BUT ARE BARRED FROM THIS
BASIC MEDICAL PROGRAM DUE TO
THEIR DOCUMENTATION STATUS
DESPITE THE TREMENDOUS ADVANCES
TO REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S
UNINSURED RATE. DOWN TO A
HISTORIC LOW OF SIX POINT 8%
THE UNINSURED RATES ARE STILL
EXCEEDINGLY HIGH AMONGST
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS. WHO
HAVE ALSO THE SMALLEST
PERCENTAGE OF EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HEALTH CARE. ALMOST TWO THIRDS
OF UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
LIVE HAVE LIVED IN THE U. S.
FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS. MORE
THAN HALF OR A MIX THAT IS
FAMILIES MEANING UNDOCUMENTED
PARENT OR GRANDPARENT. CAN TAKE
THEIR CHILD OR GRANDCHILD TO
THE DOCTOR WHEN THEY'RE SICK
BUT THE PARENT A GRANDPARENT
CANNOT DO THE SAME FOR
THEMSELVES. THEY ARE ONLY
ELIGIBLE AND WE ARE REQUIRED TO
PAY FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. AND PREGNANCY CARE
BUT THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
PREVENTATIVE CARE FOR
CONDITIONS SUCH AS ASTHMA
DIABETES OR HEART CONDITION.
LEAVING THEM WITH THE LAST
RESORT OF EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
ONCE THE CONDITIONS ARE AT
THEIR WORST THIS DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. FAR MORE TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
PREVENTIVE SERVICES- THEY
CONTRIBUTE OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES TO FUND PROGRAMS LIKE
MEDICARE. YET THEY ARE EXCLUDED
THEMSELVES. UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS SUCH AS ASTHMA AND
HEART DISEASE CAN BE TREATED TO
AVOID HIGHER COSTS ON THE
SYSTEM AND AVOID SUFFERING AND
OVERALL IT'S A BENEFIT TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH TO HAVE A
HEALTHFUL HEALTHY. A COLLECTIVE
SOCIETY. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED HOW
DEVASTATING THE LACK OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS ESPECIALLY AMONG
THE MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS AND
IMMIGRANTS HAS BEEN. THEY ARE
NOT STATISTICS THEY ARE
CALIFORNIANS THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING IS FAR GREATER THAN THE
COST OF PROVIDING COVERAGE. OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WORKS BEST
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WORKS
BEST WHEN ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- WE HAVE
HERE PRESENT A WHOLE SAID DORIS
GOT IT GARCIA LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH ACCESS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AND
BY PHONE I HAVE MY VEHICLE- FOR
US- FROM CODEC- IN THE
LANGUAGE. BUDAPEST JEFF- ALSO
FROM CODEC WILL PROVIDE
TRANSLATION IS ALBERT GROUP
THIS. THAT'S RIGHT OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S GO TO WILL
GO TO THE GALLERY FIRST. RIGHT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSE TORRES ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION AND A CO SPONSOR
SUPPORTER OF SB FIFTY SIX.
WHICH WOULD EXPAND FOR SCHOOL
MEDIC HOW TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE OLDER ADULTS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE OR
FULL SCHOOL MEDIC HOW. THAT
PROVIDE ACCESS TO ROUTINE
PRIMARY AND PREVENTIVE CARE.
THEY ARE ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR
RESTRICTED SCOPE MEDICARE WHICH
COVERS EMERGENCY ROOM CARE THE
EMERGENCY ROOM IS THE LEAST
EFFICIENT. MOST EXPENSIVE WAY
TO PROVIDE CARE AND NOT A
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS COVERED
UNDER FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL. AS A
RESULT UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
REMAIN UNINSURED LIV STECKER
DIE YOUNGER AND R. ONE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY AWAY FROM FINANCIAL
RUIN. OUR OLDER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE GROUP. CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM PUBLIC COVERAGE
PROGRAMS PARTICULAR AREA RISKY
RECOVER NINETEEN. AND THEY ARE
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE EXACERBATED
CONDITIONS IF THEY EVEN SURVIVE
THE VIRUS. BY EXPANDING
COVERAGE TO UNDOCUMENTED OLDER
ADULTS WE CAN BE ON THE- THANK.
BY EXPANDING COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS WE
CAN BE ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
HEALTH CARE EQUITY. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
SB FIFTY SIX. AND I ALSO ASK
THAT THE REMAINING TIME BE
GIVEN TO OUR OTHER WITNESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES AND- FOR OUR
OUR NEXT WITNESS. YEAH I MEAN
THE HE NAME MIGHT BE AT THE
OFFICE GOING NAY. HE MADE ME
AND MADE SHOWING THE ORGANISM.
HE'S GOT HE MADE. GUMBEL
TALLAHASSEE CAN. GREENDALE
WHICH I IT KEEPS- SEMI BODY
WORK CHECK ON. WHICH IS IN IN
MY AREA UP I'M WILL TO TRY AND
GET THE. IN THE NORTH SEEM TO
MEETING MADE MY MONDAY. IN DAY
I'M I AM BEYOND THE LEGION THE-
HE WON THE SECOND PRIZE. TURN I
BY TUESDAY- HOW DO I TELL BY
THE THEY YEAH I MEAN WHO WHO
WHO REPORTS QUICKLY EVEN THEIR-
IN THEIR SIDE WOULD BAR BUT I
TOLD. AND THE LATEST EVEN WHOLE
PROPERTY BEING IN HUNDRED
FARMING CAN HAVE LOT OF THE-
YEAH I KNOW THINK WE CAN PUT
THAT IN. IMPRIMA WHO GOT HIM TO.
EVEN EVEN- HOPING APPLE FACTOR
DAYS WHICH ARE HAD A LOT OF
TIME- IT WOULD CHAIRED. PRETTY
BOY MAJORITY. HE HAD COME HEIDI
GARCIA. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
MARIA CLOSE I AM A FIFTY NINE
YEAR I LIVE IN THE KERR AREA
I'M A MEMBER OF THE
ORGANIZATION TOLD OF WORKING
THE CALL. FIELD OVER TWO SEVEN
YEARS I AM STILL WORKING AT THE
WORKER DURING THE HEAT WAVE. A
COUPLE OF MY FRIENDS THE- AND
WE'RE TAKING TO THE ANIMAL.
DIDN'T HAVE MEDICAL EITHER
BECAUSE OF THE IMAGE THAT. AND
FEEL HIGH CALL HEALTHCARE. I AM
CALLING TO. THAT YOU OF HELP
FOR ALL. THIS WILL HELP ME FOR
MY- BECAUSE I AM IN OLDER. INFO
PERFORMED. AND OTHER CHRONIC-
IN THE I CANNOT. TO PAY DOCTORS
VISITS AND- WHAT EARNED THE
FIELD IS NOT ENOUGH. TOOL FOR
GETTING SICK TO PAY MEDICAL
TRIMS AND A- I ACTUALLY HAVE.
WE CAN COUNTRY TO HELP ONLY TO
THAT ARE UNDER- AND HAVE BEEN
WERE. IN THE FIELD CALIFORNIA.
EMPAIN ARE TRYING TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO HANNAH
BETH OFF ON A REPRESENTING CAL
BOYCE'S TODAY WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB. FIFTY SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN WORST
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW AND JUST BE ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. AND WE
WILL BE LIMITING IF IT GOES
ALONG TO TWENTY MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY. WRECKED AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE SAID ANYBODY WHO WHO
MIGHT BE LEFT OUT COULD ALWAYS
SEND US A LETTER THROUGH OUR
PORTAL AND- WE'RE HAPPY O
REGISTER THAT- POSITION SO.
WITH THAT- MADAM- OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON SB FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
REWIND THAT THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT FORTY LINES
IN Q. OR WALK OR TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BENEFITTED HANNAH
WOULD KEEP THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
POSITION FROM CONCORD ABOUT THE
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE NEW JERSEY MEMBERS JUSTIN
MERAM THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PARODIUS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THOSE THE ASIAN IN
SUPPORT. Q. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHAF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR ON BEHALF OF MIND FOR
CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE REPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BETTY
ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE
TECHNICIAN IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
GET THE MOST BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T
EVEN BUT I'VE DONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND THE HELP FROM THE
POLLUTION STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
BRAMBELL SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT THREE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SURE
NUMBER SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT THREE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHECK THE- ALPHABETICAL ISSUE
ORDER THAT THE FIFTY P. Q.
NEXTCODE. FIND THREE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS TO MADDEN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE TERM MEMBERS ADAM KADMON ON
BEHALF OF THE ULTIMATE HEALTH
SERVICES WHERE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS ARE THIRTY THREE NEED A
LESSON CAL WITH GENDER JUSTICE
LOS ANGELES AND OCCUPIED TICKET
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT NOW FOR A FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ONE CRITICAL TROUBLED CHILDHOOD
ACCESS FROM LOS ANGELES AND
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS FOR A SECOND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CBO BALLOTS WITH PULSE OX
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TWO OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE PRINTER MEMBERS
JEFF HAMPTON CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
THAT WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY AT
THE NETFLIX- CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE. THE
FOURTEENTH. SIX YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TRYING TO FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHO ARE GOD
WILL BE WITH YOU KNOW COALITION
FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA CALLING
INSTRUCTABLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM WOOD
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW
MUCH I HAVE TO PAY FOR EVERYONE
HUGE. NINE THREE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MAHLANGU BURKE
NIELSEN LOOKS MORE ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THE COUNTY
OPINION GO AND LA CARE HEALTH
PLAN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI WE TEACH TRAINING IN EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTHCARE IN STOCK. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND THREE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
ZERO EIGHT. SKEWS ME THREE ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEP NO
DANGER MEMBERS OUT THERE AT YOU
GET IF YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT IN TWO OR THREE
PLEASE GO ASK. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KELLY MCMILLAN AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAM TAYLOR
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LET ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MY NAME'S ALEXANDER
CLUTCHING I'MA RESIDENT OF
GERMAN WOULD DISTRICT IN SANTA
ROSA AND A BIRTH DOULA CARE
GIVER FOR SENIORS AND A MEDIC
CAL RECIPIENT AND ALSO THE
FIRST GENERATION U. S. IT'S AN
BY BIRTH AND THEN MY FAMILY AND
I AM IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WE DON'T KNOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS FOR A LOT OF ENTRIES
GLAD. NINE FOUR ONE ONE. HELLO
MY NAME AND LOOK AT THE ABLE
I'M CALLING FROM BUILDINGS
LEGAL CENTER OUT OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY SIX O'CLOCK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TWO SEVENTY THREE
THREE FOUR HAVE. ME TO SEE WHAT
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE
OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOULD BE ALLOWED
WITH CALIFORNIANS USABLE STATE
TRONG IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS DOMINIQUE IRAQI
REPRESENTING THE WOMAN ABOUT
I'M SORRY FOR THEM IN THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND- WE AGREE WITH
ABOUT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS GOOD BUT I YEAH I AM A
MEMBER TODD AGAIN I AM CALLING
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I WON TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME STATES
JOHNSON I'M CALLING FOR
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG AND INDIVISIBLE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS FOR TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS KNOW F. BOTTOM
ALL WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BRIAN FOUR OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE NOW
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT HERE NOT
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OKAY NEXTCODE ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINALLY
REOPENED PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA WERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND FOR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHERE MEMBERS.
I AM CALLING SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE FOR- TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER OF CLINIC AND I'M
CALLING TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND
SPEAKING THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MEDIA BORN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION AND THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU NEXT CALL. NINE ONE NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PARKER DUNCAN
FAMILY POSITIONS IN SANTA ROSA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE ANY TO ORGANIZATIONS THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
TYPICALLY ADVOCACY OF THE
MECHANIC AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BENEFIT THAT I'M WITH
THE MYSTICAL AND WE CANNOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT
AND STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS FOR TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THE
COUPON BOOK- BUT WITH THE LINE
CALIFORNIA FOR COMPARTMENT
EIGHT AND THE PORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIVE FOUR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO OUT.
IT'S BROUGH CALLING FROM
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M CALLING
IN TO GET MY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FOUR SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY AME IS
KARINA WITH THE LANGUAGE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS COALITION AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THE
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT FOR EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PATRICIA MONDRAGON FROM THE
BEAUTIFUL BORDER REGION OF SAN
DIEGO ALSO A FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN BY BIRTH AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FOUR NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
EUGENE KANSEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
EVERYONE STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT FOR TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
IN THE BACK WAY AND WHAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE FOR
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BARBARA PLATE
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND SB
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT FOUR TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CENTAMIN GIRLS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLINDS FOR
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
JUAN CARLOS FROM MEXICO AND THE
UNITED COMMUNITY ARE CONNECTION
PROJECTS IN OXNARD CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DIANA CLINIC CALLING
ON THE MULTI FAITH ACTION
COALITION IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO AHEAD AND BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF. THE BILL I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT WE HAD. WAITED
WE HAVE A- PROMOTION FOR MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND FROM
MISTER NAZARIAN THE BILL ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION-
SENATOR DRAWS A WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SENATOR- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. POLLUTION BY
MISTAKE YOUR CURRENT OPEN SORRY.
I'D LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
ROOM SENATOR IF THAT WOULD BE
OKAY. WE WILL SPROUT. MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HI I WOULD LIKE THE SAME
AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THIS
HERCULEAN TASK AND- GETTING US
ONE MORE STEP CLOSER TO.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE THANK YOU.
AND ENTER PERSISTENCE- THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MADAM SECRETARY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MISTER
NAZARIAN MOTION DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD I AM MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA GARCIA HI BIGELOW. BURKE
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN HIGH RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SIZE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. SIX ZERO YES SIX BOTH
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
TANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR ON
BEHALF OF OUR SENIORS THANK YOU
ALL. THANK YOU. AND NOW- AFTER
HAVING- I'M SORRY HI. I DIDN'T
SEE YOU BACK THERE SO SENATOR
GONZALEZ PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB TWO FOUR FIVE WHICH
WILL REQUIRE ALL STATE LICENSED
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
ISSUED AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO COVER ABORTION AND ABORTION
RELATED SERVICES WITHOUT A
COPAYMENT DEDUCTIBLE OR ANY
TYPE OF COST SHARING.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LONG- THE
LEADER IN PROTECTING AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WELL THESE EFFORTS
HAVE HELPED MAINTAIN THIS RIGHT
FOR DECADES THERE ARE STILL
NUMEROUS BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
THESE SERVICES INCLUDING
AFFORDABILITY. HEALTH PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER ABORTION
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA AS WE
KNOW BUT THEY CAN STILL CHARGE
HIGH DEDUCTIBLES AND CO PAYS
THAT CAN RANGE FROM FORTY
DOLLARS TO THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. A FIVE YEAR STUDY
CONDUCTED BYUCSF OF ONE
THOUSAND WOMEN SEEKING ABORTION
CARE AT THIRTY FACILITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOUND THAT
OVER HALF OF THE WOMEN HAD OUT
OF POCKET EXPENSES. OF MORE
THAN ONE THIRD OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME SB TWO FORTY FIVE WILL
REMOVE THIS BARRIER AND ALLOW
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS
THEIR LEGAL RIGHT TO
SERVICES BY ENSURING THAT
HEALTH PLANS CAN'T REQUIRE COST
SHARING. FOR THE SERVICES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE DOCTORS THERE ROBERTS WITH
THE BIXBY CENTER FOR GLOBAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AT UCSF.
AND BELLA CAL MORE A
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ACTUALLY FACE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
CARE THANK YOU- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR SO YOU DO HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND- HEAR THE WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. ON THE PHONE.
WONDER OPENED. THANK GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SARAH ROBERTS AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY AND
REPRODUCTIVE SCIENCES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. I THINK THE IMPACT
THE STATE LEVEL ABORTION
POLICIES. AND A PUBLISHED MORE
THAN FIFTY PEER REVIEWED
ARTICLES ABOUT ABORTION
INCLUDING MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
THAT DIRECTLY EXAMINE THE
IMPACT OF STATE LEVEL ABORTION
POLICIES. MY RESEARCH AS WELL
AS OTHER PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
FINDS THAT THE COSTS OF COURSE
AND MY SIGNIFICANT BERRIER
PEOPLE SAY BEING ABLE TO YOU
KNOW THE PERSON. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT HAVING TO PAY THESE COSTS
CAN IMPACT PEOPLE IF YOU BUY IT-
IS COST EFFECTIVE OTHER AREAS
OF PEOPLE'S LIVES. THE PEOPLE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
HAVING TO COME UP WITH THE
MONEY TO PAY FOR AN ABORTION
OUT OF POCKET IF THE PEOPLE
HAVE TO DO THINGS LIKE PUT OFF
A FOR GROPING. RENT A BUYING
SAID. SECOND COP INTERVIEW TO
DELAY IT. AND ONE OF THE THIRTY
THEY MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY MORE
THAN HALF OF THE PARTICIPANTS
REPORTED THAT HAVING TO RAISE
MONEY TO PAY FOR THE ABORTION
BUT- IT'S AND THEY WERE DELAYED.
WHEN PEOPLE WORK THROUGH
PORTION FUND YOUR FAMILY. THE
MAN ABOUT THE PREGNANCY IT'S
RAISE MONEY TO PAY FOR AN
ABORTION. IT CAN TAKE AWHILE TO
GET THE MONEY TOGETHER. IF
PEOPLE ARE DELAYED INTO THE
SECOND TRIMESTER THE COST OF AN
ABORTION I THOUGHT. WHICH CAN
THEN LEAD TO FURTHER DELAY WILL
WORK IT'S A QUESTION OF MONEY.
AS A TWENTY YEAR OLD EXPLAINED
TO US ONE PART OF IT. I GET
PAID EVERY WEEK. EVERY TIME I
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IT ALL GETS
TAKEN OUT IMPACT. THANK JUST
UNDER THE AMOUNT I NEED. EVERY
TIME I TRY TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT I'M SICK OF THE
FACT THAT I HAVE TO PAY. THIRD
MY PEOPLE CAME BURSTING COSTS
BUT SOME DO NOT. SOME PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE OF THE POPULATION
RAISING THE MONEY I'M A
PROFITABLE PERSON GOES UP SO
MUCH IN THE MEANTIME THAT THEY
CANNOT AFFORD IT OR THE DELETE
BUTTON TO BE BEYOND THE JUSTICE
OPENED AT. THIRTEEN A PERSON
CARE.EIGHT FOR THESE REASONS
THAT YOU'RE HERE APART SB TWO
FORTY FIVE. AND A AVAILABLE THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBER MY NAME IS BALLOT
HOW MORE AND I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT COFFEE
TEMPTED ENOUGH. TWENTY TWENTY
AND THAT THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC I WAS SHOCKED TO
DISCOVER THAT I WAS PREGNANT-
THE TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD LIVING
THERE MY FIRST GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
WHICH HAD ALREADY COST ME MY
JOB IN SOCIAL LIFE. I THOUGHT
NOBODY PREPARED TO TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF A CHILD
DURING SUCH UNCERTAIN TIMES.
AND I MADE THE DECISION TO HAVE
AN ABORTION. I FEDERAL AN
APPOINTMENT AT MY LOCAL CLINIC
AND MENTALLY PREPARED FOR THE
EXPERIENCE I WOULD WONDER. WHAT
I COULD NOT PREPARE FOR WAS A
FINANCIAL BARRIER I FACE WHEN
ACCESSING MY PORTION. OF THE
DAY OF MY APPOINTMENT I LEARNED
THAT UNDER MY COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE POLICY. I WOULD NEED
TO PAY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
HAVE THE PROCEDURE THAT DAY.
THE COST COMPLETELY BLINDSIDED
ME. AND I CONTEMPLATED HOW I
COULD AFFORD THIS PROCEDURE IN
ADDITION TO MY LIVING EXPENSES.
I THEN UNDERSTOOD THE TRUTH ON
THE BREAKING G. WITH ACCESSING
AN ABORTION. I NEED A LONGER I
WAITED THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT
WOULD BE. FORCED TO MAKE AN
IMPOSSIBLE DECISION THAT DAY
CAN USE NEARLY ALL THE MONEY I
HAD TO PAY FOR MY ABORTIONS.
AFTER PAYING FOR THE PROCEDURE
I WENT TO MY CAR. AND I THOUGHT
FOR MYSELF AND EVERYONE ELSE
WHO KNEW THE DISTRESS CAUSED BY
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
HEALTH CARE. OCULOMOTOR TIME IN
LIFE THE FINANCIAL BARRIER I
FIFTY TO COST SHARING ALMOST
FORGOT. ME FROM ACCESSING THE
CARE THAT I NEEDED. THE BURDEN
OF THE TITANIC COST AFFECTED ME
FINANCIALLY AND EMOTIONALLY FOR
WEEKS AFTERWARD. THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR COST OF MY
ABORTION INTENSIFIED BY
FINANCIAL TROUBLES CAUSED BY
THE PANDEMIC. AN EXISTING SIX
MONTHS AROUND ABORTION MAKE ME
FEEL ISOLATED INVOICE PLUS.
FINE GRATEFUL THAT I COULD
UNDERGO A SAFE AND LEGAL
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA I'M
CONFIDENT THAT IT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR ME. I RECOGNIZE
NOW THAT THE TRAUMA I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO COST SHARING SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED. I'M ASKING FOR
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY FIVE. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
THE OTHER CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT
ENCOUNTER THE SAME FINANCIAL
BARRIER I FACE WHEN ACCESSING
MY PORTION. AND I CHOOSE TO
SHARE MY STORY CONSERVATIVE AS
AN EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS URGENTLY NEEDED
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WHEN THEY'RE
READY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SUSAN PARNELL. I'M AN
ATTORNEY FOR THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE AND WE OPPOSE SB TWO
FORTY FIVE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA'S BIRTH RATE
HAS PLUMMETED BELOW REPLACEMENT
LEVELS FROM TWO POINT TWO TO
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE ACCORDING
TO US CENSUS BUREAU AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. A DECLINING BIRTHRATE
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
AFFECTING BOTH RACE AND
ETHNICITY WHAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
IS MORE BABIES NOT MORE
ABORTIONS. SB TWO FORTY FIVE
WILL ENCOURAGE MORE ABORTIONS
BY FORCING INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO SUBSIDIZE COSTS MAKING
ABORTION FREE FOR WOMEN NO
DEDUCTIBLES NO CO PAY NO COST
SHARING WHATSOEVER. CALIFORNIA
ALREADY REQUIRES ALL PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
COVER ABORTION THIS BILL FORCES
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO PICK UP
THE COST SHARING AS WELL. ANY
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY IS AN
ECONOMIC INCENTIVE YOU GET MORE
OF WHATEVER YOU SUBSIDIZE. THE
BILL'S PREFERENCE FOR FREE
ABORTION OVER OTHER TYPES OF
HEALTH CARE IS INCONSISTENT
SEXIST DISCRIMINATORY AND
DOUBLE DOWN ON CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING VIOLATION OF FEDERAL
LAW. SB TWO FORTY FIVE IS
INCONSISTENT WHY STOP AT
ABORTION COPAYS WHY NOT FORCED
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO ABSORB
COPAYS FOR OTHER WOMEN'S HEALTH
TREATMENTS LIKE PAP SMEARS
HYSTERECTOMIES INFERTILITY OR
EVEN CANCER. AND SB TWO FORTY
FIVE IS SEXIST WHY NOT PUBLIC
MEN'S REPRODUCTIVE ISSUES LIKE
ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION OR
DISCECTOMY REVERSAL AND WHAT
ABOUT SEX CHANGE OPERATIONS WHY
IS ABORTION FREE. SB TWO FORTY
FIVE IS DISCRIMINATORY MOST
PREGNANCIES DO NOT END IN
ABORTION SB TWO FORTY FIVE DOES
NOT REQUIRE COMPANIES TO PAY
FOR THE COST OF GIVING BIRTH
FOR HER Q. DOT ITS SELECTIVELY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST FAMILIES
AND WOMEN WHO WANT TO HAVE
BABIES. SB TWO FORTY FIVE
VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW. THE
WELDON AMENDMENT CLEARLY STATES
THAT HEALTH PLANS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO. PAY FOR ABORTIONS
SLOUCHING THIS FEDERAL
PROTECTION OF CONSCIENCE RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA ALREADY REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO INCLUDE
COVERAGE FOR ABORTION EIGHTY
TWO FORTY FIVE. DOWN ON THIS
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW BY
REDISTRIBUTING MORE FUNDS FROM
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO ABORTION
PROVIDERS IN A BID TO ADVANCE A
SPECIALIZED MEDICAL CARE
PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE. THESE
REASONS WE URGING. NO VOTE
OFTEN TO FOR FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NO WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR AND OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIDGET
BLAIR I AM THE CEO OF HOLLISTER
PREGNANCY CENTER I HAVE HAD
THREE FIRST TRIMESTER SUCTION
THE ANTI ABORTION AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AS A FRESHMAN IN HIGH
SCHOOL I BECAME PREGNANT I WAS
NAIVE AND IMMATURE A CHILD I
WENT TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD TO
HAVE AN ABORTION AND WITH NO
QUESTIONS ASKED I SIGNED UP FOR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL AND HAVE A
FREE ABORTION WITHOUT MY
PARENTS CONSENT. DURING THE
SUCTION ABORTION I THOUGHT THE
COLLECTION BOTTLE FILLED WITH
BLOOD I WAS TRAUMATIZED UPON
BEING DISCHARGED THE NURSE
ASKED IF I WANTED BIRTH CONTROL
SEDATED AND IN SHOCK FROM THE
TRAUMA OF THE ABORTION SEX WAS
THE LAST THING ON MY MIND AND I
ANSWERED NO THE NURSE REPLIED
ODDS ARE YOU WILL BE BACK AFTER
THE ABORTION I SPIRALED INTO
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE I BECAME
PREGNANT AGAIN AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. THE PAIN AND SHAME I
CARRIED COMPOUNDED WHEN I FOUND
MYSELF BACK AT THE CLINIC HE
SECOND TIME I BECAME DEPRESSED
AND BEGAN STRUGGLING IN SCHOOL
I CUT CUT CLASSES AND HAD TO GO
TO A LOCAL JUNIOR COLLEGE TO
EARN EXTRA CREDITS TO GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL WHEN I FOUND MYSELF
PREGNANT A THIRD TIME I WENT TO
THE CLINIC AN EMOTIONAL WRECK I
WAS EMOTIONALLY FRAGILE AND
UNSTABLE I FELT HOPELESS I DID
NOT RECEIVE AN ASSESSMENT
REGARDING MY EMOTIONAL HEALTH.
NOR WAS I OFFERED ANY TYPE OF
PREGNANCY OUTCOME OPTIONS I WAS
NOT ASKED WHY I WANTED AN
ABORTION ON A MEDICAL TABLE I
CRIED VULNERABLE ON MY BACK
WITH FEET IN STIRRUPS THE NURSE
STOOD OVER ME AND SAID YOU DO
NOT WANT TO DO THIS TO YOU I
SAID NO. THE NURSE SAID IT WILL
BE OVER SOON I WAS INVISIBLE
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS YES THE
CLINIC PERFORMED THE ABORTION
EVEN THOUGH I SAID NO BEFORE
THE PROCEDURE STARTED THEY
DENIED MY RIGHT. TO CHOOSE THE
TONIGHT MY RIGHT TO CHANGE TO
MY MIND. SB TWO FIVE WE'LL SEE
ABORTION INDUSTRY'S GREED FOR
FINANCIAL PROFIT. SB TWO FORTY
FIVE WILL MAKE ABORTIONS
TOTALLY FREE. THAT WILL OPEN
THE DOOR FOR ABORTION CLINICS
TO VICTIMIZE MORE WOMEN JUST
LIKE ME. FREE ABORTION WILL
INCREASE THE RISK OF COERCION
TO WOMEN FACING UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY DURING ONE OF THE
MOST DELICATE AND FRAGILE TIMES
OF THEIR LIVES. SB TWO FORTY
FIVES FREE ABORTION PROVISION
THREATENS A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
SAY NO OR CHANGED HER MIND WHEN
SHE IS IN THE CLINIC FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW
ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. A GREG BIRD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL- IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JONATHAN KELLER WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILY ALLIANCE AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION- RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW FOR JUST THE-
NAME. POSITION AND ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MADAM OPERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT S. B. TWO FOUR FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY LINES THINK YOU'LL GO TO
LINE FOR FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS KATHY MUST
AGO WE HAVE A CENTRAL ACTOR
TELLS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRANCH
MANAGER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
SKETCHUP NINE IF SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MINUTE THIRTY HINA
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT FOR FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SANTA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. CHEAPER
NOW THANK YOU. FINE FOR FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURST
KATHY DOWN AUSTIN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BRANCH
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FOUR FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SORRY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI WITH PEACH
TRAINING IN EARLY ABORTIONS OF
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIND ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MOLLY ROSE BEEN WITHIN PAIN HAD
A PLATE THE CALIFORNIA WHERE
COUPON FROM THE BILL AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GENERAL OF THE HELP DESK
DIRECTOR OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA HERE AND COULD BONTA
ON THE BALLOT AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT FOR
FIFTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A PROCESS AND ON THE
SERVICE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB TWO FOUR FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE FOUR FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT
BYRD AND ORGANIZE THE WHOLE
LIFE AND GO AND DON'T KNOW AT
THE PEOPLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES DAHLE MORGAN
STANISLAUS COUNTY IN THE
MORNING MAJORITY VOTE NO ON AT
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT FOR TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING
QUICK WORK MADERA COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT TO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DIMITRIUS WE WOULD
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE FOR
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
HE ALSO BATES AND ANNA BARBARA
COUNTY AND- IN OPPOSITION. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN.
ONE EIGHT ONE. NINE TO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THE
BRANDON FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAK IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ENSURE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS. I REPRESENT RIGHT AWAY KERN
COUNTY AND BAKERSFIELD AND I'M
A RESIDENT RIGHT NOW AS WELL A
FORMER PLANNED PARENTHOOD
NATION I DID IT AND I AM IN.
EACH YEAR FIVE. YOU CALL PLEASE.
NINE FOUR TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JULIE SO
MAYBE OF BAKERSFIELD IN STRONG
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE FOR THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY NINE
TORTILLA RIDGE CREST CALIFORNIA
WOULD IN KERN COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. CRISTINA
FUNDERBURK RESIDENT OF KERN
COUNTY AND OPPOSITION YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT FOR TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR TO
FIVE. RIGHT TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD BY MIDDAY TODAY WITH
BLACK LOCAL ON IT ACTION
PROJECT COOK BONTA SAID AND-
JOHN THE ACT AT THE SUPPORT
TRACK THE TWO FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIVE
FOUR FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MERRY WE SHOULD
WRITER DIRECTOR RIGHT TO LIFE
OF KERN COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT FOR FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORRELL
INTRODUCED WITH PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
Q. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HIDE CAMPAIGN REPRESENTING
EMBRACE GREAT THAT CAN HELP
BAKER STILL THE GROUP PROVIDING
SPIRITUAL EMOTIONAL AND SHE
CANCELED SUPPORT KEEPING ALL
PREGNANT TEENS AND WOMEN AND WE
STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS FOR FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY MERRIT
CONQUERING AND PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT FOR FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DEVELOPMENT OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BRANCH FOUR FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI DONALD SUITS BUT
ALAMEDA COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
HELLO YEAH- THE LICENSE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS
FOR FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN PARTNER I
NEED ACTIVE DIRECTOR BUT I CAN
JUST GO AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AT THE TWO FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS FOR SIXTY THREE THREE
FOUR HAD. MY NAME'S LAURA
HELDER IN KERN COUNTY TONIGHT
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO TWO
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FOUR FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FOUR FOUR SEVEN. FIVE THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS WAYNE
RICHARDSON I AM A LAW STUDENT
INVENTOR RESIDENT AND I CANNOT
EXPRESS HOW STRONGLY AT THE
THOUGHT RICHEST FELL SB TWO
FORTY THANK YOU. RIGHT FOR
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE ADD. ONE
FOUR SEVEN TWO. YES MY NAME IS
JENNIFER FALCO ARAMBULA
CALAMARI MOTHER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. ALL WHICH IS-
S. B. RIGHT FOR SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME MY
NAME IS JENNY SHOOT FROM BAKER
SO CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO FORTY SB TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
THREE FOUR. NINE FOUR SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DURING A LONGTIME WITH ASIAN
RESEARCH INC AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FOUR TWO FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THREE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY. THREE ONE
FIVE. ONE FOUR THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURKE CHAU
CONNOR CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS FOR SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DIMITRI
FOUR AKIS I'M IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL HISTORY AND ENGLISH
TEACHER AND PLEASE VOTE NO ON
SB TWO FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RYAN ONE
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE SIX TWO. NINE FOUR SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR
SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS WE
ARE TOTAL SKI AND I AM THE
REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR
STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB
TWO FORTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER KOCH J. I AM A
RESIDENT OF GERMAN WOULD
DISTRICT IN SANTA ROSA I'M A
BIRTH DOULA CARE GIVER FOR
SENIORS AND AN ORGANIZER WITH
PRO LIFE SAN FRANCISCO PLEASE
USE YOUR CREDIT POSITION TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN MEMBERS CARILLO. THE
QUESTION A COMMONER BAKER HAD.
YEP MOVE THE BILL MR RODRIGUEZ
SECOND MY MISS CAREER OKAY.
SERVICE CHARGES IN A LITTLE
CLARIFICATION I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL AT TO THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW NO ONE
EVER TALKS ABOUT HOW MANY LIVES
ABORTIONS HAVE ACTUALLY SAVED.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN'S
LIVES AND THE FACT THAT THIS
CONTINUES TO BE A CONVERSATION
NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE NATION IS QUITE
FRANKLY APPALLING IN THE YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE ISSUE
BEFORE US IS AN ISSUE OF EQUITY
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE THE FACT
THAT. WOMEN WHO ARE MORE
AFFLUENT DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT. THE COST OF AN ABORTION
OR HAVING TO PAY FOR ANY KIND
OF. COPAYMENT AT CETERA BRINGS
REALLY THE QUESTION THAT THIS
CONTINUES TO BE. AN ISSUE WHERE
POOR WOMEN AND WORKING CLASS
WOMEN. ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUITY AND HEALTH CARE IN
EQUITY AND- AND COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND SO I
THINK. THIS IS NOT ONLY A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE IMPACT.
ON WOMEN'S HEALTH. BUT ALSO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT EQUITY AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND- I AM
PROUD TO BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WOULD LOVE TO BE CONSIDERED. AS
A CO AUTHOR AND I WOULD ALSO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE AYE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NO ONE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY- SO MANY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH LIKE THE CLOSE CENTER
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THAT FORWARD SHE SAID
IT SO ELOQUENTLY THIS IS ABOUT
HEALTH EQUITY REPRODUCTIVE
ACCESSIBILITY- AS WE KNOW
ABORTIONS AND FORTUNATELY FOR
DEDUCTIBLES AND COST SHARING
CAN BE COSTLY AND IT'S ALSO A
TIME SENSITIVE PROCEDURE FOR
MANY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WHO DESPERATELY NEED THIS. I
WANT TO THANK BELLA CAL MORE
FOR SHARING HER STORY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA GARCIA I BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLOOR NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON NOW.
SEVENTY TWO YUBA SEVEN VOTES
WILL BE THERE WILL CALL FOR YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR.
SENATOR GLAZERS. SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY FOR
EVERYONE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE A- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH WITH US CLOSELY ON
AMENDMENTS TO- ON THIS BILL TO
IRON OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS.
AND ADD TO ITS ROBUST PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS- THOSE EFFORTS HAVE
PERSUADED THE ACLU. THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND OTHER
PRIVACY ADVOCATES IN THE CMA.
TO WITHDRAW THEIR OPPOSITION.
YOUR STAFF AS ACCURATELY
DRAFTED THE AMENDMENTS REFLECT
IN OUR CONVERSATIONS AND I
ACCEPT THEM HAS PRESENTED.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR
POSES MODEST CHANGES TO BEING
TO BEGIN CLOSING THE DATA GAP
THAT HAS KEPT US FROM FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE METHODS WE
USE. TO CONTROL IT. MORE THAN A
YEAR AFTER COVERT NINETEEN TOOK
THE FIRST OF MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE STILL HAVE VERY LITTLE
SCIENCE TO EXPLAIN WHAT
CONDITIONS. MAKE THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS MORE OR LESS LIKELY.
AND WE HAVE LITTLE DATA TO SHOW
WHICH OF THE STEPS WE TOOK TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
WORKED. AND WHICH DID NOT. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND WE
AS POLICY MAKERS. HAVE BEEN
LARGELY FLYING BLIND. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST NOTED THAT ARE CODED
RESPONSE EFFORT FROM OUTDATED
DATA COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING SYSTEMS THE ANALYSTS
RECOMMENDED THAT WE UNDERTAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THOSE
SYSTEMS. AS A PART OF A
SWEEPING AFTER ACTION LOOK AT
HOW OUR STATE DEALT WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED THREAT AND I
AGREE WITH THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A SMALL STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION IT DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST THE BILL WOULD ADD
DETAILS TO THE QUESTIONS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ASK THOSE
WHO TEST POSITIVE. SO THAT IT
THE INFORMATION GATHERED WOULD
BE MORE USEFUL IN STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
AND SECOND THE BILL MAKES
CHANGES TO AN EXISTING SYSTEM
FOR SHARING DATA WITH BONA FIDE
RESEARCHERS. SO THAT OUR BEST
SCIENTISTS CAN STUDY THE SPREAD
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN REAL
TIME. AND PROVIDE US WITH THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO MAKE
INTELLIGENT DECISIONS. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO
CREATE A SPECIAL PANEL DURING
EMERGENCIES. TO EVALUATE
RESEARCH REQUESTS AND EITHER
APPROVE OR DENY THEM IN FIFTEEN
DAYS. THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
THIS EXPEDITED PROCESS ABIDE BY
ALL OF THE EXISTING PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS IN LAW. AND WE EVEN
ADD SOME NEW ONES. THIS CAN BE
DONE WHILE STILL BEING MINDFUL
THAT IN A PANDEMIC. EVERY DAY
THAT GOES BY. THIS COSTING
CALIFORNIANS THEIR LIVES.
MEMBERS IT'S TOO LATE TO SAVE
THOSE LIVES THOSE WHO HAVE
PASSED AWAY DURING THIS
TERRIBLE PANDEMIC BUT- YOU KNOW
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO PREPARE
FOR THE NEXT ONE. AND THIS BILL
WOULD HELP US DO THAT WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY BY
TELEPHONE IS DR JEFFREY
KLAUSNER AN EXPERT IN THIS
FIELD. PROFESSOR OF PREVENTIVE
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WILL GO TO YOUR WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME IS DR
JEFFREY KLAUSNER. FACTOR THING
INSPECTIONS DISEASE RESISTANT
MEDICAL EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND
PROFESSOR OF PREVENTIVE
MEDICINE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA KECK SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE I'M A FORMER SAN
FRANCISCO DEPUTY HEALTH OFFICER
AND FORMER CDC MEDICAL OFFICER
MISTAKE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOUR FOUR
WHICH WOULD ADD NEW DATA
ELEMENTS TO COMMUNICABLE
RESPIRATORY DISEASE REPORTING.
REQUIRE THE STATE TO SECURELY
SHARE THE IDENTIFIED DATA TO
ENABLE CALIFORNIA BASED
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS TO
PERFORM EPIDEMIOLOGIC ANALYSES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RESPONSE TO CALL THE NINETEEN
HAS BEEN ABJECT FAILURE. OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND- THE 70% OR
DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS OF
COLOR. THE KEY CONTRIBUTORS
THAT FAILURE IS IN THE POOR YOU
TO THAT PRETTY MUCH OF DATA AND
THE INABILITY OF THE STATE TO
USE AVAILABLE DATA TO CREATE A
TARGET RESPONSE TO FOCUSED
INTERVENTIONS TO LIMIT THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE CAUSED BY
BROAD BASED STATEWIDE POLICY.
BECAUSE THE DECADES OF PLANNING
CUTS TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH THIS STATE HAS
LIMITED CAPACITY TO ANALYZE
COLLECTED DATA FURTHERMORE THE
DATA COLLECTED ARE INCOMPLETE
AND INSUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT OF
SCIENCE BASS RESPONSE. THE LACK
OF GOOD DATA RESULTED IN THE
MEDICAL ACTIVISTS SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THE FAILURE TO
IMPLEMENT TESTING IN THE WORK
FORCE WHICH COULD HAVE
IDENTIFIED CASES EARLIER AND
PREVENTED THE- SPREAD OF
INFECTION. ON THE FLIP SIDE THE
INDISCRIMINATE CLOSURE ABOUT
DOOR SPACES PLAYGROUNDS SCHOOLS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS LEVINE
FOUNDED INTERVENTIONS LIKE DEEP
CLEANING ACTIVITIES AND
TEMPERATURE SCREENING WE'RE NOT
BASED ON GOOD DATA. BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE ANY SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR WOULD BE
A STEP TOWARD RIGHTING THE
STATE'S SPELL PUBLIC OFFICE
THEM BY ADDING RELEVANT
RESPIRATORY DISEASE EXPOSURE
ELEMENTS. COLLECTIVELY ADDED
DATA ELEMENTS ARE NOT A BURDEN
TO PRACTICING CLINICIANS
DOCTORS ARE TAUGHT TO COLLECT
THOSE EXPOSURES OCCUPATION
WORKPLACE HOUSING TYPE DENSITY
TRAVEL INDUSTRY MEDICAL SCHOOL.
AS PART OF A MEDICAL HISTORY
FURTHERMORE SUCH DATA ARE OFTEN
SELF REPORTED BY PATIENTS UPON
CLINIC REGISTRATION AND ENTERED
INTO THE ELECTRONIC MEDICAL
RECORDS BY STAFF SIMILAR TO
RECORDING INSURANCE INFORMATION.
OR HOME ADDRESS. I THINK IN THE
NINETEEN OUT THERE. HAVE BEEN
SWING BLIND. IT IS NO WONDER
THAT THE HAS BEEN SEVERE.
BETTER DATA AND SHE ACT AGAIN
PRESERVE INTO PRIVACY.
PROTECTING HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A WITNESS- REGISTERED WITH
US IN OPPOSITION. YES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
PATTY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
PHYSICIAN HEALTH OFFICERS.
APPOINTED IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY JURISDICTION HOW OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE REMOVING
THEIR OPPOSITION THAT THE
AMENDMENTS PRESENTED TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY THE HEALTH
OFFICERS REMAIN RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR. WE
ARE SYMPATHETIC WITH THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT YOU JUST DON'T
THINK THIS IS THE WAY TO GET
THERE WE PROPOSE VARIOUS
AMENDMENTS. BUT HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT.
BILL KOMPLETT THE DISEASE OF
TO. THIS IS HOW MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WHAT LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS
A CASE OF THE DISEASE IN THEIR
JURISDICTION. AND THAT PROCESS
HOW PUBLIC HEALTH MONITORS
DEFEAT CATION. IF WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE CASE WE CAN'T ENACT
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTIONS LIKE-ISOLATION QUARANTINE AND
CONTACT TRACING CONTACT RACING
AND PASSING A CONTACT. BECAUSE
IT. THESE REPORTING WE FEEL
THAT IT WILL LEAD TO LESS
DISEASE REPORTING UNLESS STATE
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH NOT MORE.
IT'S A WE RECOGNIZE IT HARD IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO PROVE A
NEGATIVE SO WE CAN'T QUANTIFY
HOW MUCH DATA WE DON'T HAVE.
AND WE BUT WE DO KNOW FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE OVER THE DECADES
THAT PROVIDERS DON'T ALWAYS
REPORT CASES TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THE HARDER WE MAKE IT TO
REPORT THE LESS LIKELY THEY ARE
TO DO SO. AND THAT RESULT IN
LESS DATA AND WORST PUBLIC
HEALTH. EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO QUANTIFY HOW MANY
CASES ARE REPORTED EACH YOU
KNOW THAT. EVEN ONE CASE GOES
UNREPORTED AT THE WRONG TIME
AND IN THE WRONG PLACE. CAN
SPARK AN OUTBREAK. NATALIE
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL GO TO. OTHER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY SO. WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK OUT SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIVE COMMENTS IN Q. WILL
GO TO LINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE BRAMBLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NINE
ZERO. HELLO MY MOTHER ON THE
HACKING ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT SO YOU CALIFORNIA ACCENT
ON THE TICKET THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND WE ARE NOT NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL OTHER WE ENCOURAGE
DOCTOR TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE HELP OFFICERS AND FIREMEN
AND SLID OFF THE DRESS IN
ADDITIONAL PRIVACY IT'S ENOUGH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT ONE TO.
PLEASE CALL. WELL JANET COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. I SUPPORT AND- I
HOPE THAT THE INFORMATION WILL
INCLUDE CUSTOMS- INFORMATION
THAT COMES. FOUR TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN FOUR TO
FIVE. ONE FOUR FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR FOUR ZERO. CHEN
MEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ THE
CORBIN PARK THERE ON BEHALF OF
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
AND ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN ARE COMMON WITH ACLU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AT THE ARMSTRONG WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION I'M TURNING OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE HELP OF TWO
THIRDS OF BOTH ASIAN AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND THREE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
ALEXANDER KIRK RJ I AM A
RESIDENT SHERMAN WOODS DISTRICT
IN SANTA ROSA I'M A BIRTH DOULA
CAREGIVER FOR SENIORS AND I AM
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
Q. I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND
BY WAS WALDRON I BELIEVE IS
THAT CORRECT. SO ANY YOU KNOW
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY I WANT
TO THANK YOU- CENTER GLAZER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING.
SO DILIGENTLY ON THIS AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
COMMITTEE- I HEAR THE CONCERN
FROM HEALTH OFFICERS- AND- IT
FEELS MORE HYPOTHETICAL THAN
THAN THAN THAN REAL AT THIS
POINT. THEY GET HURT IF ONE
PERSON DOESN'T REPORT THEN THEN
THEN THEN THIS IS A PROBLEM.
OUR DATA COLLECTION AND OUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS DATA IN THE
STATE IS A HUGE CHALLENGE AND
WITH IT IF NOTHING. WAS EXPOSED
BY CO BUT IT WAS THAT- THAT
AND- SO I FULLY SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- AND IF WE
FIND THAT THIS BECOMES AN
IMPEDIMENT IN THE FUTURE THAT
THERE IS AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. THE BEAUTY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE IS THAT WE CAN
ADJUST AND MAKE CHANGES IN THE
FUTURE BUT I FULLY SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS TO COLLECT MORE
INFORMATION MORE DATA SO THAT
WE CAN RESPOND- TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SHOULD ANOTHER-
RESPIRATORY DISEASE OUTBREAK
HAPPENED- SHOULD THE BILL
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
I LOST TRACK OF IT THAT WAS A
MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY AND
SECOND I MISS WALDRON MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR GLAZERS THANK YOU
CHAIR WOULD TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KIND. KIND WORDS. IS THE
QUESTION THAT WE GET UP FROM SO
MANY OF OUR NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS GUYS WHAT DID WE DO
WRONG WHAT CAN WE DO
DIFFERENTLY. WE HOPE THAT THIS
WILL BE SOMETHING WILL NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN IN OUR LIFETIME.
BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT- OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN REAL HEROES- IN SO MANY
WAYS. REALLY THE TAKEN THE
SLINGS AND ARROWS THEY'VE DONE
THEIR BEST WORK AND THEY'VE
SAVED A LOT OF LIVES SO. IT'S
NOT EASY TO HAVE A BILL BEFORE
YOU THAT DOESN'T HAVE THEIR
FULL SUPPORT BUT LET ME TELL
YOU THIS MEMBERS. THE DATA THAT
WE COLLECT RIGHT NOW AND AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. THERE ARE
THREE QUESTIONS AND THEY'RE
DEALING WITH JOB HOUSING
SITUATION AND TRAVEL ALL THIS
BILL DOES IS PROVIDE MORE CLEAR
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKING PLACE OF
WHAT'S THERE TODAY. NOT GOING
TO BE COMPLICATED. AND AS THE
CHAIR SAID I THINK WILL ALWAYS
BE OPEN TO TRYING TO FIND WAYS
TO DO OUR WORK BETTER. BUT THE
DATA THAT WE'RE COLLECTING. IS
NOT WHAT WE NEED AS POLICY
MAKERS TO MAKE OUR BEST
DECISIONS. AND WE WANT TO DO
BETTER I KNOW THAT I THINK THIS
BILL HELP THAT IF IT'S EVER
NEEDED IN THE FUTURE WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR GLAZERS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WOOD HI WHEN I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA GARCIA I BIGELOW. BURKE
CARILLO CARILLO EYEING FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON I. EIGHT TWO ZERO YOUR
BILL HAS EIGHT VOTERS OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR PAN DR PAN. PLEASE YOU
HAVE A BILL BEFORE US. HEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT YOUR WORD
MEMBERS HAVE. PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB THREE OH SIX. WE ARE
AT A CRISIS POINT WHEN IT COMES
TO SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS OF THIS COUNTRY.
BACK TO CCS EMITS A ONE IN FIVE
PEOPLE IN THE US HAVE HAD. HAVE
AN STD BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
OF A SIXTY EIGHT MILLION STD
INFECTIONS REPORTED RATES OF
SYPHILIS CHLAMYDIA AND
GONORRHEA- UP FORTY PERCENT
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN. THIS
CRISIS AFFECTS COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. BUT BUT
CALIFORNIA YOUTH PEOPLE OF
COLOR GAVE BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED FACT OVER HALF OF ALL
STDS IN THE STATE ARE IN THE
STATE OF REPORTED AMONG YOUTH
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OLD. AFTER AMERICANS ARE 5100%
MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT UNREIN
COMMITTEE AT INTO WHAT
COUNTERPARTS. THESE DISPARITIES
ARE EXPECTED TO WORSEN AS A
RESULT OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND HIGHEST SURPLUS RATE IN
THE NATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE SURPLUS RATE AMONG WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE INCREASED BY
OVER 7100% ONE OF THE HARDEST
DATAPOINTS. FOR ME TO SQUARE
WITH HAS TO DO WITH THE RATE OF
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS A DISEASE
WE THOUGHT WE GOT RID OF BACK
IN VICTORIAN ERA WE INVENTED
PENICILLIN IN THE EARLY PART OF
CENTURY. TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
BABIES WERE BORN WITH
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS 89100%
INCREASE FROM TWENTY TWELVE
VECTOR TWENTY STILLBIRTHS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS DISEASE.
BACK HALF OF CAN JOSEPH LISTER
A CASES OCCUR BECAUSE OF GAPS
IN TESTING AND TREATMENT DURING
PRENATAL CARE. AND THIS BILL
SEEKS CLOSE THAT GAP REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL SCREENINGS. THIS
BILL ALSO INCREASES ACCESS TO
FEDSCOOP SCREENING AND
TREATMENT BY EXPANDING
SCREENING FOR CONVULSIVE LIST
OF THE MENTION. OPENING UP
ACCESS TO THE FAMILY PACK
PROGRAM INCREASING THE USE OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXPEDITED PARTNER
THERAPY. PERMITTING HIV
COUNSELOR SENATORS ADMINISTERED
RAPID STD TESTS REQUIRING
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR HOME STD
TESTING. CALIFORNIA HAS LAGGED
AND ACTING COMPREHENSIVE
POLICIES INCREASE ACCESS STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT.
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE EXACERBATED
STD RATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
YOU CAN IMAGINE WILL HAPPEN AS
WE RE OPEN. SB THREE OH SIX SIX
A COOPERATIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S STD
CRISIS. BY EXPANDING ACCESS THE
STD CARE AND EQUITABLE WAY
ESPECIALLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YES- PLEASE- MADAM
OPERATOR WHEN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BOTH FIND THEIR OPEN.
GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THIS IS DR- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS DR
J. GLAD STEEN I AM THE CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER A PELE HEALTH
IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
STATE BILL. CALIFORNIA AND
INDEED THE NATION WAS ALREADY
SEEING RISING CASES OF STDS
BEFORE THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THOSE OF US WORKING
IN THE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH FIELDS ARE CONCERNED DFT
CRISIS HAS LIKELY GROWN WORSE
OVER THE PAST YEAR SINCE THE
PANDEMIC HAS BEGUN. PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFF HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATELY FOCUSED ON THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BUT
DOING SO DIVERTED PUBLIC HEALTH
RESOURCES AWAY FROM STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT.
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
LOT OF CONCRETE DATA ON THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
STATE'S A CD CRISIS WE DO HAVE
CONCERNING SIGNS THAT THE STD
EPIDEMIC HAS WORSENED. IN ORDER
TO PREVENT ONGOING COURT
INCREASING NUMBERS OF STDS. WE
NEED TO REMAIN VIGILANT IF WE
DO NOT REMAIN VIGILANT. WE MAY
HAVE INCREASING DEVELOPMENT OF
ANTIBIOTIC RESISTANT STRAINS OF
GONORRHEA WHICH ACCORDING TO
THE CDC ARE ALREADY BEGINNING
TO EMERGE IN THIS COUNTRY. IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UP DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. LISTEN ALERT
ABOUT RISING NUMBERS OF CASES
OF DISSEMINATED GONOCOCCAL
INFECTIONS THIS IS A MORE
AGGRESSIVE MANIFESTATION OF
GONORRHEA WHICH IF NOT TREATED
PROMPTLY AND APPROPRIATELY. CAN
LEAD TO MORE SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS INCLUDING THE
ROOTS OF ARTHRITIS AND RARELY.
INFECTIONS OF THE HEART VALVES
WHICH ARE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TO TREAT AND POTENTIALLY FATAL.
ANOTHER WARNING SIGN THAT WAS
JUST MENTIONED OF THE
PROGRESSING STD EPIDEMIC IS
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS. AND IN
THIS LAST YEAR WE SAW IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ONE HUNDRED
CASES OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
THIS OCCURS WHEN SYPHILIS IN A
PREGNANT WOMAN IS NOT TREATED
APPROPRIATELY AND CAN LEAD TO
PERMANENT BIRTH DEFECTS IN THE
BABY. DOES ONE HUNDRED CASES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WERE EVEN
HIGHER THAN THE INCREASE THAT
WE SEE ACROSS THE STATE IT'S AT
13100% INCREASE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. A CRISIS OF THIS
MAGNITUDE REQUIRES A
COORDINATED AND COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH AND STATE BILL THREE
OH SIX IS A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARD GETTING A HANDLE ON THE
STATE'S STD EPIDEMIC. THE
GROWING A CITY CRISIS NO DOUBT
AFFECTS ALL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. BUT CALIFORNIA
YOUTH. COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS CONTINUE
TO BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. NOTABLY THE BILL
WOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO STD
TESTING AND TREATMENT THROUGH
THE STATE'S FAMILY PACKED
PROGRAM. TO INCLUDE ALL PEOPLE
WITH STD SCREENING NEEDS.
CURRENTLY I THINK THAT FAMILY
PACKED COVERS AT TV SERVICES
FOR LOW INCOME UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS BUT ONLY WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF A FAMILY PLANNING
VISIT. THE INDIVIDUALS MOST
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THE
STRUCTURAL INEQUITY R. L. G. B.
T. Q. CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
REPORTED BEING BEEN TURNED AWAY
OR OUT TO PAY FOR THEIR
ASSIDUOUS SERVICES BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT NEED COMPREHENSIVE CON
CONTRACEPTION. AND WERE
THEREFORE INELIGIBLE FOR FAMILY
PACK SERVICES ALSO EXCLUDED OR
THOSE WHO MAY FALL OUTSIDE OF
THEIR CHILDBEARING YEARS.
EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
STD SERVICES UNDER FAMILY
PACKED PROVIDE THE FEASIBLE
COST EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE
PATHWAY TO INCREASE THAT TV
COVERAGE RATHER THAN CREATING
AN ENTIRELY SEPARATE PROGRAM.
SB THREE OH SIX INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROVISIONS TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S STD CRISIS
INCLUDING LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
TO INCREASE USE OF EXPEDITED
PARTNER THERAPY. WIRING
SYPHILIS SCREENING DURING THE
THIRD TRIMESTER OF PREGNANCY TO
HELP BRING DOWN THESE RATES OF
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS AND
COVERAGE AS WE JUST HEARD OF
THE IN HOME HIV AND STD TESTING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE SCOPE
OF THE STATE THIRTY CRISIS
REQUIRES A BOLD AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH SB THREE
OH SIX IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD CREATING A MORE
EQUITABLE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO SED
TESTING AND TREATMENT. KEEP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS. FIVE THANK
YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JIM ROBINSON AND I AM ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I'M REPRESENTING BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS. AND BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT WE ARE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION WITH
OFFICES IN LOS ANGELES AND
STOCKTON WHAT THE MISSION
DEDICATED TO BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS. I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS FOR
OVER A DECADE NOW AND MY ENTIRE
TENURE HAS BEEN. WHITE A CRISIS
IMPACTING DISPROPORTIONATELY
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTION RATES
THAT ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST
POINT. IN THIRTY YEARS WHAT
CHLAMYDIA RATES UP TWO HUNDRED
AND 11% AND GONORRHEA RATES UP
56% AND GENERAL OFFICE SUPPORT
INCREASED ABOUT 9100% BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN. THESE
RATES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING BLACK TEENAGERS THANK
WHERE YOU. HI STD RATES ARE
CANARIAN AND OUR WHOLE MIND
THAT IS LETTING US KNOW THAT
OUR SYSTEMS ARE BROKEN AND WE
ARE FAILING YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ISSUES SUCH AS
INCARCERATIONS ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND LACK OF ACCESS THE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY ARE ALL
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS THE HIGH
STD RATE BUT LUCKILY WE HAVE
TOOLS TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE. SB
THREE OH SIX. IS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING AT THE RATE
INCLUDING EXPANDING ACCESS THE
L. D. P. L. G. B. T. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS OTHER
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY NOT
ELIGIBLE TO GET STD SCREENING
AND TREATMENT. ENCOURAGING THE
USE. OF EXPEDITED PARTNER
TREATMENT. A SOLUTION THAT HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE
REINFECTION RATE. EXPANDING
RAPID TESTING AND OTHER
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES LIKE AT
HOME TESTING AS WELL AS
UPDATING STUFF WITH TESTING
PROTOCOLS FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE.
THIS LAST POINT IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT GIVEN THAT 15% OF
PEOPLE WITH THE FLU IN THE
STATE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE
PREGNANT. AND TWENTY TWO BABIES
DIED OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WELL IF
SOMETHING WE KNOW CAN BE
TREATED WITH ANNA ANTIBIOTICS
THAT COST LESS THAN A DOLLAR
BUT LACK OF TREATMENT CAN CAUSE
PERMANENT DAMAGE. THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUED NEW GUIDELINES.
RESPONDING TO THE ALARMING
INCREASE OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
AND HIV TO DO THIRD TRIMESTER
CASTING. A RECOMMENDATION IN
LINE WITH THE OLD. CD PH WHEN
THEY ARE GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS.
THAT HAVE SEEN RISES AND OR
RISK AND OR AT RISK COMMUNITIES
WHICH IS FOR THE- OUR. THERE
ARE DIFFICULT INCOME IS THAT
ARE. IS FACING COMING SURE WE
ARE FORWARD TO MORE THAN JUST
EQUITABLE CAL HOWEVER. THIS IS
OF THOSE COMPLICATED ISSUES WE
HAVE THE TWO RESEARCH AND WHERE
WITH ALL TO TURN THE CORNER ON
THESE ISSUES ALL WE'RE MISSING.
IS OUR WILL TO DO SO THIS IS
WHY I ASK THIS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES ON SB THREE OH SIX. A
VITAL STEP IN ADDRESSING STD
RATES IN OUR STATE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE NO REGISTERED OF
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
HAVE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY SO
WE'LL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES.
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR A PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION THE BILL JUST
YOUR NAME. YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL IN ANY ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT. ONE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM OPERATOR. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OUT AT THE THREE
OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TEN LINES IN Q. WILL
GO TO ONE THREE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BENEFITING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND PART OF SB THREE A SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT FOR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS KATHY
MUSTARD ON BEHALF OF THE CORN
OF THE CO SPONSORS ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE OH SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BUT THE ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
MST. THREE ZERO SIX. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE LINE FOR FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRACKLED ON BEHALF OF A DELAY
HELP THE PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FOUR FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN CHLORINE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
FOR FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND NAY ROUTE PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FINE FOR NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MOLLY WRITTEN WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORTER THAT AFFECTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FOUR NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW ANY
OF TO WIDEN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JIM JACKSON BY UPON CALIFORNIA
DO SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY BAKER
PATEL CONFIRMED EDUCATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINE FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BROKEN THE- OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FOUR TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
TWO FIVE. LYDIA BORN
REPRESENTING AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS WALDRON. FROM THE
DOCTOR AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BILLS YOU KNOW THIS PEOPLE ON
BOTH SIDES THERE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT COSTS AND THINGS. HAVEN'T
BEEN ON HEALTH COMMITTEE NOW
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS OR SO.
WHEN I LOOK AT BILLS LIKE THIS
I THINK. YOU KNOW. IF WE KNEW
PEOPLE STATUS IF WE KNEW THE
YOU KNOW IF THE INFECTION RATES
ARE OR PEOPLE COULD BE TESTED.
THERE'S A COST TO THAT. BUT
WOULD YOU SAY OR HAS IT BEEN
LOOKED AT EVER WHAT WOULD BE
THE COST SAVINGS. OF ACTUALLY
GETTING THIS INFORMATION AND
TREATING PEOPLE SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. AND AVOIDING THE
COST AND THINGS THAT COME DOWN
THE PIPELINE. THAT TEND TO BE
MORE EXPENSIVE I MEAN I'M JUST.
YOU KNOW IN A BILL LIKE THIS
ONE IF. KIND OF THE FLOW OF
THAT TYPE OF THING BECAUSE IT
DOES COST TO HAVE THE KIDS AND
PROCESSING LAB AND EVERYTHING
BUT- ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF THE
PATIENT. THE ABILITY TO KNOW
YOU KNOW STATUS AND OTHER
THINGS TO GET TREATMENT THERE'S
DEFINITELY OF THE COST OR
SAVINGS TO THAT AS WELL.
NOTHING THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
CENTER WALDRON I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING UP THAT
POINT BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL OF
COURSE THERE'S A BENEFIT TO.
PEOPLE BEING ABOUT THE TESTED
AND GETTING TREATMENT THESE ARE
ALL TREATABLE RIGHT THE OTHER
THING I'D POINT OUT AS THESE
ARE INFECTIOUS. SO ALSO WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THEY SPREAD
IT TO OTHER PEOPLE SO NOT ONLY
OF COURSE THERE'S POTENTIALLY
GREATER COSTS ASSOCIATED THIS
IN VIOLATION MENTION THINGS
LIKE CHLAMYDIA GONORRHEA CAN
CAUSE THINGS LIKE INFERTILITY
AND OTHER TYPES OF- YOU KNOW
THOSE OTHER SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
WE TALK ABOUT SYPHILIS AND
LEADING TO CONGENITAL SYPHILIS.
WHICH CN LEAD TO NOW I STILL
BIRDS BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY
PERMANENT- OF INJURY TO THE- TO
THE BABY SO. THESE ARE THINGS
WE LIKE TO PREVENT. AS AND ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD THE DISEASE AS WELL AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THINGS LIKE
EXPEDITED PARTNER THERAPY AS
WELL AS OF COURSE- PAYING FOR
HOME TESTING BECAUSE WE WANT TO
GET PEOPLE TESTED. FIND OUT GET
THEM TREATED AND THAT'S AND IN
THE LONG RUN I BELIEVE THAT'S
GOING TO BE BETTER HEALTH BUT
ALSO ACTUALLY- LOWER SPENDING
AS WELL FOR HEALTHCARE. ANYONE
ELSE. OUR THERE'S NO MOTION IN.
WHICH I CAN MAKE. WITH A MOTION
AND A CHORUS OF SECOND SO
MOTIONFAMOUS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD CENTER PAN- I
KNOW IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE BACK
TO THE FUTURE IN SOME WAYS
BECAUSE- OF THE- I KNOW IN MY
OWN DISTRICT THERE ARE THERE
AREAS WHERE WE'VE SEEN ALARMING
INCREASES AND STDS AND- AND
THESE ARE DISEASES THAT ARE
PREVENTABLE- AND THE SPREAD IS
SIGNIFICANT AND QUICK AND THE
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE ARE. ARE
ARE A REALLY PRETTY POOR IF
YOU'RE NOT TREATED WELL SEPT I
DO BELIEVE THAT- IN THE LONG
RUN BY CATCHING THESE DISEASES
EARLY PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
IT WE ARE GOING TO SAVE MONEY
FOR THE SYSTEM ALTHOUGH YOU
KNOW THERE SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
TO SPEND A SAFE AND THAT IS
THAT'S THE REALITY OF IT. ALSO
KIND OF POINTS TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGESWE HAVE OUR ENTIRE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
HAS BEEN UNDER UNDER ASSAULT
AND SIEGE AND HAS BEEN UNDER
FUNDED FOR MANY MANY YEARS
WHICH IS WHY YOU AND I HAVE
BEEN PUSHING SO HARD. FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SPENDING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING THIS IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT- AND
SO- WITH THAT- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION THE SECOND- OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YEAH I FIRST OF ALL I
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE- THE
DOCTOR WOULD YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND- AND PUBLIC HEALTH SO THANK
YOU I'M I THINK THE- THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL INTERSECT WE
OFTEN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS PAST WHO
BUSINESS ON PROFESSIONS WHAT.
HI WOULD I'D MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA GARCIA I BIGELOW. BURKE
CARILLO RIO II FLORA FLOOR NO
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON I. EIGHT TO ONE
YOUR BILL IS OUT WITH THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ARE THANK
YOU DOCTOR THANK YOU. YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO. YOU HAVE THE
FINAL TWO BILLS OF THE-
AFTERNOON IT'S GETTING CLOSE
THE EVENING BUT WE'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET. SO DO YOU WANT TO DO
TO FIVE FIVE FIRST YEAR YES
PLEASE I WOULD BE GREAT THANK
YOU AWESOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL TRY TO BE QUICK GIVEN THE
TIME YOU GUYS HAVE PUT IN
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PRESENTING SB TWO FIVE FIVE
WHICH WILL PROTECT EVERY TO
FREELANCE COMMON LAW TV
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION
EMPLOYEES. FROM LOSING THEIR
EXISTING QUALITY AT NO COST
INSURANCE RESULTING FROM. A
SINGLE A RECENT CHANGE IN LAW.
FREELANCE EMPLOYMENT IS THE
BACKBONE OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. AND BECAUSE FREELANCE
FILMMAKERS ARE HIRED ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS. AND
MAY HAVE DOZENS OF DIFFERENT
PRODUCTION COMPANY EMPLOYERS
OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR. THEY
HAVE NO MEANS TO QUALIFY FOR A
REGULAR EMPLOYMENT BENEFIT
PLANS. TO FILL THIS VOID THE
PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFITS PLAN.
FULLY INSURED EMPLOYER
SPONSORED PLAN WAS FORMED TO
PROVIDE. HEALTH BENEFITS AT NO
COST TO NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
ELIGIBLE. COMMON LAW EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYEES OF THE TELEVISION
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER DUE TO THIS RECENT.
CHANGE IN LEGISLATION. THE
FREELANCERS ARE NOW IN JEOPARDY
OF LOSING THAT INSURANCE- SB
TWO FIVE FIVE WILL CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS PLAN CONTINUES. ON THE
PHONE TODAY I HAVE SHOWN COOLEY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PLANT
AND BONNIE GOLDFARB THE OWNER
OF A PRODUCTION COMPANY AND A
COMMISSIONER ON THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR PER PORTANTINO- WE'RE
GOING TO OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. BOTH
SIDES ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF SB TWO FIFTY
FIVE MY NAME IS SEAN COOLEY AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFITS
PLAN THE BILL'S SPONSOR ALL
REFERRED TO US BY OUR ACRONYM
THE PHD P. P. THREE P. WAS
STARTED AS A WAY FOR EMPLOYERS
IN THE TELEVISION COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
HEALTH BENEFITS TO THEIR FULL
TIME W. TWO FREELANCE EMPLOYEES
OR OTHERWISE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
EMPLOYER HEALTH PLAN. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAVE PROVIDED
FREE HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
COVERAGE AND CURRENTLY INSURED
TWELVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA THE
LANCERS WELL PARTICIPATION IN
THE FREE LUNCH PROGRAM IS
MANDATORY OF ALL OF OUR TWO
HUNDRED PLUS PARTICIPATING
EMPLOYERS OPTIONAL NON
FREELANCE GAP COVERAGE IS
AVAILABLE OF WHICH 38% OF OUR
EMPLOYERS PARTICIPATE. 70% OF
OUR TOTAL COVERED EMPLOYEES ARE
FREELANCERS. YOU TOO CAN EVEN
DIE NOT ON TO THE LIVES OF
THESE FREELANCERS BUT I BELIEVE
TO THE STATE AS WELL FOR
EXAMPLE WITHIN A WEEK OF THE
GOVERNOR STAY AT HOME ORDERS
THE PLAN IMPLEMENTED A SERIES
OF COVERED NINETEEN RELIEF
MEASURES. EXTENDING COVERAGE
KOREANS FROM TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN MONTH DURATIONS TO
ENSURE NO ONE LOST COVERAGE DUE
TO THE SHUTDOWN OF THE
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION INDUSTRY
THE FIRST SEVERAL MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC. HE WENT ALL OUT OF
POCKET FEES SUCH AS ALREADY
HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED DEPENDENCIES
AND ISSUE THE 20% DISCOUNT ON
ALL COBRA PREMIUMS FROM APRIL
FIRST THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY. IF ANYONE LOST COVERAGE
IN THE FIRST TWO MONTHS AFTER
THE EXPIRATION OF THE RELIEF
MEASURES. WE SUBSIDIZE COUPLE
PREMIUMS BY ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. BECAUSE IT HEALTHY
RESERVES INCLUDING GOVERNANCE
THE PLAN WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE A
LIFESAVING FINANCIAL SAFETY NET
TO ALL OF OUR COVERED
FREELANCERS AT NO COST TO THE
STATE. IS EXAMPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITY TAKING CARE OF ITSELF
IS TYPICAL THE PGP STORY.
THERE'S NO SCENARIO IN WHICH
THE WORKER OR FOR THAT MATTER
THE EMPLOYER OR THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. BENEFITS OF PEACE
FREELANCERS ARE FORCED TO THE
OPEN MARKET TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET FOR INSURANCE THE
EMPLOYER IS WILLING TO PROVIDE
IT HAS PROVIDED. FOR FREE FOR
THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS. I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT SB TWO FIFTY FIVE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ALSO BEEN NOTIFIED THAT SEVERAL
OF OUR TEACHERS HAVE HAD TO
DROP OFF SO APOLOGIES IF THAT
LINE- IF THAT- MINUS LITTLETON.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL GO AHEAD WITH TO OUR NEW
WITNESS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND CAN MEMBER. MY NAME IS BOB
GOLD. I AM THE OF HER FILMS OF
LOS ANGELES COMMERCIAL. COMPANY
A PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER IN THE
PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFIT PLANS.
AND A BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION. AS
THE CURRENT EMPLOYER AND FORMER
FREELANCER IN COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND THE POSITIVE IMPACT THIS
HEALTH BENEFIT PLAN HAS HAD ON
MY EMPLOYEES MY COMPANY AND OUR
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE. THE P. H.
B. P. PROVIDE FREE EMPLOYER
PAID HEALTH COVERAGE TO OUR
FREELANCE EMPLOYEES. WHICH
ENABLES US TO KEEP AND MAINTAIN
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT KEEPS
EVERYONE WORKING HERE WITH THE
CREW THAT HAS PAID HEALTH
INSURANCE. WE HAVE THE BEST
CRUISE IN THE WORLD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF OUR MAIN
CHALLENGES INCLUDES OTHER
STATES VYING FOR THE ANNUAL ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
SPENT. IN CALIFORNIA ON
MARSHALL PRODUCTION EACH YEAR
WE CAN'T RISK FORCING OUR
FREELANCERS TO THE OPEN MARKET
TO REPLACE. THEIR CURRENT
EMPLOYER FUNDED HEALTH PLAN.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT
AND THOSE INCREASED COSTS WILL
BE PASSED ON TO OUR CLIENTS
RESULTING IN MORE PRODUCTION
HEADING OUT OF STATE. BATES B.
P. IS DOING THE RIGHT THING BY
PROVIDING EMPLOYER PAID HEALTH
CARE TO COMMERCIAL FREELANCERS
IN PRODUCTION THAT REALLY
MATTERS- I URGE YOU TO PASSED
SB TWO FIFTY FIVE TO ENSURE
THAT EMPLOYERS LIKE ME. CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FREE
EMPLOYER PAID HIGH QUALITY
HEALTH COVERAGE TO THE
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION
INDUSTRIES AMAZING FREELANCE
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
ANY BODY IN THE GALLERY SO
WE'LL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR. A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF THEY REPRESENT
ONE AND POSITION ON THE BILL SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MADAM
OPERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON SB EIGHT TWO FIVE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE LINES IN Q. WILL GO TO
LINE FOR NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS PATHOLOGY OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT SB TWO
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU COULD NOT CALL ME SB.
THREE OH SIX- WELL. I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DANIEL CALLING ON THE
CEO OF THE PHD TO PARTICIPATING
EMPLOYER AND I SUPPORT SB TWO
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE I JUST IT
JUST A COMMENT- FROM MY END I
KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME QUESTIONS
RAISED AS TO WHY WE'RE
REQUESTING TO. SUNSET ON SB
SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BATES
WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY AND NOT
FOR THIS BILL- AND IT IS REALLY
A DIFFERENCES IN THE
ASSOCIATION'S WHILE BOTH BILLS
ARE SETTING FORTH ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME GUARD RAILS. AND
PROCESSES THE EMPLOYEE STATUS
OF EACH OF THE ASSOCIATION'S
APPEAR TO BE DIFFERENT. SB
SEVEN EIGHTEEN COULD APPLIES
NARROWLY TO BIO COMPANIES WHO
CAN POTENTIALLY BY IN THE SMALL
GROUP MARKET. BUT AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT BY THE AUTHOR AND
WITNESSES TODAY- THIS BILL-
APPLIES NEARLY TWO EMPLOYEES
WHO. ARE FREELANCE EMPLOYEES
WITH NO ABILITY TO QUALIFY FOR
THEIR EMPLOYER'S GROUP HEALTH
PLANS- WHETHER SMALL OR LARGE
GROUP. THE PROJECT BY PROJECT
FREELANCE NATURE OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT PATTERNS INHERENT IN
THE COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION
INDUSTRY SO THAT IS WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS DIFFERENTLY AND SO
AND THROUGH THIS BILL- THE BILL
HAS A MOTION BY. MISTER
NAZARIAN A SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THAT VERY. COGENT
EXPLANATION OF THE DIFFERENCES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NAGA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE BILL DOES THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GARCIA GARCIA HI BIGELOW. BURKE.
CORREA CORREO I LARA OR I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON I BIGELOW BIGELOW HIGH.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO YOUR
BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OF
PRISON FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
BEFORE WE GO TO MEXICO JUST A
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT PRESENT THIS IS THE LAST
BILL WERE PRESENTED TONIGHT SO-
WOULD HOPE YOU COULD PLEASE
COME DOWN AND SO WE CAN GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE ONLY ONE
TIME- I WOULD MUCH APPRECIATE
IT I MEMBERS COULD COME TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WITH THAT-
CENTER PORTANTINO SB FIVE SIXTY
TWO WHENEVER YOU'RE LIKE YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND MEMBERS SB
FIVE SIX TWO WILL ELIMINATE
SIGNIFICANT ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS
IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS. THAT
ARE PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
EXACT ACCESSING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM WHO
RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT EARLY CAN SHOW
REMARKABLE PROGRESS THIS BILL
CODIFIES THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL AND PARA
PROFESSIONAL TO ENSURE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE STATISTICS
TELL US THAT ONE IN FIFTY NINE
CHILDREN BORN TODAY ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO
HELPING THESE CHILDREN LIVE UP
TO THEIR POTENTIAL AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IS
CRITICAL. NOT ALL CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM ARE THE SAME THEY
RESPOND TO TREATMENT
DIFFERENTLY CHILDREN NEED
TREATMENT TAILORED TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS PRESCRIBED BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN OR PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO KNOWS THEM BEST NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL TREATMENT THAT
MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR
EVERY CHILD TEN YEARS AGO SB
NINE FORTY SIX PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM IT'S
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS BUT OTHERS HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED FOR RECEIVING
ITS BENEFITS BECAUSE OF A
DRAFTING ERROR AN ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS NOT EVERY CHILD
RECEIVING COVERAGE FOR THE
TREATMENTS. AT BY THEIR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER- PRESCRIBED FOR
THEM THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE BEING DENIED THAT COVERAGE
ADDITIONALLY FOR MANY CHILDREN
THERE IS A SIX TO TWELVE MONTH
WAITING LIST FOR THE ONE
TREATMENT THAT HEALTH INSURANCE
WILL COVER TREATMENT THE LATEST
TREATMENT TONIGHT IN A
DEVELOPING MIND BY EXPANDING
THE TIMES OF QUALIFIED BY
EXPANDING THE TYPES OF
QUALIFIED ALREADY STATE
CERTIFIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE. THIS
BILL WILL ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
SHORTAGE AND ALLOW FOR. TO
RECEIVE THE TREATMENT THEIR
PHYSICIAN HAS PRESCRIBED. THE
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES ROADBLOCKS
THE COVERAGE FOR PARENTS. WHO
FOR REASONS OF WORKER FAMILY
PRESSURE CANNOT FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
THERAPY SESSION. THE SESSION
THE SITUATION SHOULDN'T
PRECLUDE COVERAGE OF A
MEDICALLY NECESSARY. TREATMENT
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I HAVE JIM
LANTRY. FROM THE D. I. R. FOR
TIME COALITION AND ALISON FEIGN
A PARENT. OF A CHILD WITH
AUTISM TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR- MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR TWO WITNESSES PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. KEEP UP
FIND THEIR OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WOULD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JIM LANDRY WITH THE D.
I. R. FLOOR TIME COALITION IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW FOR MANY OF
US WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD
BEFORE SO THIS WILL SOUND
FAMILIAR. ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM DESERVE THE BEST DOCTOR
PSYCHOLOGIST PRESCRIBED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THEM RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT CHILDREN RECEIVE
TREATMENT EARLY RESPOND BETTER
AND RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THE
TREATMENT TAILORED TO THE NEEDS
OF THE CHILD IS IMPORTANT AND
RESULTS IN THE CHILD ATTAINING
HIS OR HER POTENTIAL. NO TWO
CHILDREN ARE ALIKE NO TWO
CHILDREN WITH ACTED MORE LIKE
RATHER WHAT WORKS FOR ONE CHILD
MAY ACTUALLY BE HARMFUL FOR
ANOTHER UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
TREATMENT SHOULD BE AN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE WHICH REQUIRES
THREE THINGS. BIRDS THE
TREATMENT HAS TO BE SUPPORTED
BY RESEARCH SECOND IT MUST USE
THE CLINICIANS BEST JUDGMENT
AND THIRD IT MUST TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
THE PATIENT A TREATMENT OUR
IDEA OF SYSTEM THAT ONLY ALLOWS
FOR ONE TREATMENT CAN'T
POSSIBLY MEET THOSE THREE
CRITERIA. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CAST MENTAL HEALTH PARITY LAW
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE IT
ANTICIPATED THAT AUTISM WOULD
BE TREATED THE SAME MATTERS
PHYSICAL AILMENTS UNFORTUNATELY
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN IN TWENTY
ELEVEN WE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SENATE BILL NINE FORTY
SIX WHICH MANDATED THAT ALL
PRESCRIBE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
EVIDENCE BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT TO BE COVERED
BY HEALTH INSURANCE AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN WHAT DID HAPPEN IS THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS COVERED ONLY ONE
FORM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT APPLIED BEHAVIORAL
ANALYSIS OTHER FORMS OF
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT WERE
DENIED COVERAGE AS A RESULT
PARENTS OF CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
PRESCRIBE A DIFFERENT FORM OF
TREATMENT WERE FACED WITH THREE
OPTIONS. FIRST PUT THE PAPER
THE PRESCRIBE TREATMENT OUT OF
POCKET EVEN THOUGH THEIR THEIR
EMPLOYERS THAT ALREADY PAY FOR
COVERAGE AND FOR MOST PARENTS
PARTICULARLY SINGLE PARENTS LOW
INCOME PARENTS THIS OPTION WAS
ON AFFORDABLE. THE SECOND WAS
THIS REGIONAL CENTERS TO PAY
FOR THE TREATMENT IN SOME CASES
OCCURRED CONTRARY TO THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. OF SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY SIX. THE THIRD
OPTION WAS TO SEND ACCEPT THE
ONE FORM OF. THAT WAS COVERED
HE THOUGH NINETY MIGHT NOT BE A-
OR MIGHT BE BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE CHILD. IT ALSO RESULTED IN
THE LONGER TERM CARE COSTS IN
HEALTH INSURANCE KERRIER MORE
MONEY BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
CUSSING THE CHILD TIME THAT CAN
NEVER BE RECOVERED. THIS BILL
WILL RECTIFY THAT AND FINALLY
ACHIEVED THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
BILL AND SENATE BILL NINE FORTY
SIX. THE BILL COMPLEMENTS LAST
YEAR'S SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE WHICH AMENDED MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY BILL. UNDER SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO QUALIFIED
UNSUPERVISED PROFESSIONALS WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE COVER
TREATMENT AND ALLOW MORE
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE THIS
ESSENTIAL TREATMENT. SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO ALSO INCREASE OF THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PARA
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDING NINE
ABA SERVICES. AND ALSO REQUIRES
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND CLOSE
OTHER LOOPHOLES THAT HAVE
ALLOWED INSURANCE CARRIERS TO
DENY COVERAGE. THE BILL
ASSORTED AS SUPPORTED BY DOZENS
OF ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
AUTISM SOCIETY IN DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
OVER FOUR HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS.
PARTICULARLY PARENTS OF
CHILDREN WHO NEED THESE
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENTS. THE
BILL ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN EACH
SENATE VOTE. THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL. GO AHEAD
MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT WITNESS. HI
ALISON. THE MOTHER A CHILD WITH
AUTISM AND IT SPEAKS THIS TO BE
HEARD PROBABLY AROUND THREE
O'CLOCK AND SO- SHE MAY BE
CARRYING PER CHILD INSTEAD. FOR
FAIR ENOUGH IF SHE DOES COME ON
THE LINE WE WILL ABSOLUTELY LET
HER TESTIFY SO. THANK YOU- WE
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION SO
WE'LL OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. LINES ARE OPEN.
SORRY GOOD ACTORS MR KAREN
MEMBERS MAKING WITH ME OFF THE
MARK MARX ON THE OF THE K.
STATE FOR THE NOW. ALSO KNOWN
AS CALA. REGRETTED CALLOUT BY
IS ONCE OPPOSE TO LIKE A THAT
REVISED THE STAFF DE OF BEHAVE
HEALTH. SB FIVE FIFTY TWO THE
LATEST MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO BE
DAY. TO INCLUDE AND
RELATIONSHIP AND OF MANY OF
WHICH ARE NOT EVIDENCE BASED
THANK YOU BERMAN ALICE'S NOTES
LIMITATIONS WITH THE STUDIES ON
OF THOSE TREATMENT. AND
SPECIFICALLY THAT THEY ARE
UNDER STUDY WITH MY SAMPLE ARE
OFFERED INCLUDES AT OF THEIR
MEDICAL EFFECTIVENESS. IF THE
THREE WERE ABLE TO SIGN.
EVIDENCE STANDARDS THAT GOVERN
THE OF MANY. THEY WOULD ALL BE
COVERED UNDER THE- PHD DEATH.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DO MEET THE
STANDARDS SUPPOSED OF THE BILL
USING A LEGISLATOR PROCESS THAT
SIR. THIS PROCESS. CONTRA TO
THE PURPOSE CLAIM THERE IS NO
BEING. AS THERE ARE OTHER TO
MODE. THAT ARE NOT EXPLICITLY
IN THE STATUTE BUT OUR EVIDENCE
BASED AND ARE THEREFORE CA BY.
INSURANCE FOR A- THE EARLY CAN
MODEL IS A REAL. FACE ENTER
THAT IS MAY AND HEALTH PLANS
ARE PAYING FOR THAT TREE TO. I
DID WE ARE CONCERNED SB FIVE
SIXTY TO EXPAND THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR QUALIFY
ARTISANS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
INCLUDE UNQUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
SB FIVE SIXTY TWO ALSO INCLUDES
REFERENCES TO EDUCATION AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC AS THERE
ARE CURRENTLY NO UNDERGRADUATE
OR GRADUATE PROGRAMS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
THIS REFERENCE BECAUSE OF
CONFUSION IN THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY. MISTER JERRY MEMBERS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS
BASED ON MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE OCCUPANT
INSURANCE MANDATE BY ENSURING
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY. AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER INTERVENTIONS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT THEY RECEIVE
MEDICALLY VALIDATED SERVICES
FROM QUALIFIED PROVIDERS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. TIME SPENT
ON UNPROVEN TREATMENTS IT'S
TIME THAT CANNOT BE GOTTEN BACK
AND IT'S FOR THOSE REASONS THAT
CHALAMET DEPOSED FIVE FIFTY TWO
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MOVING TO OUR NAY WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER MAKE LEADERS BEHALF OF.
SO OF HEALTH PLANS WHICH YOU
ARE NOT TO FIVE SIXTY TWO.
POINT SIGNIFICAN EXPAND EXPAND
CAL OCCURS BECAME HEALTH. IN A
MANNER THAT IN KERR MEDICAL
RECOMMENDED INVEST. MEMBERS
APPOINTED THE POOR EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACH TO COME YOU SEE
JUST HOW INSURANCE RELEASE RISK
THE RIGHT AT THE TIME THE RIGHT.
SOME OF THIS OF IS V. SIX
REVIEW OF THE BASED METHODS TO
TREAT THAT THIS PROCESS LEGAL A
REVIEW REFER ME ABOUT THE- OF
MEDICAL ENTERED. PUBLISHED BY
MEDICAL SOCIETY ANOTHER SO.
BROUGHT TO SERVICES AB AND
OTHER- AS I JUST BY THE PRIOR
WE NEED ALREADY. AS EVIDENCE
TREATMENT. THE PROBLEM WITH SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO HOWEVER IS. IT
IS W. THE SUB STANDARD RICK FOR
DIRECT PROVIDERS BY ALLOWING ON
BE PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
ARE AND CARE. MITCHELL DEEP THE
OF SERVICE BECAUSE THE WATER IS
NEED TO MAKE OF THE BASED CARE
PROVIDER TO CHILL WITH DOCTOR
DURING THAT YEARS. AGAIN THE
BILL IN PEOPLE THE HEALTH PLAN
TO THE TREE PLAN- ANY VOW WAIT
LOCAL OF. AND TAKING THINK
WHETHER THE ARE ARE ACTIVE FOR
IN THAT TREE. BE LIMITED DALY
THE CALL OF OUR CARE BECAUSE
SIR ARE TO FOR AND SETTINGS
BURKE AS A STRUCTURED THE ALBUM
BENEFIT THE CHILD- PRACTICE
THREE HAS PER THAT CHILL HAVE
BETTER. TO TREAT AND MASTER
SKILLS BEHAVIOR ARE
CONSISTENTLY A- BY THEIR
PARENTS OR OF PROVIDE IN THE
RIGHT SETTING SO I'M PRETTY
REASONS AND THE REASON STATED
BY THE CAR WITH- I WE OPPOSE SB
FIVE SIX TWO THANK YOU. ZERO
ACTORS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT TEN COMMENTS IN CUBA WILL
GO TO LINE. ONE SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM AND RELATED DISORDERS
THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IN
THE NATION AND THE THIRD
LARGEST PROVIDER OF AUTISM
RESEARCH THAT NON GOVERNMENT
FUNDED IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. NEXT THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
THREE OH ONE WHICH FEATURED- I
HAD. GOOD EVENING SURE MEMBERS
CALLS WERE SO THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND WANT TO
THANK THE OFFICERS CONTINUE
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS FOR
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER MISTER MEMBERS JOHN
LINGER ON THE UP AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT FOR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ERIN RIGHT
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINE
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS HOLLY BEEN IN KOTA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
QUALIFIED APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS CREDENTIALING BOARD IN
SUPPORT AS FIFTY FIVE SIX TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JENNA
SOAKED UP FROM ALL THE MEALS
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE AT THE
I THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FINE FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN. FOUR
EIGHT SEVEN. RIGHT THREE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS HEATHER SMITH WITH AUTISM
BEHAVIOR SERVICER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MERION ROUTLEDGE CALLING FROM
AUTISM NEED YOUR SERVICES AND I
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE FOR NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DANIEL IRWIN
OF AUTISM BEHAVIOR SERVICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX
TWO. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR
MISTER NAZARIAN JUST VERY
QUICKLY WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE- AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'VE WORKED ON
AS WELL AND I KNOW YOU
STEADFASTLY NETWORK FOUNDED ON
THE FOR HONOR SEVERAL OCCASIONS
SO- THERE REALLY SHOULDN'T BE A
DISCREPANCY LIKE THIS WHERE IT-
PROMOTES ONE SERVICE OVER
OTHERS. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NO ONE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN A SECOND BY MISS-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION I
AM PLEASED TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO A PROBES. IMMINENCE AND
YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
YES SIR- THAT DOESN'T ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION- MISTER
MISTER OF PORTANTINO CENTER
CENTER PORTANTINO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON YES SORRY MUST
BE A LOW BLOOD SUGAR HERE
SOMETHING SOMETHING'S GOING ON.
IT'S ALL GOOD DOCTOR WHICH I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL HAS GONE
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE A NUMBER
OF TIMES AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS
AREA AND CARRIED IT ONE OF
THOSE TIMES AND SHARES THE SAME
PASSION SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK TO HELP BRING TREATMENT TO
KIDS WHO NEED IT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR- THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY ICE GARCIA GARCIA
HI BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BURKE. CARILLO CARILLO III
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON OF
VOTING. NINE ZERO YOUR BILL HAS
NINE VOTES IT'S OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER DATA
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO THE TOP OF OUR LIST
ENDS AND- GO THROUGH GO TO THE
BILL SO. ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B.
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BATES
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BURKE FLORES
RIVAS RIVAS I. SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WALDRON I. TWELVE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
BRADFORD PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BURKE
LARA NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS. RIVAS AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB FIFTY SIX
CONTACT. YES YOU WERE YEAH YEAH.
THANK YOU- ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
FIFTY SIX PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW.
BURKE FLORA MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I REVERSE REVERSE ICE
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WALDRON NO.
NINETY TWO THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WAS A CONSENT ITEM
S. B. THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE FLORA RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON I TOLD ZERO THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
EIGHTY- SENATOR EGGMAN PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GARCIA GARCIA I.
FLORA. THREE EIGHTY EGGMAN
THREE EIGHTY I KNOW. THE FOR
NOW MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING WALDRON.
WALDRON NO. SENATE THREE AT
THOSE TEN VOTES LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADD ONS- ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB FOUR SIXTY FIVE EGGMAN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GARCIA GARCIA
HI BURKE BURKE HI LAURA. SORRY
FLUORIDE. THE SYRIAN NAZARIAN
AYE RIVAS. RIVAS III SANTIAGO
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE LIFT THE CAR
OPEN OPEN THE ROLE AT COFFEE
ABSENT MEMBERS GIVES ME GARCIA
GARCIA I BURKE BURKE I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON AYE
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER NINE- S. B. TWO
FORTY FIVE PLEASE- LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE DIDN'T DO EIGHT I'M SORRY
HELLO SIR WE DID DO A SEIZE ME
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR GLAZER PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL OR OPEN THE PRO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT. MAYES.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
BURKE. BURKE NOT VOTING. FLORA
FLOOR I'M SORRY NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I
RIVAS RIVAS I SANTIAGO. I'VE
NEVER EIGHT SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR. SANTIAGO HI. ELEVEN ZERO
ELEVEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS RIVAS
AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI.
ELEVEN TO TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THREE ELEVEN THREE OKAY
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TEN. OF
THE BILL IS OUT EXCUSE ME- ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB THREE OH SIX
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOW BURKE BURKE HI.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
REQUEST RIVAS III SANTIAGO. SB
THREE OH SIX ITEM NUMBER TEN.
SANTIAGO HI THANK YOU. THE ITEM
NUMBER OF THE TWO I'M SORRY
TWELVE THIRTY TO TWELVE THE TO
THINK HERE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
S. B. TWO FIFTY FIVE OF MISTER
PORTANTINO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES
BURKE BURKE I RIVAS RIVAS HI
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI. FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO BY MISTER PORTANTINO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES BURKE
BURKE HI LAURA. FLORIDA VOTING.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ELEVEN
ZERO SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU AND
THE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GARCIA
GARCIA I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW
FLORA. FOR NOW MAIENSCHEIN
ASIAN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
HIGHNESS ARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING. AND THE FINAL
BILL I'M SORRY GO AHEAD OF WAY
FOR THE NUMBER. ELEVEN A TWO
ELEVEN TWO THANK YOU. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BY CENTER SKINNER PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAYES BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NOW CORREA CARILLO HI FLORA.
LARA NO MAIENSCHEIN A CONCERT
NOT VOTING FLORIDA VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I REQUEST
RIVAS I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
ELEVEN TO- LEVIN A ONE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY WE'VE
GONE THROUGH EVERYTHING. ONCE
HERE WILL GO THROUGH AGAIN- I
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BURKE
BURKE I FLORA LARA I. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIVE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE
BURKE I LAURA LAURA I FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FIFTY SIX PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES BURKE. BURKE I.
FLORA FLOOR NO. I REMEMBER FOR
SB THREE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I.
TWELVE TO THREE OKAY THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB THREE SIX
I'M SORRY. THAT WAS TWELVE
THREE. RIGHT I'M SORRY ELEVEN
AT THREE ELEVEN THREE OKAY
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
THREE SIXTEEN. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BURKE. BURKE EYEING FLORA. LARA
I. SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO OKAY AND I REMEMBER FIVE
SB THREE EIGHTY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THERE ARE NO ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE- PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO FIVE
FIFTEEN ZERO AND ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
FIFTEEN ZERO. I REMEMBER EIGHT-
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES. THAT'S IT OKAY
ELEVEN I THINK OF THEM I THINK
WE ARE GOOD ACTORS ARE CORRECT
YES OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT
I THINK WE ARE COMPLETE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EVERYBODY AND WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE.